impact of suela bravaman departing the
job of Home Secretary she wrote a pretty
stinging resignation letter didn't she
would those people who are on the right
of the party who've been supportive of
Sue Ella bravaman and Liz trust be
changing their minds now
well that's the question that we just
don't quite know the answer to certainly
some of those that I was talking to from
that Wing we're not prepared to hand it
over to Rishi sulak uh 48 hours ago they
didn't see why the person who lost in
the contest just six weeks ago in the
face of the members should now pick up
the crown and take the country on a
really a different economic course from
the one that they that they that they
thought was necessary
um uh you have others like Nadine Doris
who are publicly now campaigning for
Boris Johnson to return he of course has
a mandate of thought having won the 2019
general election but also having been
deforestrated by Tory MPS who who
essentially uh out of Shame felt that he
couldn't stay in office because of uh
events earlier in the year involving
parties and uh one of his former allies
so that that gives you a sense of the
sort of lack of easy options but but the
hard-headed question you're completely
right Anna the hard headed question for
the conservative party right now is can
you put your personal and political
differences aside can you put what
faction you're in aside for the good of
the country and for the sake of a smooth
transition now actually maybe overnight
maybe the spectacle of what we saw
yesterday which which people haven't
really seen before maybe all of that
cumulatively has focused people's minds
forced people uh into thinking
differently to how they did before but
you know it it's things are moving very
very fast and everybody's looking for
easy neat solutions that that frankly
there aren't and and and that's what
makes it that's what makes this uh so
dramatic and so uncertain
um because whether it's Boris Johnson
supporters wanting him back whether it's
Zoella Brotherman supporters thinking
that they have a legitimate shot at the
top because they think she'd be quite
popular with members whether it's those
who think that the answer is somewhere
between Rishi sunak and Penny board and
either them teaming up uh uh or some
agreement where there's overwhelming
backing for one of the two uh that you
know the pressure the enormous pressure
etched on MP's faces at the moment you
can see starting to change calculations
in the way uh that they that they that
they think and I think um that um and I
think that that is absolutely I I think
that that evolving uh thinking amongst
Tory MPS is just very very evident at
the moment at this point where uh there
is huge uncertainty uh but with Granbury
and number 10. it feels like we're
taking a step forward
Sam for the moment thanks very much
indeed well let's bring in now our
political editor Beth Rigby who's in
Westminster for us this afternoon so
Beth we understand that so gray and
Brady is talking to the Prime Minister
Liz truss at number 10 right now what do
you make of that
well Anna as Sam was reporting it's
thought that the Prime Minister asked
for that meeting but where are we at as
I understand it yesterday as far as the
chair of the 22 committee so growing
Brady was concerned uh any moves to
agitate to remove or try to say to Liz
trust that the game was up was not
something that uh the chair of the back
bench committee I was told was looking
at indeed what I got a sense of talking
to a number of senior MPS yesterday was
that there was a sense that October 31st
you'll remember this date that's when
Jeremy Hunt the new Chancellor is about
to lay out the government's long-term
fiscal plan with all the tax and
spending commitments that this
government is meant to be making there
was a sense to give the Prime Minister
some breathing space up to that point
that it was important I was told by one
figure to keep everything calm in order
to keep them markets calm you'll
remember sacking quasi-core tang and
then that Announcement by Jeremy Hunt
that he was pretty much junk in the
whole mini budget really did seem to
settle the markets at least what it
didn't settle was MPS and since uh that
uh that since those conversations I had
yesterday what you saw last night in the
Commons was absolute chaos and it seems
that that could have hastened this
process potentially uh for Liz trust and
the reason I say that is overnight as
we've been reporting we've gone from six
MPS publicly calling for her to go to
14. I was already told a week ago that
there are a substantial number of
letters of no confidence going in to Sir
Graham and if you want a sense Anna of
how people are feeling this is a
minister a servant Minister who backed
Liz truss in the leadership contact
contests
sending me a message today saying this
morning we live day by day who am I cat
kidding actually we live hour by hour
the party has had a collective breakdown
as I understand it uh from a source in
number 10 Liz truss has brought gray and
Brady in to quote this figure to take
the temperature of the party the Prime
Minister now assessing where is she can
she command this government how long can
she carry on a former cabinet minister
told me yesterday we know how this is
now going to end what we don't know is
the speed of the departure and that I
guess is now what everyone is focusing
on what is that conversation behind the
door what might the Prime Minister
decide to do it's very very uncertain
but that she's called the chair of the
back bench 22 committee into Downing
Street to take the temperature of a
party in mutiny
it suggests to me that he won't have any
good news when he speaks to Liz Truss
and Beth are
the measures that determine whether she
stays or is this ultimately down to her
and the level of pressure that she's
under
There Are Rules There Are Rules Anna but
the thing about the rules is the rules
can be changed in in moments of
unprecedented
um turmoil and the rules are as such
that a stand-in prime minister a new
prime minister would not face a
confidence vote for a year what triggers
a confidence vote for the conservative
parliamentary parties if 15 of MPS on
the current number of MPS that's 54 MPS
right to Sir growing Brady saying they
have no confidence in the Prime Minister
now under the current rules even if he
got 54 letters at the moment grown Brady
under rules wouldn't trigger a ballot
but it's pretty much a kind of a settled
view amongst MPS that if the situation
is such they will change the rules to
potentially hold a confidence vote in
the Prime Minister now there's lots of
talk yesterday about where Mike Row and
Brady changed the threshold would it be
a third of MPS that would be about 119
MPS would it be a majority of MPS that
wanted that confidence vote now as I
understand it from two different sources
that was not decided there hasn't been
no decision on that but what is what is
clearer is that for sir gray and Brady
if he has an absolute outpouring of MP
saying this cannot go on it's
unsustainable it has to end he does have
to go to the Prime Minister and say you
cannot command your party you therefore
cannot remain in office look a gov a
prime minister that can't get her policy
platform through who cannot command her
party who has no Authority in her party
and I think that was laid completely
bare last night in those chaotic scenes
in the House of Commons really it's very
difficult to see how she can stay on and
I think behind that door now there will
be discussions about what the
Parliamentary party uh what Liz truss
does next but I think
quite frankly the conversations that I
have had even from those that have
backed her and supported her there is a
sense that this uh debacle has reached
the point of no return everyone I speak
to now is talking about when not if it's
very hard to find anyone who could say
in good faith that Liz trust can lead
the conservative parties into the next
general election
and what about the cabinet how crucial
is the their view or their support
well the cabinet's always crucial Anna
and you saw when Boris Johnson was
eventually deposed and very reluctantly
agreed to stand down because he
literally had no choice he had dozens of
government resignations that a cabinet
resignations can trigger departures if
cabinet ministers began to resign now it
really would be game up for Liz tras but
I think there's a few things going on
amongst those I talked to
um that that Richie sunak has been
tarnished by the legacy of being
perceived as the person that brought
Boris Johnson down this is a real
genuine block now on Rishi sunak trying
to take over as prime minister because
there are the johnsonites on the benches
they will literally never forgive him
for that so I think there's a few things
going on I think that no one in cabinet
wants to be the person to scene to be
wheeled in the knife Penny Morgan
clearly has leadership Ambitions as now
does Jeremy Hunt they won't want to be
seen to be making the situation any
worse they probably also think that this
is reaching an inevitable conclusion
anyway so why jump now and I think the
second thing to say about it is that Liz
truss like Boris Johnson filled her
cabinet with people that were her Die
Hard backers that had backed her in the
leadership race that I do logically
agree read with her she has now of
course changed that by bringing in
Jeremy Hunt and Grant Sharps but yeah
it's not as if there's a big ground
swell of those that might walk now I
should say there are two ministers who
we think are on resignation watch one of
them is Kami badanok and the other is
Kip moth house so it's not as if they're
people that aren't uh
potentially thinking about it but at the
moment we have had no resignations
that's obviously something we are
watching there's also a view about
swella bravaman in that she resigned and
as we reported yesterday in a highly
critical letter to the Prime Minister
openly challenging her and criticizing
both her record and her conduct in
office uh swella bravaman now on the
back benches and many people in the
party have said to me that this is
swella bravaman now positioning to try
and take a Tilt at the leadership she
would be the next candidate if you like
of the right of the party so Zoella
bravman didn't resign to challenge
directly Liz truss's leadership yet she
didn't say I'm resigning because I think
I haven't got confidence in you she
resigned over a breach of the
ministerial code but there's no doubt
that she will now be an agitator on the
back benches for Liz Truss
okay Beth for the moment thanks very
much indeed we'll come back to you
shortly but let's just rejoin Sam coats
who's in central Lobby
um at Parliament for us now who's got
someone with him Sam that's right
um it's quite a day to be a Tory MP so
let's ask what it feels like right now
Natalie elfick
um what do you think is going on well I
mean I think the prime minister's in a
very difficult place I think it's been
an extremely difficult 24 hours I think
it's really important that she sets out
her priorities as prime minister and
that we you know move forward as a party
you talk to a lot of colleagues do you
think Graham Brady is in there saying
she's lost the conservative party
well I think a lot of colleagues like
like me who actually voted for her in
the leadership challenge are now left a
bit disappointed and a little let down
over what seems to be a change of
priorities from those she set out in the
leadership election you know it's been a
very difficult two or three weeks we've
seen a number of changes and for you
know someone in a seat like mine in
Dover and deal it issues the small boats
she said it was a top priority and key
priority immigration would be kept under
control that that'd be gross and also
that we would still be a compassionate
party looking after the vulnerable and
the old I think it's been a very
difficult couple of weeks should she go
well I think that she must set out what
her priorities are as the Prime Minister
and as the leader of the party
particularly in light of the change
that's happened since she was elected
under the priorities I don't understand
that she set out her priorities on
Monday in an interview she set out her
priorities on Wednesday at Prime
Minister's questions how many more times
do you need her to set up her priorities
well I think that you've really hit the
nail on the head that there has been
shifting Sam's in terms of the
government's positions now governments
do change positions and there are
sometimes good reasons for that but
fundamentally she was she was selected
and elected in the summer on a clear
package of priorities that I feel were
right for my constituency on the country
those are the priorities I'd like to see
us pursuing as a party and they're the
ones that are important to me
um are you at least thinking that if it
gets that point somebody should somebody
should take over who that somebody
should be and do you have any favorites
well I think the immediate priority is
to see what happens next in terms of
this next period it was an extraordinary
day yesterday in Parliament
extraordinary set of events yesterday
evening in the House of Commons in the
voting I think she is in a very
difficult position I think she's in a
bit of a bind and I think she needs to
set out how she's going to move forward
from that there does seem to be a chance
she may not even last the next few days
what odds would you give her well I
think these sorts of situations there's
always you know fevered speculation all
around I think the the key thing though
is to see what she's going to do what
she's going to set out how she thinks
she move forward I'm still open to
listening to her I voted for her in the
summer and I would want her to succeed
but right now I think she's in a very
difficult spot I think as she said
herself they've been quite serious
mistakes that have been made over her
Premiership so far and I think it's
absolutely vital that she really
addresses that now you're prepared to
give her a bit of time
but it's not clear that there is time
because in 11 days the chancellor must
set out the very very difficult
decisions about public spending that are
necessary in order to maintain the
confidence of the market in uh UK PLC I
mean isn't actually your position a bit
irresponsible well I think we're in a
position where the markets have more
stabilized
welcome because we want to make sure
they stabilize because they know October
31st is coming and there are lots of
decisions massively difficult government
decisions to be made in the next 11 days
but you want to give let's try some time
well I think it's absolutely vital that
that the markets continue to be in this
in this better situation but I also
think as I've said that it is vital that
she addresses the issues that have
Arisen and it clearly matters have
accelerated in the last 24 hours I mean
yesterday was a dreadful day in
parliamentary terms a lot of colleagues
are very very concerned I share some of
those concerns I think it is really
important that this is addressed and
finally just how does it feel to be a
Tory MP today well there's a lot of good
things that we've actually done
particularly over the last week or so
with the NGC support package with the
public
element and a lot of it is really really
good news so I want us to get away from
the drama and concentrate on the things
that we're delivering for the country
that's what I was elected to do that's
what I believe we as the government were
elected to do we've got that 2019
Manifesto let's move forward and deliver
it Natalie elfic there not quite ready
to say the Prime Minister should go
despite a very very difficult few hours
and days back to you
Sam thanks very much indeed and while
you were speaking Sam we did actually
see the Deputy Prime Minister Therese
coffee going into number 10 via the back
door so we saw that during that
interview and just to say as Sam was
saying we know that the gray and Brady
is speaking to the prime minister at
number 10 right now the chair of the
1922 committee at number 10 have
confirmed that and said it was a meeting
that Liz truss herself had requested
we've had the further line now but says
that she wanted to take the temperature
of the party so that's the latest on
that meeting that's underway inside at
Downing Street right now let's just um
stop talking about Liz trust for a
moment because there is some other
breaking news that's come out of
parliament today in the last few minutes
the defense secretary Ben Wallace has
been speaking in the comments about
Ukraine and an incident involving an RAF
aircraft and Russian fighter jet so
here's what he said
but an unarmed RAF
rc-135 rivet joint a civilian I start
aircraft on routine Patrol over the
Black Sea was interacted with by two
Russian armed su-27 fighter aircraft it
is not unusual for aircraft to be
shadowed and this day was no different
during that interaction however it
transpired that one of the su-27
aircraft
released a missile in the vicinity of
the RAF rivet joint Beyond visual range
the total time of the interaction
between the Russian aircraft and the
rivet joint was approximately 90 minutes
the patrol completed and the aircraft
returned to its base
in light of this potentially dangerous
engagement I've communicated
oh that's because you need a jacket here
um
guys in the gallery
can you turn the volume down to your
side I actually can't put my earpiece in
because it's so loud
[Music]
don't worry about
it every time you talk to me
it's nothing personal
right let's do it
oh God I can't
can't hear now
sorry guys I don't want a bit of pain
but I know you can't hear
you guys I think it's at that end
there's a car coming
guys
so if you could turn the program level
up that would be great so I don't know
why but you're considerably louder than
ah you are so much louder than the
program
like incredible
it's going in number nine
so I can't hear the program but if you
speak to me
incredibly loud
so maybe just turn the program up and
I'll give you a thumbs up
fine let's leave it there
so you're gonna go for your break
oh cooler thing can Nick me about the
pool shop
sorry
twice
thank you
now guys if you I actually can't do this
not seen them come out Anita
um he went in there a week while ago at
the prime minister's invitation she
asked him to come up here which I think
is number 10 trying to tell us all to
calm down a bit this isn't necessarily
sugary and Brady going in there to tell
the Prime Minister the game's up and she
needs to go
however
the mood of the party
from my judgment speaking to Tory MPS
over the past few hours in the past few
days is incredibly bleak there are a
growing number of MPS who are just
banging their heads off tables now
saying we've no idea how this is going
to continue it's totally attainable how
can the Prime Minister win any Authority
back
the question over the next few hours is
whether that leads to something and I
know that might sound like a slightly
ridiculous hypothetical question but
there's two things that you can't forget
today when all the speculation about the
prime minister's future swirls one is
nobody has decided who should succeed
there's a big disagreement among
different wings of the conservative
party about who that should be secondly
Tony MPS who want to get rid of her
don't necessarily know how they want to
do it one of the options is to create a
system whereby MPS would just choose
their next leader and forego any go to
the membership the conservative
membership on their next leader but
that's not been agreed yet and there are
some saying calm down a bit let's not
move too fast too soon so we're keeping
an eye out for to Brady we're trying to
find out what's going on in that meeting
my my sense is that it's a sign off how
Grim the picture is that he's in there
but I also get the impression he's not
in there just now to tell the Prime
Minister it's over
yes that is what a lot of conservative
MPS are whacking out they've been doing
it for a few days actually
the kind of question and I think this
might be happening certainly amongst the
small number of MPS I've spoken to some
who were maybe prepared to give the
Prime Minister the benefit they doubt so
everything that happened yesterday the
home secretary's resignation the chaos
in Parliament with votes last night know
the threat to remove the whip from some
MP the entrance to the nose so you
always cross over your colleagues there
as I was coming out there was what
looked like a scuffle happening Jacob
Reese moggs was in the center of it
there was a deputy prime minister there
were some other people around and there
was uh what looked like at the time two
MPS that were extremely distraught I I
stood to one side to see what was
happening to see if it needed any
assistance and what became clear is that
there was one MP in particular who to me
looked like he was distraught and
emotional who was clearly feeling
conflicted and not wanting to go through
the lobbies and they were putting
enormous pressure on him to the extent
where both his arms at one point were
grabbed and someone put their palm of
their hand on his back and manhandled
him I would describe through into the
lobby area now he didn't there were
plenty of us around that if he'd called
out for help we would have intervened
but clearly he was not comfortable and
it was not a pleasant experience and
seeing that sends chills I think down
many of our spines that that maybe the
votes are not fair and free and that
people are not treated in the way that
you would expect in a democracy
well and I do know that there is coffee
the Deputy Prime Minister and the
business secretary Jacob reese-mogg have
denied any wrongdoing and it's true
isn't it that the MP that Chris Bryant
was talking about yesterday and
suggesting had been manhandled has
tweeted no one pushes me around
um there's also an investigation that
has been launched into this so are you
at all reassured
well look there will be an investigation
um Chris Bryant tweeted a photo and you
can see me uh in um just just watching
observing in the corner there
um we know what we saw and numerous of
us saw it of course people will not want
to be framed as um as being bullied um
and I can totally understand why people
would
um not want that uh that accusation as
either the the victim or the perpetrator
but what was clear last night is there
was some nasty business happening I mean
even to the extent where the chief whip
kind of resigned and unresigned and the
deputy chief whip resigned and
unresigned and apparently the Prime
Minister was having to kind of plead
with the chief whip at one point this is
no government that's not how you run the
country this is chaos and it's dangerous
and okay MPS can stick up for themselves
to some extent but their job is meant to
be able to speak out fairly uh freely
and without fear or favor for their
constituents and what I'm starting to
see is that that is diminishing now an
inquiry will go some way it will
probably stop that kind of behavior
happening again because people will know
the eyes are on them but what really
needs to happen is those people who
think that you can run your country by
bullying and bravado without much talent
the people that we've got in power at
the moment I'm afraid who have crashed
the economy and destroyed many people's
futures in the uh with with mortgage
rates going up etc those are the people
that need to suffer the consequences of
this through losing their seats in a
general election and we need to move to
that quickly
okay well I'll come on to that in just a
moment and we will hear more about this
from the findings of inquiry no doubt uh
those people that that you're accusing
of Behaving Badly will have their say as
well but the fundamental issue was this
was a vote about fracking wasn't it uh
called for by labor and there are a
number of Tory MPS would have been
sympathetic to the labor position and
yet you didn't win the vote I mean that
that's the fundamental issue here isn't
it yeah look
I usually lose votes at the moment
because I'm in the opposition and the
government has a majority and they're
used to losing votes I have sat through
the brexit debates the illegal
paragation of parliament where we
protested on those things you you know
and your viewers will know that I'm not
someone that
um that just sits down meekly in
Parliament I the rgbaji of parliament is
an important part of our Democratic
process I've got nothing wrong with that
but what I do have something wrong with
is the idea that first of all the
government is so incompetent it turns
this into a confidence vote and clearly
there's the Fallout from that but
secondly the MPS are so distraught that
you are having other MPS intimidating
them or making it look like
um intimidation is happening that is not
that is not right now I've never seen
that even through the brexit debates
when there were tears
um I have not quite seen that level of
intimidation by um by the government
okay well Lloyd Russell wall we
appreciate your time thanks very much
indeed for talking to us today
and let's get some reaction to that and
the news of Liz truss's meeting with sir
Graham Brady I'm joined now by the
former Attorney General and former
Shadow Home Secretary Dominic grieve a
very good afternoon to you Dominic Reeve
thanks so much for joining us uh first
of all your reaction to What Lloyd
Russell Moyle was saying just now I
don't know if you managed to hear it he
was concerned about some of the scenes
he witnessed last night in the voting
Lobby what do you make of what's been
said
it certainly sounded chaotic I have to
say that in the course of my time in
Parliament I've seen similar things
before on difficult votes
um what seems to be so unusual about
last night was that um it was unclear
whether this was in fact confidence uh
emotional confidence was going to be
treated as a confidence matter or not
um all that suggests a certain degree of
chaos but I have seen people being
physically pushed into uh the uh the
lobbies I'm afraid before and it's not
very edifying and it shouldn't happen
you say a certain degree of chaos what
do you think that says about the state
of your party at the moment if anything
the state of the party at which I was
formerly an MP uh until we partied
company is woeful uh under somebody who
has conservative inclinations it's
painful to watch but there's a certain
inevitability about this the party is
fragmenting it's fragmented obviously
over brexit uh that started the
fragmentation I thought saw eventually
people like myself being forced out but
what's more chilling in a way is that it
is not remaking itself subsequently
firstly because he'd had a charlatan as
a prime minister and therefore it
eventually had to get rid of him and
then it's allowed itself effectively to
be hijacked by a small group within it
um with ideological views which are
broken down of the first Challenge and
the Prime Minister who was part of that
ideology has then tried to completely
reorientate uh part of the party with
which is in one sense commendable but as
found by doing it she's been turned by
by the sections of the party that had
previously supported her and unless you
can have a coherent government with a
policy
you cannot carry on in government and
and so it's it's High Noon either they
are prepared to back uh Liz truss or
they are prepared to put in somebody
very quickly and without the
intervention of the membership to take
over and back that person all quite
frankly it's right it'll have to be a
general election because the king's
government can't be carried on
what do you think should happen
well I think
seeing the nature of the emergency and
economic problems we've got and a a
conservative government led by a
sensible prime minister surrounded by a
group of people who apply some common
sense yeah uh to the problems that we
are facing would be a good first step
but the question is whether the
Parliamentary conservative party is
capable of delivering that and as I say
they're looking into the abyss it seems
to me and rightly the public and
everybody looking in will say what on
Earth is going on and uh they've got to
make up their mind what it is they want
this Charles said prime minister's
questions just well it feels like an age
ago but I think it was just yesterday
I'm a fighter not a quitter do you think
that she will go
I have no idea whether she'll go there's
no point in fighting whilst the king's
government is not actually being carried
out it's Anarchy and the government will
be paralyzed and incapable of operation
at that point bluntly they owe a duty to
the public to hand over to somebody else
who can govern so there is an obligation
we talk a lot about Party politics in
this country but there is actually an
obligation over the Bob Party politics
about the national interest
and it is not in the National interest
to be watching this sort of unraveling
and if the conservative party has really
got to the point where they've fallen
out into factions and they can't
actually identify a common point then it
is the end for them uh but if on the
other hand they can do something about
it they've got to do it very quickly
do you have a view on who that candidate
could be to replace her should she be
removed no I don't because I think there
are a number of possibilities and I
would wish there has a a choice but what
does appear to be quite clear is that
this trust herself is in great
difficulty delivering that now she has
carried out a complete some assault on
her policies and appears to be dependent
on a different group in the party one I
have to say seems to me to be much more
sensible but the problem is that I don't
think her position is sustainable
she might say the country doesn't need
another change of prime minister she
might say I've admitted I made mistakes
but I've reversed them I've sacked
people close to me for the better good
of a functioning government she might
argue and she would say the markets are
being restored to some level of calm
what would you make if she did put those
arguments forward as a reason for
staying on those are all completely
legitimate points and I recognize that
and she's entitled to make them but then
the question is is that sustainable and
the sustainability of that change is
dependent on whether she can carry the
conservative parliamentary party with
her if she can't then simply continuing
is not an option equally then the
responsibility on the Parliamentary
party as to whether or not they can
identify an alternative leader and prime
minister if they can't do that
immediately and they certainly can't go
out to the membership in those
circumstances then it is the end and I
have to say it is an end which they have
dug the hole for themselves relentlessly
over a period of four or five years
and how should that process be
coordinated if there is this push for a
new leader is this down to it's a Graham
Grady Brady speaking to as many people
as possible or is it down to Cabinet
colleagues what's your view
both if they're going to exercise
responsibility and also individual
members of the conservative
parliamentary party that's their Duty in
these circumstances as I say are they
going to rise to the occasion I have no
idea
okay well Dominic grieve former Shadow
Home Secretary thanks very much indeed
for joining us very interesting to get
your take on it
so let's uh cross over to Downing Street
shall we now our chief political
correspondent John Craig is for us there
and and John behind you in that street a
meeting going on in Downing Street
between it's a gray and Brady the chair
of the 1922 committee and the Prime
Minister do you imagine we'll hear
anything of what it's about later on in
the day we may hear from Sir Graham yes
so we may hear a statement from number
10. I can tell you that sir gray and
Brady arrived here just over an hour ago
now so he's been in there for an hour
now to raise coffee the Deputy Prime
Minister joined them about about half an
hour ago now there's a car just arriving
looks like a government car who is this
who is that
is
not sure who that was
oh is the conservative party chairman
sir Jake Berry I'm told well we really
are in full crisis mode now because
we've got the chairman of the 1922
committee we've got the Deputy Prime
Minister and we've now got the chairman
of the conservative party inside number
10 for what are clearly prices talks now
the fact that the chairman of the
party's been brought in suggests that
there is going to be some sort of
involvement of the party some sort
perhaps election vote of confidence
coronation you wouldn't have the
chairman of the party in there if there
wasn't going to be some activity
involving the voluntary party the
voluntary party of course who put Liz
truss into uh Downing Street so the
chairman of the 1922 committee number 10
as we've been reporting
um have been saying that the PM
requested the meeting uh to take the
temperature of the Parliamentary party
well I'd say the temperature of the
Parliamentary party is reaching boiling
point
Malcolm tents on the Tory back benches
have been telling me all week that sir
Graham's got 100 plus letters that is
hotly disputed by many other
conservative MPS I spoke to Sir Graham
just after the 1922 committee last night
when Jeremy Hunt by all accounts put in
a very reassuring performance I said to
Sir Graham have you had a meeting with
the pm today that was yes last night he
smiled in that wonderful inscrutable way
of his and said ah that would be telling
anyway it's perhaps there was no meeting
but there certainly is now he's been in
there for over an hour to raise coffee
Deputy Prime Minister two jobs to raise
because she's also the health secretary
one of her ministers Caroline Johnson is
having to make a statement about the
awful news from the Kent hospital all
those baby deaths as we speak uh no
doubt opposition MPS will say it
suggests that perhaps she's not a
full-time health secretary she's only
part-time I'm just looking over there
just in case somebody is leaving when
sir Graham arrived at about quarter to
12 he he didn't come in the front door
he arrived by the back door
um he walked briskly under a huge
umbrella they were expecting him because
he was just going straight in no
security and now the most recent
addition is as Sir Jake Berry's just
been given a Knighthood in the last few
days actually
um the um
the the uh just read it I'm just oh I'm
just reading something very significant
from our political editor Beth Rigby a
senior Party Source has told Beth they
understand any change of rules to impose
a candidate or change thresh thresholds
for nominations would need to go to the
party board so
um that suggests why um Wise Wise Jake
Berry's gone in there just let me repeat
that it may well be that they are then
discussing changes to the rules senior
party sources have told Beth Rigby any
change of rules to impose a candidate or
change the thresholds for nominations
would need to go to the party board
that's why the party chairman is in
there so
um it's looking pretty dicey for even
more dicey for the Prime Minister I'm
told actually that this is um sir Jake
Barry's second visit to Downing Street
this morning
there is also
um another visitor here earlier today
was Wendy Morton the chief whip who of
course was I was about to say presiding
over that Fiasco in the voting lobbies
last night but she wasn't really
presiding over it at all it was all the
shambles
um she at one point was said to have not
been told by number 10 they were
changing from a confidence vote to a not
a confidence vote then in the middle of
the night the middle of the night a
statement from number 10 was saying it
was always a confidence vote some
official in in number 10 gave the wrong
information anyway just to sum up
crisis talks chairman of the 22 Deputy
Prime Minister chairman of the party in
with the beleaguered prime minister as
the number of MPS calling for Liz trust
to go continues to grow
John thank you so as John was saying the
crisis talks underway in number 10. so
what's the reaction to that amongst Tory
MPS are Deputy political editor Sam
Coates is with one of them in Parliament
Central Lobby Sam
that's right I'm here with Cheryl Murray
uh conservative MP
um currently the Deputy Prime Minister
is in number 10 Graham Brady's in number
10 the chairman of the parties in number
10. should they be telling Liz trust to
go
well I've been very clear this morning
that I've put a letter into Graham Brady
it was done with a very heavy heart Sam
I backed Liz truss
and I've I've given all week to reflect
on what we are seeing but last night the
organizational
situation last night actually made me
start to think very seriously I then
slept on it and this morning I spoke to
my Association chairman
because clearly you don't do something
like that when people send you here you
have to consult with them at least
and we all came to the same conclusion
unfortunately and and it is with a heavy
heart that I wrote the letter and what
did you see last night that tips you
over the end well I think when you see
Chief whips um and
coming out shouting saying they've
resigned and then suddenly at half past
one in the morning you see Downing
Street going back no they haven't
resigned they're still here and it just
causes confusion it does nothing for our
image here it makes people feel very
very confused and it doesn't send the
message to the rest of the country that
we are in control and I think it's now
time for us to choose somebody that all
the MPS can get behind
and can be put to the membership for
them to endorse and then we get on and
start governing the country do you have
an idea of who you would like to see be
that person there isn't any individual
person but that person must be somebody
who can bring both sides of the party
together a message for my colleagues and
I'm somebody who backlits trusts but a
message for all of us on either side so
we might not get everything we want
but we have to perhaps compromise in
some way and that's every single one of
us and and did I get that right that you
think it should go to the membership
there should be six weeks of Hiatus
while MPS choose that to watch it happen
next right look at uh back to Michael
Howard I don't know whether you can
remember when Michael Howard was chosen
but he was chosen by the MPS but the
members endorsed him and they could have
rejected him if they'd have wanted when
Andrea ledson pulled out of the race
with Theresa May Theresa May was put to
the members and the members could
endorse her or reject it reject her and
so if we got to that sort of situation
um it's not ideal
but I think for the stability and
continuing governance of the country
that may be the best thing to do I mean
I I hear lots of different people put
lots of different options forward Rishi
sunac Penny Morden sowella braveman they
they all seem to want to shot it at this
I mean it it actually could get messy
and quite dragged out for quite a long
time but we could do that selection in
private and not in the wider country is
that the conversation that's going on at
the moment I have no idea I used to be
on the executive of the 1922 I'm no
longer on the executive of the 1922 they
are the people who will set the rules so
you should really ask one of them
um
there is 11 days until the chancellor
stands up to make some of the most
difficult decisions in this country in
terms of spending cuts do you think Liz
trust can stay through that period to to
make those decisions or does she need to
go immediately so that the different
prime minister can make the choices for
the country well if Liz trust left
sister it would move I believe to the
Deputy Prime Minister
to be a caretaker prime minister or a
selection for a replacement went on I'm
not 100 certain that that would happen
but I think that's normally what would I
my question is more do you think Liz
trust can be trusted to do the difficult
decision over the next 10 days I'm not
saying does she have to go now I'm
certainly not saying Liz trust is
untrustworthy I think that's the wrong
description I just think she is now the
wrong person for the job in one word how
do you feel this morning
I feel very very
um upset because I love my party I like
Liz and it's not it doesn't give me any
pleasure whatsoever to have submitted a
letter to Sir Graham Brady thank you
very much indeed Cheryl Murray a
heartfelt call for Liz truss to stand
down from one of her big supporters
Sam thanks very much indeed and just to
let you know that while Sam was speaking
there it's been confirmed that at the
15th Tory MP to publicly call for the
prime minister to go has revealed
themselves this is Jill Mortimer she
says she was not called in prime
minister's questions yesterday and so
submitted a letter of no confidence to
segrem Brady and to Graham Brady the
chair of the 1922 Committee of course
inside Downing Street at the moment
having talks with the Prime Minister
Downing Street Keen to stress that this
was at the request of the Prime Minister
who wanted to take the temperature of
the party
thank you
good afternoon it's one o'clock you join
us live as the prime minister is in that
meeting with the chair of the 1922
committee sir gray and Brady inside
Downing Street
so we can see the door to number 10 as
those talks take place with a further
anger directed at the Prime Minister
today as 15 MPS have now reportedly
submitted letters of no confidence in
her leadership so let's bring in our
political editor Beth Rigby now and Beth
what should we make of the fact that a
meeting is underway in Downing Street
with the Prime Minister and Sir Graham
Brady as well as the chairman of the
conservative party and the Deputy Prime
Minister we understand yes Sandra that's
right
um so now we have in this meeting in
Downing Street not just the chair of the
22 committee but to raise coffee who is
Liz truss's closest Ally and her Deputy
Prime Minister and then the Tory party
chairman Jake Berry has also gone in now
what do we understand that we understand
that Liz truss asked for this meeting
and as I say in a number 10 source told
me that was because she wanted to take
the temperature of the party while we've
been taking it too and you can see that
it is pretty much a burning Fury at the
moment 15 MPS have now submitted their
letters as you just said Anna the lay
latest is Jill Mortimer now Jill
Mortimer is a red wall MP she is the one
that won the Hartley pool by-election at
the height of Johnson's power and Reign
and she has written to Sir Graham saying
it's with deep regret I write to inform
you that I have no confidence in the
competence of the current prime minister
Liz trust I would therefore like to add
my support to the call for a vote of no
confidence so that's 15 MPS publicly
many no doubt privately have sent
letters in and Graham Brady is now I
imagine sitting down with the Prime
Minister explaining to her the situation
and probably running through her options
now just in terms of where are we this
is
so
there
foreign
people
tonight
I think it's 40.
14th mileage
we've got our own count and it's still
on 40s
yeah I am
is going to outline the five-year fiscal
plan we're going to get all the growth
projections independent forecasts from
the office of budget responsibility and
then Jeremy Hunt's going to like set out
a tax and spend plan in order to have to
reassure the markets that this
government is able to balance the books
it's going to be a critical moment in
terms of the market judging the
sustainability of the fiscal plans of
this government and there was a sense I
think that um MPS didn't want to
destabilize number 10 further in the
run-up to that statement after that
statement all bets were off but there
was a sense of let's just keep a lid on
the frenzy and just calm things down as
one person said to me they thought that
the frenzy was bigger in the media if
you like than it was amongst MPS I think
what happened last night changed that
because I think the absolute scenes of
Chaos in the Commons MPS not knowing
whether this was a confidence identify
the fracking motion first it was a
confidence face then someone said it
wasn't then it was again then the whips
are half won in the morning the
government put out a statement saying it
was a confidence vote and that people
would be disciplined if they hadn't got
a reasonable excuse uh one MP texted me
to say it's did they just didn't
understand the logic of that but then
they also said to me of course we don't
but this government to quote this person
is mad that was the view of MPS so the
wheels really came off last night and
the question I think is how long can
these this show keep on the road and I
guess that's what sir Graham Jerome
Jake Berry Therese coffee and the Prime
Minister are hashing out at the moment
the one final thing I would say and I've
been talking a bit probably but the one
final thing I would say is that from
every single person that I have spoken
to that nasala's trust she will try and
hang on in there she will not give up
this position easily from her point of
view she won the battle for number 10
and she wants to remain in post the
question of course now is that her party
don't seem to want to let her but what
is the mechanism by which she departs
and then what comes next
okay Beth for the moment thanks very
much indeed and while Beth was talking
there the 6th 16th MP calling for the
prime minister to go has gone public
Ruth Edwards MP is the 16th to say that
Liz truss should stand down let's go
over now to Parliament Central Lobby and
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
who's there and Sam you've been gauging
the mood of Tory MPS for some time now
not just last night during that vote
which seemed to create such chaotic
scenes but also today as well what are
you picking up
well I thought it was very striking what
you heard from Cheryl Murray a few
minutes ago she saw some of the stuff
that went on in the division lobbies
last night and that's what turned uh
long time Liz trust supporter into
somebody coming on National Television
calling for her to stand down
as Boris Johnson said when the herd
moves it moves and as you see the
numbers of MPS ticking up there is that
sense of movement in Westminster today
not only amongst MPS but also uh amongst
those around Liz truss lots of
conversations about what Therese coffee
is telling the prime minister right now
and I I've talked to a whole series of
MPS the notaries coffee very well and
have been speaking with her regularly in
in recent days and they say that the
Deputy Prime Minister well sort of
bewildered and chill-shocked understand
where we are now and they wouldn't be
surprised if their that Therese coffee
the base of their conversations that
they've had with her in recent days does
actually tell Liz trust at the time is
up and that would be one of the
absolutely critical conversations that's
coming on at the moment because there's
something fairly clinical something sort
of feeling bruising about the formality
around this the potential for change of
the rules the potential for um sorting
out the process of how whatever happens
next happens but there's also the human
element to this Liz truss who was had
setbacks in her career before when she
was moved out of the treasury all those
years ago under uh Theresa May then
fighting her way back up all the way up
to foreign secretary she's been reborn
once she knows what uh problems look
like political problems and political
setbacks look like and that has
motivated her to fight harder for what
she believes in but it's those very
beliefs that have been effectively
rejected by the markets and now rejected
by her party that now leave her to the
with her Premiership absolutely on the
brink as those key figures Jake Barry to
his coffee Graham Brady all surround her
plotting what to do next there is a
strand of thought it goes all the way to
the top of this cabinet that said this
was 24 hours ago that said look we know
what needs to be done but we just can't
do it yet because you do have this
statement on October the 31st we need to
get through that to keep the markets on
site and then yes by all means let's
let's uh let's let's let's look at
whether or not to do what we need to do
um but I I just wonder whether or not
the political moods have shifted since
then
um and uh and the events of last night
which I think
talking to everybody they found quite
traumatic I mean it it was the
disorganization the aggression the
uncertainty the mishandling the
miscommunication the endless excuses
that you got I think it's all of those
things did not make them think that this
was a government that had sufficient
grip to make all of it recoverable
almost every low in politics up until
this point has it there's been a path
back uh to when um uh to to when it was
a bit more sustainable but um but but
with the the key pillars of a government
clearly crumbling the whips office uh
accusations of a junior staff member in
number 10 changing the status of last
night's vote cabinet ministers are odds
cabinet ministers resigning the party
membership more a majority saying she
should go with all of those pillars all
of them have crumbled what does it leave
you with and Cheryl um uh some MPS
saying well we really want uh Liz trust
to come out and set out her vision set
out her platform but she did that she
did that on Monday in interview she did
that on Wednesday in prime minister's
questions and the problem with some of
the ways that she now uses to defend
herself by for instance saying
that the energy price policy was the
right thing to do is she boasts about
that completely ignoring the fact that
it had to be written Rewritten on Monday
morning the plan that she implemented is
not the plan that survived but elements
of the plan she was most proud of like
the fact it went on for two years have
been put in the bin so
and although that's a detail it shows
that even Liz trust does not have the
Armory to Shield herself from the
attacks that she's got because she is
saying things that opposition and her
own MPS point out is transparently not
good enough and transparently not true
and that's that's the bind I think
that's that's why that's where the mark
the sort of political markets have moved
so quickly over the last 24 hours
because when when there's no functioning
bit I think that
um it's not the polls it's that it's the
lack of Direction and certainty that
this government can continue in anything
like a functioning form that is is
moving people from Deep concern to
outright panic and demand for action and
and I understand that those demands for
Action have been pouring into cabinet
ministers phones this morning after last
night uh that's just one factor that has
precipitated what's going on right now
okay Sam for the moment thanks very much
indeed well let's get another view of
what's going on now I'm joined by former
special advisor to Theresa May Giles
Wilkes thanks so much for talking to us
today Giles and as we speak we
understand that there is a meeting going
on behind the door of number 10 between
the Prime Minister and the chair of the
1922 committee the chair of the
conservative party and the Deputy Prime
Minister Therese Coffey you've worked
behind the scenes at number 10 what do
you make of the fact that meeting's
happening well it cannot be good news it
has to mean that they are discussing the
um the when not the if about her leaving
and um and it's entirely out of the
prime minister's control what's really
humiliating here is the prime minister
is obviously normally the person who
decides the choreography of the
government who does what when largely
through a confidence trick nobody
challenges her and it's her job to do
these things now it's in the hands of
MPS handing in letters to the sagran
Brady and other people making tactical
decisions about whether it looks good to
go now later by Christmas and so um it
has to mean she's just they're just
deciding what her exit should be right
in front of her which is just abysmal
she should be safe for a year though
shouldn't she under the rules well the
rules say that yes but I mean the thing
is our constitution is ultimately about
being able to command confidence of a
working majority in the House of Commons
we saw last night that that looked
incredibly ropey that her own mechanisms
for doing this the whipping operation
doesn't seem to work but also once once
MPS are looking at a different circuit
set of circumstances going forward if
they're thinking I'm going to be wiped
out if this carries on much like this
her ability to command that confidence
just doesn't exist so there might be
formal rules that say we cannot actually
command you go but if cigarette and
Brady goes in and says we already have
40 50 of the Parliamentary parties
saying you need to go it's very
difficult to see how she can turn around
and say right I'm staying
I I wonder if you might be able to just
hold fire for a moment Giles we'd love
to come back to you but I just want to
go back to Sam coats who's in central
Lobby for us Sam over to you
I understand that there is going to be a
statement at 1 30 A Downing Street
statement at 1 30. I've just been told
that that suggests that things have
moved much further much quicker I have
no further details at this time but I
think everybody can join the dots of
what's going on I am told by Downing
Street there is a statement at 1 30 that
will no doubt address the question of
Liz truss's feature after those crisis
talks in Downing Street that have seen
Graham Brady chairman of the 1922
committee to raise coffee the Deputy
Prime Minister and Jake Berry the
conservative party chairman after those
crisis talks I Now understand there will
be a statement at 1 30. this lunchtime
looks like we may get a big development
in the future of Liz Truss
okay Sam thanks very much indeed so a
significant piece of breaking news there
from our Deputy political editor Sam
coats there at Downing Street saying
that there will be a statement at 1 30
which will of course bring you uh live
at just 15 minutes away less
um let's go back to Giles Wills a
special advisor to Theresa May Charles
Wilkes no doubt you you've heard that
development what do you make of it yeah
well it has to mean that they're trying
to bring it to a head that it doesn't
mean necessarily she goes this afternoon
but my suspicion is they need to make
some statement about her position coming
up to this really important date on the
31st of October when the markets are
meant to hear how the government gets
its finances back on track I mean I I
can only speculate Sam is closer to the
MPS in there but my suspicion is they'll
be saying she's going and this is the
process that we need to now follow what
makes this really different from when
Theresa May went is although there was
all sorts of really quite dangerous
possibilities around the brexit group
it's in 2019 we're currently in this
situation where people are anxiously
watching the behavior of the bond
markets for how they interpret politics
and that produces a real urgency we saw
earlier this week Jeremy Hunt bringing
forward his announcement of new measures
purely in order to be able to reverse
sentiments in the markets and we've
still got that kind of drum beat going
on if it wasn't for that gigantic
mistake of the mini budget in September
the 23rd and she was just this unpopular
there would maybe be more time to do
this in a deliberative way like we did
in 2019 where there was a couple of
months but right now the longer this
goes on the less people know whether
there is a function in government and
the more that unnerves the people trying
to lend money to us so it's just
accelerating everything
okay Charles well it's really
interesting to get your take on events
uh underway in Downing Street this
afternoon thanks very much indeed for
your time
so let's return then to Sam coats who's
in central lobby with a lot of MPS
Milling around he's um grabbing various
ones of them Sam over to you thank you
very much indeed Anna yes so that news
that there is a Downing Street statement
at 1 30 many many people will be joining
the dots right now let's find out what
an MP makes a bit Roger Gale what do you
think
I don't know what to think Sam accept
that quite clearly Graham Brady sir
Graham Brady uh the leader of the mening
gray suits went to see Mr trust this
morning we know that we obviously don't
at this stage know what was discussed
quite cleared it was a serious
discussion uh that's led to a statement
being made at 1 30 which we now have to
wait and hear the outcome from
the game appears to be moving very fast
indeed I had hoped very much that Mrs
trust would remain in office until at
least October the 31st for the fiscal
statement and the um
the
rest of the material that goes with that
and I still hope that might be the case
but I think we have to wait now until 1
30 and see what is actually said from
dining Street rather than listening to
me or indeed any other backbencher do
you accept that Liz truss has no
long-term future as prime minister
I think that it's probably almost
certainly the case but there has to be a
machinery for dealing with this decently
and in a dignified manner in the
interest of the British people and as
I've said over and over again to you and
to others it is the future of this
country and it's the future of the
British people that matters not the
future of the conservative party or any
other party and we have to focus on that
and make sure that we do the right
things in the interests of the public so
you wanted her to stay in office at
least until October 31st because of this
huge importance of this statement but is
it responsible to effectively allow a
zombie prime minister with very little
political authority to oversee the kinds
of incredibly tense negotiations that
lead to such a difficult set of
decisions of the sort that we were going
to see on October was your position
really sustainable given her lack of
authority yes because I believe that Mrs
trust is now effectively the chairman of
the board and that the chief executive
is Jeremy Hunt who is taking the
executive decisions and driving the
economy in the right direction I believe
and I think that is very important
indeed that we maintain the stability of
Jeremy Hunt's position so that the um
the economic forecasts can be brought
forward
the budget of office responsibility can
do its job and that Jeremy Hunt can do
his and make his statement what next
can there be a contest how is this going
to be decided if Liz trust does go and
granted that we're gonna have to wait to
130 but if she does go how should the
party handle it next we have to handle
it within the Parliamentary party there
has to be a consensus candidate who will
come forward and take the reins and
manage the business and let Jeremy out
of it is to be him as Chancellor and I
hope it will be do the job that has to
be done again as Sam I have to say to
you this is about the future of our
country and the British people not about
the future of any one political party a
Unity candidate in this conservative
party I mean you have met them you have
seen them over the last few days do you
think that is at all possible yeah there
are absolutely there are people who can
do the job and will do the job you know
that and I know that there are people
who can do the job but can you get
sufficient Tory MPS to sign up to that
though without their being ranker and
anger and Division and factionalism
there are people who want Boris Johnson
back there are people who say never seen
that there are people who want Penny
mordant there are other options as well
you make it sound easy it's not it's not
easy but I was in the tea room this
morning and with the respect you weren't
and there is quite clearly a consensus
forming not necessarily about one
particular person at this time
but a consensus that we have to find and
then get behind one person in the
interest of our country and that's what
we'll do
Roger Carl thank you very much indeed so
it sounds like the MPS in the Tea Room
are discussing what needs to happen next
Liz truss has been discussing what needs
to happen next with her closest allies
and Senior Party figures we will find
out what happens next at 1 30.
yes and Sam we can see the lectern being
put out in the street in front of number
10. so all eyes will be on that spot in
the next 10 minutes or so as we await
that statement from number 10 but this
comes after those crunch talks going on
inside of course with key members of the
party
Sam coats I think you can't hear me now
so hello sorry I can now I can now
apologies I was just reminding everyone
of the talks that have been going on
inside Downing Street that that precede
this statement
that's right so you have basically a
trio of the most important people in the
conservative party the Deputy Prime
Minister uh the uh You've Got Jake Berry
the conservative party chairman and
you've got Graham Brady the chairman of
the 1922 that triumvirent all speaking
with Liz truss uh Liz truss of course uh
finding the No Doubt finding the advice
that they're giving difficult uh to take
she has been a fighter uh all her life
it was only oh my God it was only
yesterday that Liz trust told the
commons that she is a fighter not a
quitter but this is a week for u-turns
and it looks as if there is going to be
a major announcement on her future at 1
30. and the the problem for Liz trust
the sort of emotionally difficult thing
I think will be that she's going to have
to talk through in some detail if she
does go what what that departure looks
like and what happens next she's she's
sort of having to sign off on her own
execution and that there is no
politician in the land who would ever
enjoy that process so it's not going to
have been pretty behind the doors in
number 10 so we we wait to find for the
out the conclusion of that
um but I think I think what you heard
from Roger Gale there was was was what
it sounds like when the political
markets moved and it sounds like in the
Tea Room with Tory MPS that he was
talking about speaking to the the
markets have moved and they moved after
yesterday's extraordinary chaos
yesterday was a was a was a day that
could have you know filled A month's
worth of news Cycles you had a U-turn
over the um pensioner triple lock which
was on the table for cuts and then Liz
truss abandoned that there was
uncertainty over what she's going to do
about the Northern Ireland protocol
there was a sacking of a senior Aid
Denmark was the sacking of soella
Braverman for linky leaking confidential
material then there was the massive dust
up with her own party over fracking and
then there were the chaotic scenes in
the voting division lobbies and then
there were the ways that that was
handled and then the resignation and
unresignation of her Chief Whip and the
confirmation the early hours of this
morning that Wendy Morton is still in
post I mean I I I think that just
emotionally and practically and
politically so much so much for
conservative MPS to swallow just in that
period of time uh that I think that
really so many of them now clearly
coming to the conclusion that uh that um
that that she has to go and we look like
we are on calls for a Podium moment at 1
30 and that's when we will find out
exactly what she's got to say but but
this is not a personality drama alone
this is also a massive economic and
political crisis because as I keep
taking us back to they're all the worst
some of the most difficult decisions
that this country is ever going to have
to make and they're now going to have to
make them without a prime minister or
potentially without a prime minister in
place so how on Earth can Jeremy Hunt
the chance slur continued to find
savings somewhere in the order of 40
billion which is not and are that far
away from what George Osborne and David
Cameron did with months of planning very
careful political pitch rolling in a
much calmer economic environment back in
2010 now Jeremy Hunt's got to do that in
10 days possibly without a prime
minister certainly with loads of
politicians looking over their shoulder
cabinet members looking over their
shoulder at whom might inherit the crown
what jobs they're all going to be doing
how hard to fight on various things you
know we are we are landing this crisis
this political crisis at the same time
as we've got an economic crisis and and
and in the end that that's not really to
anybody's benefit now the Alternatives
keep this trust in place uh try and you
know apply a sticking class to solution
well they're not pretty either there
isn't an Easy Way Forward nobody's maybe
saying any of this any any of this is
without downsides but but because of
yesterday and that dog determinism to
have fights the the thing that undeed
Liz trust yesterday was her again her
conviction that she is right to take on
her party to try and force through her
agenda to to face down opponents in her
party to do to do all of that not
recognizing the vulnerabilities of her
political position as she did it and I
think and it's that disconnect I think
ultimately that's been
um her downfall she she seems to she she
has given every impression of thinking
that she can just push things through at
every stage that she hadn't got the
political consensus behind that she
hadn't done the work on and she seemed
to think she could say it and it would
happen whether it was yesterday's fight
whether it was the mini budget whether
it was a legislative program that she
was going to set out and in politics you
can't just say things you need to build
coalitions consensus and get people on
board but she's fought fought people in
her own party from before she was prime
minister during that really rather
devices leadership contest and then not
recognize the bruising the scars the
hurt the upset and the division
and that's one of the things that's led
to this moment
thanks very much indeed well let's cross
now to our political editor Beth Rigby
who's there in Downing Street watching
them get the podium ready for Liz
truss's statement which is due in just
two minutes time so Beth what are you
hearing about what this could contain
and I've been told the prime minister is
about to resign a number 10 Source tells
me it's all over I've been told the
Prime Minister will come out here and
she's going to have to stand down
so quite a moment then Beth this for a
prime minister who's been in place for
just six weeks
indeed it is Anna but as we have been
talking about in recent days it has
become increasingly untenable for Liz
truss the reversal of the mini budget
having to sack her Chancellor then her
home secretary resigning the chaos in
the Commons now as I was saying there
was a hope within the party that she
could hang on in there perhaps till at
least that statement but I have been
told that in a couple of minutes the
Prime Minister who has just been in
office for a few weeks is going to have
to stand down watch for the resignation
of Liz truss As One Source in number 10
told me it's all over
okay and Beth we will keep chatting to
you until we see the Prime Minister
emerging from number 10 but was there a
feeling that the last 24 hours were the
breaking point we saw the departure of
the Home Secretary and then chaotic
scenes in the voting Lobby last night
over a vote on fracking was was that
critical in her stepping down today
yes I think it was Anna because as I was
saying even in the afternoon yesterday
afternoon when I was talking to senior
party figures there was a sense that
growing Brady the chair of the back
bench 22 committee didn't want to cause
more turmoil in the run-up to that
critical fiscal statement that was sort
of mid-afternoon yesterday and then the
thing that really undid the whole
precipice or everything hanging on that
precipice and tipped it over the edge
was that fracking vote and it's always
the things that summer times catch you
out but the chaos around was it a
confidence or not vote or not and all of
those MPS getting agitated in the
lobbies and it just seemed that this
government just couldn't wasn't
functioning it wasn't fit for purpose
and I think that that has triggered many
MPS to say enough is enough as we know
there's already been 16 letters in uh
Graham Brady has been in there today the
Deputy Prime Minister is coffee has been
in Jake Barry the party chair has been
in they've had a meeting it's over for
Liz truss according to my source she's
going to have to step down it's
absolutely extraordinary she has been
imposed but six weeks
so your sources suggesting that Liz
truss is about to emerge from Downing
Street to announce her resignation if
that is the case Beth the big question
is what next
that absolutely is the case Anna and I
don't have an answer on what's next and
that was one of the things that was
keeping Liz truss in number 10 that MPS
just simply couldn't decide on who
should replace her that has been talk
one Minister and this was someone that
Battlers trust I should say said that
there should be a Rishi sunak Penny
mordant deal where they take over Grant
Schatz might fancy himself for the job
Jeremy Hunt swallow Braverman certainly
fancies herself on the right to the
party and the question for the
conservatives is how do they have an
orderly Handover of power maybe we will
learn a bit more of that today there
were lots of discussions about whether
they would lift them nominations to say
100 120 MPS in order to get on the uh
voting ballot in order to stand as a
candidate there was some talk about
whether sir Graham would try and re not
rig that but set the bar so high that
effectively you've got a Unity candidate
because I think there is a sense from
MPS that they don't I can feel
everyone's getting quite jittery now as
we wait for the primers to come out but
there was a sense from MPS that they
didn't uh they didn't want to have they
don't want to have a long drawn-out
contest they can't have a two-month
contest again that much is clear there's
a question about what do they do with
the membership you'll remember it wasn't
Liz Truss It was Rishi sunak that run
with MPS Liz truss was the choice of the
the party members and I think that the
government the governing party the
conservative party will want a short
contest they might even want to anoint a
successor but Anna this party is so so
divided that I'm not clear about how
easy that process will be
and the context for this Beth as we wait
at the Prime Minister running three
minutes late at the moment it was due to
happen at 1 30. let me just remind
people of the context I'll let you
remind people of the context not just a
a political crisis here but there has
been a markets crisis as well and the
Market's no doubt watching very closely
too
yes the markets are washing closely but
you'll remember Anna that when um
Usher's coming out let's listen in
[Music]
foreign
at a time of great economic and
international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
and so Liz truss announcing their her
resignation as prime minister after just
six weeks in office our political editor
Beth Rigby was listening to that
statement so Beth what did you make of
it
while it was shortened to the point Anna
wasn't it she uh the Prime Minister said
I cannot deliver the Mandate for which I
have been elected I have spoken to the
king I've notified him I'm resigning
this morning she met with graham Brady
and she says that she and the chair of
the 1922 party has agreed that the
leadership election will be completed
within the next week absolutely
Breakneck speed so they wanted to keep
her in post until that fiscal statement
clear that she could not survive that
she literally could not manage or leave
the party even for a couple of weeks
longer and they have decided between
them that Liz truss has to go she stood
down we will have a new prime minister
within a week by the end of next week
Liz truss is saying there will be a new
prime minister is an absolutely
astonishing finishing turn of events
Boris Johnson
ousted from number 10 in July Liz truss
elected she took up the post on
September the 5th and now here we are
six weeks later she's been forced to
stand down and now the question is who
is going to take over how will those
rules work we are going to have another
prime minister the third in what a
matter of three or four months within
the next week
well yes and let's reflect on on what a
moment this is as you were saying there
Beth extraordinary that we're going to
see yet another prime minister take over
after six extraordinary weeks of her
being in office at losing her Chancellor
losing her home secretary and having to
reverse key planks of her key policies
that's right Anna and let's just reflect
for a moment
on the attempt of Liz truss attempt of
her regime and and wear it all ended up
because it didn't have to go this way
actually in terms of the policy platform
she stood on the party like that party
members like that lots of MPS like that
they wanted tax cuts they wanted to go
for growth but the staging and the pitch
rolling of these plans was just done in
a way that didn't bring people with her
and as any prime minister any leader
knows you're only as strong as the
people that come with you that you rule
if you like by consent and by support
and I think what happened with Liz truss
was she had won the party uh membership
over she had won the position and with
that she took absolute power and I say
that in the sense that she decided to
not include sunac
supporters in her cabinet she then
Unleashed an economic program which she
said went against treasury Orthodoxy in
fact she was quite critical I'm just
going to grab a Rollie it's raining a
bit now she was quite critical of uh the
economic Orthodoxy of the treasury she
was critical in the leadership race of
the bank of England she thought she
could do things her way and then what
happened was that a statement came out
that mini budget it went further and
faster than people expected with more
than expected tax cuts 45 billion pounds
of unfunded tax cuts the markets gave
their verdict very quickly and it was
very bad for Liz trust so bad she had to
u-turn on her 45 Pence rate policy to
sprout the 45 Pence rate she then had to
U-turn a few days later on the entire
thing having sacked her Chancellor and
at that point we were saying it's a
matter of time this prime minister's
reputation is in to quote one former
Minister absolute tatters you then saw
the polling uh from the public only one
in ten britons gave her a favorable
rating she had the worst ratings of any
prime minister since ratings began and
then of course in the polls labor just
absolutely charged in ahead this is not
a recipe for sustainability for a prime
minister so in a way there was a sense
that the game could be over and then a
series of unforced Errors I would say
over the past 48 Hours has just
precipitated uh her demise as I said
there was hopes she could stay on until
October the 31st as calm things down it
just simply became untenable and it is
nearly beyond belief that having ousted
Boris Johnson in July the conservative
party having picked Liz truss has
decided she is not up for the job and
now we have to see who will replace her
and there is going to be a lot of horse
trading now behind the scenes between
the likes of
Jeremy Hunt who else Ben Wallace swella
bravaman resigning yesterday clearly
fancies her chances on the right of the
party I might the party do well as I was
reporting this week there's talks about
lifting the nomination threshold above
100 a hundred
and twenty MPS why might you do that
because you flush out other candidates
and the party really want candidate I
think the fact that I don't have the
details yet I'm afraid but I think the
fact that the Prime Minister has said
the race will be completed by next week
so that's what eight nine days from now
suggests to me that it is going to be a
race just of the Parliamentary party I
don't think that that can go to members
during that time I was told that that
could be a problem by someone because
that might mean that there was a legal
challenge because it should go to
members but obviously Jake Barry the
party chairman has been in uh to number
10 and they've clearly discussed all of
this but what an astonishing turn of
events we thought and we've been talking
amongst ourselves and we've been
reporting it on television too that her
time was going to be up as I said last
night people had just decided her time
was up the question was the speed of the
departure and I think what happened in
the Commons last night the fracking
debacle the chaos the whips resigning
and not resigning I think many MPS just
said we can't do this for a day longer
and they haven't she is out
that's extraordinary developments I will
come back to you in a moment but we have
just had a statement in from kirstma of
course the leader of the labor party
responding to the prime minister's
resignation he has said in the last few
minutes the conservative party has shown
it no longer has a mandate to govern he
goes on after 12 years of Tory failure
the British people deserve so much
better than this revolving door of Chaos
in the last few years the Tories have
set record high taxation trashed our
institutions and created a cost of
living crisis now they've crashed the
economy so badly the people are facing
500 pounds a month extra on their
mortgages the damage they have done will
take years to fix and just to carry on
with secure starma statement which which
is quite long but this is an important
moment he says each one of these crises
was made in Downing Street but paid for
by the British public each one has left
our country weaker and worse off and
goes on to say the Tories cannot respond
to their latest shambles but yet again
simply clicking their fingers and
shuffling the people at the top without
the consent of the British people they
don't have a mandate to put the country
through yet another experiment Britain
is not their personal fiefdom to run how
they wish and then the leader of the
labor party sums up saying the British
public deserve a proper say on the
country's future they must have the
chance to compare the Tories chaos with
Labor's plans to sort out their mess
grow the economy for working people and
build the country for a fairer Greener
future we must have a chance at a fresh
start we need a general election now
so that was Secure stalma's response to
Liz truss's announcement outside Downing
Street in the last few minutes that she
was going to resign let's listen to that
statement once more
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills on on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our physical plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
so that was the statement by Liz truss
in the last 15 minutes announcing her
resignation outside number 10. she said
she wasn't able to deliver on she wasn't
able to deliver the Mandate on which she
was elected and so it was time to go and
she announced that there would be a
leadership election within the next week
to choose her successor well let's cross
over to Sam coats who's in central Lobby
in Parliament at Forest this afternoon
and what do we know about who might step
forward to take up the role Sam
we've got first piece of information
about the leadership contest Anna and
that is that Jeremy Hunt the newly
appointed Chancellor will not stand in
this contest presumably he feels he's
got an enormous job to do trying to work
out what cuts to push through probably
for this statement that's due to be
happening on October the 31st to
reassure the markets to show that
Britain can live within its means but
Jeremy Hunt will not stand in this
contest taking one of the big beats to
the conservative party out of the frame
and leaving the way presumably for
discussions between Rishi sunak who I
was told this morning is very very up
for the job uh Penny Morden who's been
making it clear in her public
performances that she's up for the job
suela Braverman who resigned critical of
Liz truss in a move that many of her
allies suggests that she might be up for
the job the question is which will stand
aside and which will survive in a
contest that goes back to the way
contest were run before 2000 before the
rules were changed in a contest that
would be determined only by conservative
MPS so it's going to be an enormous week
inside the houses of Parliament and in
the tea rooms and bars and the WhatsApp
groups of conservative MPS as they try
to work out which of the names they can
rally behind for the next prime minister
who will be presumably installed in
about a week's time when Liz trust steps
down as prime minister she's gone as
leader of the conservative party she has
informed the king but there is now a few
days for the conservative party to sort
itself out kierstama pointing out that
the third having a third prime minister
in this Parliament should mean that we
now have a general election conservative
MPS absolutely desperate to avoid that
and so they will be trying to put
personal and political differences aside
Jeremy Hunt presumably won't be taking a
great deal of part in that there's an
interesting question Anna about about
quite what this means for Jeremy Hunt in
the sort of medium to long term if he
doesn't take part in the contest over
the next few days has he been given some
kind of assurance that he might stay on
as Chancellor stay on to do the package
of cuts that is on October the 31st or
we're still expecting on October 31st is
he expecting to be Chancellor at that
point that he's been given a reassurance
by Graham Brady that whoever takes over
would keep him there well that is
constitutionally complicated so we're
going to have to wait to see what that
role is that he sees himself doing over
the next few days but there's no doubt
that the arrival of Jeremy Hunt last
week stabilized the markets and nobody
here wants the resignation of Liz truss
to destabilize the markets once more so
I think that there is a lot of uh there
is a lot of uncertainty uh in in in
what's going on but I think Jeremy Hunt
deciding not to stand uh is a signal
that he certainly wants to move uh at
PACE trying to work out which bits of
government dependent Department budgets
to cut and all the rest of it while the
rest of the conservative party
presumably goes into a high intensity
high intensity frenzy and I think if you
step back from the personalities
involved there are a big big policy
questions uh that will be kicked around
at lightning speed in this leadership
contest Liz trust came in and spent 44
days in power with a very particular
ideology that reflected a certain strand
of libertarian conservative thinking
will Tory MPS just now reject that
outright will they say that has failed
candidates potentially like Zoella
braveman not that far away from a lot of
the things that Liz truss was doing
could they end up with a with a
candidate for prime minister that's in
bit closer to what the kinds of things
that Liz trust espouses perhaps at a
slightly slower Pace or do they do a
sharp handbrake turn and having rejected
Rishi sunak uh just at the start of
September to they then decide that
actually as the polling of conservative
party members suggest actually that he
is the right answer given that this is
an economic crisis given that the
warnings that he made turned out to be
true about Liz truss's plans and given
that he's been quietly biding his time
not really causing any difficulty in the
public eye he's been having a few quiet
conversations with colleagues that
supported him on the leadership contest
he has been seen a little bit in Port
Keller's house in Westminster a little
bit on the party circuit last week
having conversations both with Tory MPS
and notably at a Bloomberg party with
Rachel Reeves so he's just been there in
the background I I suspect the other big
figure in this leadership contest at the
moment as we go into get out of the
starting blocks as Penny mordant she of
course did that barnstorming uh Speech
48 hours ago in the Commons standing in
for Liz truss who was asked to justify
some of the economic chaos she sent
Penny Morton in her place famously Penny
bordent uh said that Liz trust wasn't
under a desk but um Liz trust turned up
much later on uh in that statement as
Penny Morton was defending her but I
think quite a lot of MPS are attracted
to Penny Morton's bombast to her ability
in the chamber to her wit and to the way
that she can dispatch uh political
opponents with a sort of figure and
firmness that perhaps isn't seen uh it's
not necessarily one of the strengths of
maybe Rishi sunak or even or even Liz
trust so so I can see that Penny mordant
can hold some attraction for MPS but the
question during the leadership contest
so often was yes but what did you think
about economics and does that mean that
she's the right person uh to hold the
room at this point in time given this
particular set of challenges they're
could be wild cards we could have others
and we are just going to have to wait
and see I'm now joined by a conservative
MP it's Andrew bridgen writer of letters
to get rid of Tory prime ministers
was it the right decision what should
happen next
yes it was the right decision
um
clearly this trust had lost the
confidence not only of the Parliamentary
party but the public at large I think
when you get to minus 70 on personal
approvals
um you're basically giving Vladimir
Putin a push a run for his money aren't
you there was no way back so she's done
The Honorable thing the right thing to
do
a very quick leadership election I hope
that all the main contenders can come
together in the National interest some
egos will have to be put to one side I
want to see a government of conservative
of all the talents we've got on the back
benches which are considerable all wings
of the party
and I think
the state of politics we find ourselves
in today
if the party can't do that and we can't
coalesce around a leadership a new prime
minister and a leadership team and we're
heading for a general election you say
that's the last thing that we want and
probably the country wants when we're
facing so many challenges you say all
the big beasts should stand please name
them for us so I've been speculating
itself but who who are you talking about
well all the people who stood in the
summer I think they've got to have a
place at the table I think it's probably
between Rishi and Penny who's the most
acceptable but I I hope that we won't
have to even run the full week I I'm
hoping that they can all get together
and and come up with it with a team that
will be acceptable
um as I say some egos will have to be uh
sacrificed in the National interest and
in the interest of the conservative
party so if it does boil down to a big
big difficult choice between Richie
sumac and penny more than well what is
that choice is it a choice between
economic competence but not necessary
really flare at the dispatch box and on
behalf of Richie's see like an ability
to absolutely command the House of
Commons chamber dispatch opponents but a
slightly uncertain uh economic stance
from penny board is that is that a fair
way of describing the choice of it does
boil down to those two I think it's a
bit more nuanced than that I think
they're both very capable politicians
and I would add that I think um Jeremy
Hunt's probably secured his place as
Chancellor I think it would be
irresponsible for anyone in the short
term to to move him from that position
uh at the moment so I think we've got
all wings of the party potentially can
be in that cabinet and I I think
that's the best way forward let's say if
if those egos can't be uh sacrificed a
little bit in the National interest what
we'll focus the minds is we would have
to go for a general election
um if we can't form a stable government
the one person who might not be willing
to stand behind a Unity ticket that
might disrupt some of this it's been
suggested to me is Zoella Braverman do
you think that's possible what's your
message to her now Sue Ella uh
represents my wing of the party if you
like
um I think the problem with the right
wing of the party I was probably only
one of five or six of us who didn't
didn't back Liz
um and I think there's you know
the right wing of the party my wing of
the party has taken a bit of a a bit of
a dent we'll need Sue Ella uh in the
cabinet for sure because she's she's our
flag bearer she's a fellow Spartan with
me but but she has been playing footsie
with the Tory members do you know she's
not going to disrupt this attempt that
was prior to listro's uh announcement
this afternoon we're in a different
territory now
let's be sure the conservative party
where the polling is today we are
drinking in The Last Chance Saloon uh
and everyone has to recognize that and
if they don't well they deserve what
will be coming to us
um forgive me you Andrew bridgen serial
writer of letters to get rid of prime
minister and now telling Sky viewers
that the most important thing is unity
in the conservative party after
everything that we've seen I mean isn't
it isn't it hard to it's a bit hard to
take that uh that's just four letters in
nearly 13 years I mean uh there was four
letters in about five years yeah over
the last and at the end of the day when
I you know when I when I announced I was
putting my letter in the prime
minister's always went there I certainly
wasn't the only person in the
Parliamentary party who it was of that
view and I think they were the right
decisions at the right time and that's
what I'm telling you now we need down to
coalesce around a new prime minister but
also a team and they've got to represent
all wings of the party this isn't just
about personality and prime minister
it's about C2 just very briefly Jeremy
Hunt has to decide the most difficult
Cuts in a generation on behalf of the
conservative party without knowing who
the prime minister is who at the very
last minute is going to have to sign off
on them that's politically unsustainable
isn't it
um
I'm sure that we're all going to have
input on to what Jeremy Hunt's going to
have to do in in his budget
the answer is also to to get rid of hs2
and cut your losses now which is a huge
amount of money but that's another one
of my little hobby horses right now it
sounds like Jeremy Hunt though is the
most powerful person
in government
he arrived at a time of Crisis he's done
a competent job he's reassured the
markets he's secured his place at the
table he's already announced he wouldn't
stand in the leadership he's got his
work to do
I hope other potential cabinet members
will take such a responsible attitude to
the roles they're going to have to do
for the party and the country over the
next week or two final question
um do you lean currently towards any of
the big piece are you a bit more of a
Rishi sunac fan now are you a bit more
of a penny more than tight are you are
you even Stevens are you up the grabs
I'm comfortable with either of them I
think they're both very competent
politicians but I think it will be one
of those two and will it be a vote that
determines that amongst MPS
if they were to come to me tomorrow and
say we've decided between ourselves we
don't need a vote this is what we've got
uh and he's a I would accept that either
way
um or if we have to have one round of
voting to see who's in front what I
don't really want is that someone's got
49 and someone's got 51 and the
divisions continue because we can't have
that continue we must move forward now
as a team we've got two years to the
next general election and uh if we move
forward competently what's happened over
the last few few weeks will will be seen
as an aberration rather than the norm it
can't be the norm thank you very much
indeed Andrew Bridge a lot of important
stuff in that conversation just there
Andrew bridge and making clear that the
priority is for an orderly transition so
that there is not a general election he
thinks that this contest is right now
between Richie sunac and penny more than
he doesn't even think that Tory MPS
necessarily need to vote on the outcome
over the next few weeks and he thinks
that Jeremy Hunt has secured himself the
show onto the ship into the next
Premiership so whoever becomes next
after Liz trust will keep Jeremy Hunt
there as Chancellor big developments
Sam thanks very much indeed so plenty
more coverage to come here on Sky News
as Liz truss announces her resignation
after just 44 days in office during
which she lost the confidence of Tory
MPS and the public according to the
polls and oversaw Market turbulence
plenty of analysis coming up next
it's two o'clock this is Sky News live
from Downing Street
Liz truss resigns as prime minister
after just 44 days in office
the Mandate on which I was elected by
the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
it will now be a leadership election
within a week with Liz truss saying
she'll remain as prime minister until a
successor is announced Sky News
understands the chancellor Jeremy Hunt
will not stand for the leadership
we will have live coverage throughout
the afternoon as we get the latest
reaction to Liz truss's resignation and
the Front Runners to replace her
[Music]
good afternoon then from Downing Street
where in the past half an hour Liz truss
has resigned as prime minister after
just 44 days in office she said she
recognized that she could not deliver on
her mandate a leadership election will
be completed within a week here is Liz
truss's statement in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills on on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
so they said it was only a matter of
time and so it has proved our political
Beth Rigby is with me it was this an
inevitability it wasn't inevitability
Mark pretty much it became more
inevitable if you like us as it went
along I think what has surprised people
was the speed of the departure so from
the reversal on the 45 Pence tax then
the junk in of the mini budget uh the
departure of the Home Secretary the
U-turn yesterday on pensions it felt
like Liz trust was not running the
government that the benches were running
higher and if you're a prime minister
without a policy platform and without
the authority within your parliamentary
party there's only a certain amount of
time that you can hang in there I think
what's been surprising what has
surprised many senior conservatives was
what the speed of the departure one
former cabinet minister I was talking to
last night said to me look Beth we know
how this is going to end the only
question now is the speed events Dear
Boy sometimes isn't it and I think what
happened last night in the Commons it
meant things unraveled much more quickly
than people actually wanted as well it
should be said that gray and Brady and
his team would have preferred that she
had stayed in post until the end of the
month and I think that's why now the
leadership race is so short and
condensed it will probably be MPS only
because it's only going to be a week
long she said within a week within a
week I'm sure we will hear soon about
what Sergio and Brady intends to do but
within a week and the reason I'm
checking my phone like mad is I'm trying
to work out who is and isn't going to
run Jeremy Hunt has ruled it out he
ruled it out actually an interview to me
on Monday saying Mrs hunt and the three
children the three little hunts had
ruled it out on his behalf and I I only
half believed him because often
politicians say that but he's ruled him
out himself out again clearly wishes
sonat will want a Tilt at the top job
Penny mordant Ben Wallace as well a
bravaman will also no dad be looking at
options and could she potentially team
up with Cami badanov to form the sort of
right-wing ticket of the party that was
the sort of Trio between her and Liz
truss and Cami they were the right so
will those two team up on a double
ticket the question will be is how high
do they set the threshold and who gets
through because they do not want a big
horse race of a number of MPS batting it
out they're going to want to make this a
very short Snappy campaign they need a
new prime minister in a week before
October 31st I can't keep up with events
Mark I've done this job for a long time
I have never seen anything anything like
it it's absolutely astonishing I know
and I know you've got to run I do I've
got the we've got our few weeks of being
a shambles or something they've been a
shambles the last 24 hours though
like nothing I've ever known and even in
those moments in July when Boris Johnson
was staying in I remember it so well and
the number of resignations were ticking
up and Ticking up and Ticking up it was
easier for Boris Johnson in some ways to
hold on because he'd won the Mandate but
for Liz truss she never won a mandate
from the country she didn't ever have
the public majority support of her
parliamentary party and then she ran her
government in a way that she thought she
could dictate the terms to a party that
we're not sure about her and they
punished her they punished her swiftly
They concluded she wasn't up for the job
and now we are facing our third prime
minister in four months it's absolutely
astonishing I don't think I'll ever see
live to see days like this again I mean
it's gonna happen in the future well
it's entirely unprecedented it's just
astonishing turn of events listen I know
you've got to run off you go thanks very
much indeed there for now come back to
see us a little bit later it's been an
extraordinary morning with MPS all
morning coming out and saying they
wanted her to go every time you
've updated Twitter and other MPS seem
to be saying or calling for Liz trust to
go our Deputy political editor Sam coats
is in the central lobby of the houses of
Parliament uh so Sam what reaction are
you picking up from MPS
that's right Mark every time you watch
Sky News there was another MP coming out
suggesting uh that Liz trust should go I
think there's a lot there's a lot that
we don't know I suspect we'll get some
clarity before long about exactly what's
about to happen with the Parliamentary
party the conservatives choosing
Britain's new prime minister in a week
at a point of financial crisis
let's find out what what are these Tory
MPS things this is Simon fell uh what do
you think of events that have happened
in the last hour
um well the world is moving very quickly
at the moment
um I I'm not surprised to be perfectly
honest you know we've had a tumultuous
couple of weeks and the vote last night
was for me the final nail in the coffin
um it was just chaos you put in the
letter yeah
is just such an uncomfortable time what
we need is stability and Clarity of
Direction and someone in number 10 who
can calm things down and when Jeremy
Hunt came in we saw that with the
treasury we saw the market start to come
we saw a clear sense of direction and we
just haven't had that from the top so
it's time for that change what happens
next
well I think we're about to hear from
Instagram about you know what the exact
rules will be but I think given where we
are as a country we need a fast uh
competition where we can just get a very
very quick Battle of ideas hopefully we
can get some Coalition coalescing around
a decent candidate and then we can just
move forward and get on with the job of
governing now it seems all but it's all
but certain you're not going to put
whatever the decision is to the members
because of the time scale I mean is it
even wise to get MPS to vote to decide
the next prime minister or Reason is
even that potentially too risky uh no I
said well personally I think we should
have a vote I think it gives that
legitimacy but it also allows us to test
the candidates you know when when we had
the last leadership election however
many days ago that was not that long
um you know I went around and spoke to
them all one-on-one and tried to get a
feel for them I didn't know them
um and I think you know we should be
doing that same thing again because it's
you know we know them best of all but
there is stress testing to be done as
well and you know this is a serious
decision who do you think the candidates
are going to be
um to be honest I don't know I'd be
surprised if Richie and Penny weren't in
the mix
um aside from that who knows
you have a preference over Rishi over
Penny or do you lean in any direction uh
so I backed trishi last time having
previously been on on Tom tigernutt's
campaign
um I think he's an exceptional character
but you know I really like Penny too I
just frankly I want to see a government
of the talent CEO of left and right
coming together people who've Got Deep
experience back in cabinet just
governing the country for the best of
the country do you have some sympathy
for Sky viewers watching all of this
thinking well the conservative party got
the last prime minister wrong
without going to the country and now
they're going to task themselves with
finding another one
why there might be some discontent about
the way politics is unfolding as someone
who's feeling quite a lot of discontent
himself yes absolutely
um I keep mentioning the word stability
I think this is absolutely The crucial
thing we've got to go for and whilst
there are calls for an election and all
that I get that but I think what we
don't need is that protracted time
talking to ourselves and the country
again we need to demonstrate we can put
someone in and deliver a bit of
stability for the country Jeremy did
that in number 11. you know hopefully we
can get to that place in number 10 and
The Wider cabinet and government but I
suppose my question why should viewers
trust you to come up with a new prime
minister when you came up with another
with one that lasted just 44 days in
office well I think the question is
really what the shape of this election
looks like so if it is just um Tory MPS
then we know these people better and I
think we can probably stress test them a
bit better if it goes out to The Wider
membership then there are those
questions again and I think you know
after this is long gone we need to look
at those rules around what we do when
we're in government what we do when
we're in opposition around selecting a
leader but but right now I think you
know what we need is to come together
and show that we can put a leader in
place with a broad team around them and
government all the talents
thank you very much indeed so today
there you have it it's a call for
stability from a Tory MP honest that
things have not gone in the way that
viewers voters might want and I
understand that we're now joined by Paul
Bristow another conservative MP
um what do you make of this morning
well it's an extraordinary day in in
politics but you know I went to my
constituency at the weekend and I always
wanted to talk to my constituents and
feel see how they feel and I went to
Diwali I went to the Great Eastern run I
even did some campaigning and the strong
message that I got was bring back Boris
Johnson I stood in a by-election six
months before Boris Johnson we won that
historic mandate that election I came
third we were 19 points behind in the
polls before Boris Johnson became prime
minister we're facing a similar
situation now now I don't know what the
situation is going to be I don't know
the rules I don't even know if Boris
Johnson wants to stand but we need an
election winner and we've had an
election winner and so as far as I'm
concerned I'll listen to my constituents
and their message was bring back Boris
do you think many conservative MPS agree
with you one of the seven members
certainly agree with me we saw the
members earlier on it said that Boris
Johnson was the most popular look it's
about making sure that we win as many
seats as we possibly can we get back to
good government and uh we we get back on
the right track Boris Johnson has got a
mandate from the members he's got a
mandate from the country if Boris
Johnson wants to do this my constituents
clearly want Boris to do this I think it
would be a fine choice but as I say I
don't know I don't know what the
situation is I don't know if any even if
he wants it do you don't think that
viewers voters might just raise one
eyebrow that a prime minister that was
ousted by the conservative party because
they were ashamed of him and didn't
think that he upheld the necessary
standards of high office should then be
brought back because you're in effect
well some I never wanted Boris to go in
the first place and you've nailed it we
are in a fix and the last time we were
in a fix Boris Johnson got us out of
that fix I hope he can do it again
um
do you think it's realistic though it is
a name that is mentioned a bit around
here but what's wrong with a fresh face
what's wrong with a Rishi sunak or a
penny mordant well I don't know what was
going to happen and I'm not going to
comment on any individual candidates
let's just see what the situation is but
what is clear we've got someone who's
got a mandate from the members of our
party already do you really think he's
still got a mandate given that he has
been ejected and therefore is not prime
minister and therefore you know the
conservative party chose to defenestrate
him and and he's not prime minister
anymore that mandate is expired well
that was a historic win he got from the
country in December 2019. it wasn't that
long ago and only in May 2021 in my city
in Peterborough we had the local
elections Boris was prime minister we
just come through covid we got an
amazing result in our local elections
where we made gains having been in power
for 11 years but Boris is a winner but
as I say I don't know what's going to
happen I don't know who's going to put
their names forward this is purely
speculation I'm just telling you what my
constituents are telling me thank you
very much indeed so there you have it a
big range of views there from Rishi
sunac to Penny mordant to the Wild Card
of Boris Johnson it is a name I'm
hearing as somebody who could actually
Bridge The Divide because the depths of
the infighting between the various camps
between the modern Knights and the
sunachites which you can surely only
going to intensify in the coming days
some some including some in the one
nation more Centrist part of the
conservative party actually saying Boris
Johnson could be the answer when we did
a focus group on Sky News barely a week
ago the name Boris Johnson actually
amongst blue wool former Tory voters who
supported Boris in 2019 absolutely
bombed so a big challenge with the
voters but some Tory MPS think he could
be the answer
yep uh who it's going to be how it's
going to happen all interesting
questions now Sky's Chief political
correspondent John Craig is with me so
there needs to be a process now there
needs to be a mechanism when are we
going to hear what that's going to be I
think we'll probably learn more about
that later this afternoon we understand
that the board of the conservative party
you might find out right now I think
Graham Brady is about to speak
we also have a meeting of the
conservative party board I have spoken
to the party chairman Jake Berry and he
has confirmed that it will be possible
to conduct a ballot and conclude the
leadership election by Friday the 28th
of October so we should have a new
leader in place before the fiscal
statement which will take place on the
31st I'll be able to give you more
details later on this afternoon
will members be included in the process
well that is the expectation uh so the
reason I've spoken to the party chairman
and discussed the parameters of a
process is to look at how we can make
the whole thing happen uh including the
party uh being consulted uh by Friday
next week
um it's certainly not a circumstance I
would wish to see so Graham will you
have to make the threshold conversations
flush out candidates you just can't
waste time I think these are details
that will be clear later on I haven't
got any more detail to share with you
now but there will be some clarity later
this afternoon
just just one more question how
disappointed are you in this this is the
fourth third person in four months the
public must be looking at is thinking
what on Earth is going on this is the
governing party absolutely
um absolutely and I think we're deeply
conscious uh of the imperative and the
national interest of resolving this uh
clearly and quickly a general elections
are great they're not just be a general
elect will there definitely be two
candidates going forward such as
membership uh the party's rules say
there will be two candidates unless
there is only one candidate so if
somebody drops out if somebody drops out
it could only be one if there is only
one candidate there is only one
candidate
I really can't give you any more details
again wasn't to have this contest
truncated to one week was in this
trust's idea or was it your support I
think uh I think it's a matter on which
there is a pretty broad consensus
thank you be alive
how's that there we are Graham Brady
saying the whole process he thinks could
be over or he's been told it's possible
to do it by at the end of next week I
mean what do you make of that well think
back to July when Boris Johnson went
Graham Brady was all for a fairly Swift
process then but there was a bit of a
Revolt from the part of the activists
and they wanted the longer process with
all those hustings remember there were
12. now the conservative party board is
meeting later this afternoon and they
may may not May dig their heels and say
no you can't freeze out the members
because and of course the members will
feel cheated of course by what's
happened here because the members voted
for Liz truss and it's entirely possible
that they may say we want to say now at
the moment I can tell you that Rishi
sunak is the overwhelming favorite with
the bookmakers
um odds on with both Ladbrokes and
William Hills we have haven't heard a
peep out of Rishi sunak since Liz trust
became prime minister he has been very
quiet he's studiously avoided all
attempts to talk to him when we've been
to his house first thing in the morning
and elsewhere he's been to a few social
events I seem to remember he went to a
reception hosted by Bloomberg's I think
it was at the at the Tate modern and I
think he took his daughter to a film
Premiere no interviews though behind the
scenes though his team will be saying
Richie this is your moment but he may
not have all his own way we've just been
listening to Paul Bristow the
Peterborough MP saying bring back Boris
we reported a couple of days ago on a
poll that showed the party members if
Liz trust were to go had the backing of
33 percent a poll of 530 members Rishi
sunak was second on 23 so there will be
some in the party who oppose this idea
of a coronation or a stitch up which is
perhaps what sir Graham wants and
perhaps what the party Elder if you're
likely let's say we've that Dreadful old
cliche the men in Gray suits the 1922
committee executive uh they want a
smooth I remember when it was Tony Blair
and Gordon Brown the phrase are smooth
and oddly transition was used they'll be
wanting that but I wouldn't mind betting
quite a few activists and members will
say no we should have a say right I want
to talk to you about Boris Johnson and
what Paul Bristol was saying about Boris
Johnson just a moment Kia stama has been
speaking let's have a listen
well what a mess and this is not just a
soap opera at the top of the Tory party
it's doing huge damage to our economy
and to the reputation of our country and
the public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election
some simple people is trust her time in
office pretty humiliating the damage
that has been inflicted on the public
through higher prices and mortgages is
considerable this is not a soap opera
these are real lives that are being
impacted by the mess at the top of the
Tory party we've had this revolving door
we've had these experiments at the top
of the Tory party the public are
entitled to choose between this utter
chaos and a labor party which will
stabilize the economy and have got a
clear plan for growth for living
standards and for jobs of the future we
need a general election so the public
can make their mind up about this utter
chaos isn't there an argument that a
general election might actually prolong
the instability to an outcome of that
general election did we need more
instability now or just a chance for a
clean State and just to stabilize the
ship the risk at the moment is
continuing with this chaos not having a
stable labor government so that's why
there should be a general election we
can't just allow the Tory party to keep
putting up the next candidate in the
middle of this chaos there is a choice
there's a labor party that's capable of
you know stabilizing the economy has a
clear plan and the public entitled to
choose between that stable labor
government and this utter chaos of the
conservatives are you ready for
government this is not the context you
would have wanted to take over we are
ready to form a government to stabilize
the economy and Implement a real plan
for growth for living standards to help
people through a cost of living crisis
and that's the choice now a stable labor
government or this utter chaos from the
conservatives
brilliant thanks so much
we are secure style are predictably
calling for an election I'm with John
Craig we were just talking about this
mechanism now to find a replacement for
Liz truss and
um so it does seem as though it's going
to be done before the fiscal statement
it does seem it's going to be done by
the end of next week and there will be
some membership involvement I mean
that's a tall order and just Liz trust
going doesn't mean this is no longer a
split party no certainly not especially
if they can't agree or there's a a
Rancor a sacrimonious leadership
Campaign which is possible Boris Johnson
will he I mean he's reported to be on
holiday in the Caribbean with his wife
Carrie
um will he suddenly fly back to say I'm
a candidate there's plenty of Paul
bristow's not the only MP now Dean Doris
is his great champion and cheerleader
and as I was saying a moment ago there's
this poll by of the it was a yougov poll
the party activist 33 he was the
favorite to come back to to succeed Liz
truss if she were to go and now she's
going but yes the timetable
is ambitious isn't it a week because if
there's if there's two online boots it
could be it could be
um during the summer of course you they
could vote online and I remember there's
a security glitch right at the beginning
um because they were there was a talk of
them being able to change their votes
which was open to all sorts of problems
um they had a choice of voting by post
or online during the summer no doubt if
they're going to consult the members
they will be asked to do it online to
save time now in recent contests of
course we've they've had amongst MPS
they knock out one candidate each time
and they get down to the final two
um we don't know yet there was talk Beth
Wrigley was talking earlier about a
threat the threshold being being raised
for the number of number of nominations
you need to get onto the ballot paper
ideally if they're going to have a
contest they'd only probably want two or
three candidates they wouldn't want I
seem to remember it's about eight or ten
at the beginning in the summer it could
potentially be very messy and I'd say I
wouldn't rule out the party Elders the
the the the chairman of local parties
all those people the party board which
is meeting this afternoon saying we want
a bigger say that's possible sir Graham
who's left here but obviously left here
to go and uh do that statement just now
he got I think he needs to get a
government car to take him back
um to the House of Commons uh he clearly
wants it all neat and tidy
um but uh of course we are in the whole
position now where there's gonna if
there is going to be a new prime
minister in the week in a week's time
well we're looking at a whole new
cabinet again we're looking at cabinet
ministers who've only been in their jobs
for a few weeks possibly I mean we've
been setting all sorts of Records this
week for the shortest serving
chancellors haven't we which then begs
the question and Kia stalmers already
been asking for it what within an hour
of of Liz truss resigning it begs the
question how many chancellors how many
prime ministers how many changes of
governments does it take before
you have an election well the party will
say we have a majority of 80 or down to
about 71 72 now with for various reasons
they've got a healthy majority that vote
last night when it came in the vote at
seven o'clock the government won with a
majority of 96. it wasn't as if it was a
close vote and then of course we learned
afterwards about all the rgbaji and the
division Lobby the no Lobby where the
conservatives were voting the chief Whip
and her Deputy was said to have resigned
it was a complete Fiasco all those
allegations of unruly behavior
manhandling of MPS and so on they have
got a working majority and so that of
course is the argument for no election
at Prime Minister's questions uh Liz
trussing's a week ago said the last
thing anybody wants is a general
election the opposition party's one of
course they do look at the polls
um I listen to you get one well the
government has got to start losing votes
in Parliament really for there to be a
general election
you were talking about Boris Johnson and
we were going to talk a bit more about
that but joining us I think is Henry
Newman who was an advisor to the Boris
Johnson government uh good afternoon
Henry thanks very much for uh being with
us first of all we'll talk about Boris
Johnson in just a moment first of all uh
what do you make of today's events
well it's just absolutely extraordinary
I don't think I've seen anything like it
and I thought with the brexit referendum
and the indicative votes and the
meaningful votes and all that we lived
through some of the most turbulent times
in British politics but this is uh
simply of a different level and uh I
think at one level perhaps the best
argument it can be made for the
conservative party is that they've
recognize they made a mistake and
they're now going to over the next few
days coalesce around a new leader who
will have the job of calming the markets
or coming to office we're told on the
28th of October shortly before there's
expected to be a statement on the 31st
on Halloween which will set out how the
government plans to spend public money
over the next few years and that's
really the key the key date the 28th of
October and the 31st of October but it
is absolutely uh unbelievable moment
again in British politics
and what about Boris Johnson uh John
Craig just saying he's on holiday in the
Caribbean or has been in the last few
days will he will he be interested in
doing it do you think he said it wasn't
over when he left
I also read these abroad and I simply
don't know and I obviously uh can't
speak for him but I think that you know
what I worked for him in Downey Street
and he was a politician who I uh
respected a great deal and I came to
admire more and more as I saw him up
place
and what about the calls now which will
get louder louder I'm sure for an
election and what we've just been
discussing so many different chancellors
now another prime minister will there
come a time do you think when the clamor
for an election will have to be listened
to
I think obviously there's going to be a
lot of uh demands for an election from
the labor party from the Scottish
national party and so on but it's not
the opposition parties that can demand
an election that's a matter for the
governing party I think exactly as John
was saying there's clearly uh the
potential for a new leader to form a
stable majority it's about 70 now the
conservative majority give or take a few
MPS and I think that a new leader should
be able to win votes on Supply and
confidence and I think it would frankly
be quite irresponsible now to see the
country plunged into a new general
election there'd be questions really
about whether that would be in the best
economic interest of the country I think
what we do need is the government to
come back together around a new leader
and calm the markets show that they can
get on with it quietly with the job of
running the country that's the most
important thing not going back to the
public
okay uh Henry thank you very much indeed
for being with us this afternoon and
joining us now is associate editor of
the news Statesman Rachel cunliffe and
the writer Benedict Spence thank you
both uh I hope you're dry at least uh
uh Rachel's starting off with you uh
well well your reaction to uh Liz truss
resigning
the the reaction is is shock I mean we
all knew it was coming but I don't think
anyone expected it to unfold quite like
this and and quite so quickly what we
thought we were waiting for on Monday
was for the conservative party to work
out amongst itself who the successor to
Liz truss was going to be knowing that
they did not want a messy leadership
contest and that after this period of
instability they really needed to
coalesce around a candidate and say
right she's going here's who we're going
to get in instead what we saw yesterday
both with the departure of the Home
Secretary and then with the kerfuffle
over that vote on on fracking that ended
up not really being a vote on fracking
at all was that the conservative party
made the decision that actually it was
more of a liability to allow Liz trust
to stay in position than it was to
announce that that she was going without
having that succession plan lined up so
now we're at a point where we have no
idea what's going to happen in the next
week talk of a contest talk of Tory man
is getting another vote good luck with
that uh but it really shows how dire the
situation was that the party felt it had
to move that quickly even when there
isn't a clear succession strategy lined
up
and Benedict your observations on
another pretty dramatic day here
um relief tinged with the faintest
amount of amusement that actually you
know after the fury of the Summer where
everything was dragged on yeah was Boris
Johnson going to go wasn't he going to
go you know that went on for so long and
then there was the elongated leadership
contest relief
um and amusement that they have learned
from their mistakes albeit probably
frankly too late
um but now we're going to have this
whole process done and dusted in a week
which wouldn't have been a wouldn't have
been magnificent so if if you know the
previous regime had been dealt with in
this manner perhaps all of this could
have been avoided or at the very least
we could have got this subsequent regime
out of the way a lot sooner um also
irritation that that it has got to this
stage because honestly you know that we
don't have time now to be messing around
with a leadership contest with trying to
get uh new leaders in with having to go
through that whole process again we're
in the midst of the Maelstrom now
actually and the party has known that
this was coming for a long time be it
People's Energy bills uh or whatever you
know the fact that
this was allowed to happen I think is
incredibly frustrating and I I don't
believe that they that the public will
forgive them if what we now see is even
more inviting nobody wants to see a
coronation of an unpopular uh
replacement prime minister obviously but
if that you know if we now what we have
is more ferrets fighting in a sack over
who gets to BPM and more obfuscation and
more
um you know infighting and backstabbing
well you know the party might as well
call a general election because you know
you just hasten the inevitable that's
the point isn't it Rachel just because
Liz trusses resigned it doesn't mean
this party is still not Riven with
division in fact it may be more so
uh very much so I mean I think the
chances of them calling election before
they absolutely have to are sort of
close to zero if not absolute zero
because they know how badly that they're
going to lose and why would you as a as
a conservative MP vote for something
that would put you out of a job the idea
that they might go back to the
conservative members uh to try and
replace Liz trusses is absolutely
ludicrous it's incredibly self-indulgent
it was self-indulgent over the summer
when week by week almost day by day we
saw the economy and the energy situation
getting steadily worse while we didn't
really have a government and obviously
and Liz truss were right around the
country making increasingly wild
promises the number of conservative
members who voted in that selection
contest works out and I think around 0.3
percent of the overall lecturers so you
know virtually no mandate there at all
and obviously what we saw is they voted
for a candidate putting forward an
economic agenda which spontaneously
combusted as soon as it made contact
with reality why we think it is in any
way appropriate or even feasible to go
back to these people six weeks later and
say yeah you made a mistake how about
trying again it's not a lucky dip I
think the the only course of action the
conservatives have right now is to find
a Unity candidate okay it's a coronation
no one really likes that but come on
look at the alternative here
so who is the most like likely in your
view a Unity candidate Rachel
I think it's quite likely going to be
rich you've seen Alex simply because
many of the other people who it could be
have already ruled themselves out he
really wants it he came second and and
let's not forget basically everything
that's happened since Liz trust
announced her economic agenda uh the
reaction from markets and how terribly
it's all gone he predicted all that over
the summer he lost but he was right
and just finally Bennett I mean is the
problem here that it's not really just a
credibility problem with uh the prime
minister or former prime minister
um isn't it developing into a credit
credibility problem with the party the
Tory party well I mean that is
ultimately why I think they have to go
to the members so I know Rachel says
that you know there isn't the time and I
do agree but ultimately you can't just
have now just a ballot of MPS to say
who's who's the Prime Minister because
then we'll have gone certainly from the
country to the membership to the MP as
well what's next are we just appoint a
technocrat when the next one doesn't
work out I don't think you'll be able to
sell that to the electorate I also think
that Rachel is wrong to say that it
isn't a lucky dip I believe it is quite
literally a lucky dip at this stage
because there isn't a Unity candidate
Rishi sunak is no more a Unity candidate
than Liz Tross was going to be
um yeah but she is quite right that what
we could be about to see is the same
thing that happened last time happening
again I know that people are talking
about Penny Morton they're talking about
Ben Wallace they're talking about Mr
Suna but the one that I don't think is
being spoken about but who was the one
that was headed off because of address
and the clash and the Divide between who
they were going to support well that was
Kenny babe knock yeah and ultimately
she's much more popular with the members
than she is uh than uh Rishi sunak is
for example so hypothetically let's say
that Liz truss's supporters all
gravitate in the Parliamentary party to
Kenny Bay not what's to stop her getting
into a final two then that goes for the
membership and then potentially she
squeaks through because the arithmetic
is almost the same and then it's
entirely you know it's up it's up for
debate whether or not that would be an
improvement a lot of people would say
she's very inexperienced uh but I think
that that is quite literally the stage
that we've got to right now
yeah all sorts of possibilities Benedict
and Rachel thank you both very much
indeed let's just draw breath here in
the rain in Downing Street bring
ourselves up to speed with what has been
happening in the last hour or so Liz
truss has resigned as prime minister
after just 44 days in office she said
she recognized that she could not
deliver on her mandate a leadership
election will now be completed within a
week we we're told here is Liz truss's
statement in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir Graham Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
please trust there confirming she is on
the way out the chair of the 1922
committee confirmed a short time ago
that the new prime minister will be
decided by next Friday or that's what he
expects here's what's the Graham Brady
said in a statement uh a short time ago
I'll be meeting with the officers of the
22 and the executive later this
afternoon we also have a meeting of the
conservative party board I have spoken
to the party chairman Jake Berry and he
has confirmed that it will be possible
to conduct a ballot and conclude the
leadership election
by Friday the 28th of October so we
should have a new leader in place before
the fiscal statement which will take
place on the 31st I'll be able to give
you more details later on this afternoon
Graham Brady there kicking off yet
another leadership election the labor
leader Sakia stammer well he's reacted
to the prime minister's resignation and
demanded a general election
well what a mess and this is not just a
soap opera at the top of the Tory party
it's doing huge damage to our economy
and to the reputation of our country and
the public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election some sympathy for Liz trust had
time in office pretty humiliating the
damage that has been inflicted on the
public through higher prices and
mortgages is considerable this is not a
soap opera these are real lives that are
being impacted by the mess at the top of
the Tory party we've had this revolving
door we've had these experiments at the
top of the Tory party the public are
entitled to choose between this utter
chaos and a labor party which will
stabilize the economy and have got a
clear plan for growth for living
standards and for jobs of the future
isn't there an argument that a general
election might actually prolong the
instability to an outcome of that
collection do we need more instability
now or just a chance for a clean State
and just to stabilize the ship the risk
at the moment is continuing with this
chaos not having a stable labor
government so that's why there should be
a general election we can't just allow
the Tory party to keep putting up the
next candidate in the middle of this
chaos there is a choice there's a labor
party that's capable of you know
stabilizing the economy has a clear plan
and the public entitled to choose
between that stable labor government and
this utter chaos of the conservatives
are you ready for government this is not
the context you would have wanted to
take over we are ready to form a
government to stabilize the economy and
Implement a real plan for growth for
living standards to help people through
a cost of living crisis and that's the
choice now a stable labor government or
this utter chaos from the conservatives
kissed armor calling perhaps predictably
for a general election there well it's
the markets that have driven much of
what has been happening in the past few
weeks and uh let's talk to Ian King he's
in the city to find out what the markets
make of Liz truss's resignation Ian
what's happening
hello Mike well it's actually been
pretty quiet to be honest and the
personality of Liz trust going is is
probably less relevant than the policies
that accompanied her going and those
were all ditched a few days ago by
Jeremy Hunt and that was really when you
saw the pronounced Market reaction now
guilt yields obviously government
employed government borrowing costs
they've gone in broadly the direction
that the treasury likes to see them
going and I.E down mainly at the longer
end of the maturity uh curve uh for
example uh the 30-year guilt the long
guilt that's yielding now 3.954 percent
uh it was 3.987 at the end of last night
at the shorter end of the curve well uh
things have been moving less
dramatically there and that of course
reflects the fact that the bank of
England from the 1st of November is
going to start unwinding some of its
asset purchases quantitative tightening
in the jargon so you're not seeing that
much movement there but initially the
market reaction was pretty favorable on
the guilt market Sterling also very
slightly rallied it had been trading
roughly before the announcement it hit a
low today of there you can see see the
air shot that's how much it's been
trading at uh today hit a low today of
1.11.69 at a height it uh went above
1.13 briefly so put on a centaur so it's
now back at around
1.12.63 the pound is uh slightly being
weighed down this morning by comments
from Ben Broadbent the Deputy Governor
of the bank of England who gave a speech
today in which he indicated that uh the
bank of England's main policy rate bank
rate would not be peaking at the levels
that the market appears to be pricing in
so Sterling has been slightly depressed
on that news but Sterling is nonetheless
higher on the session it's not something
a departing chief executive wants to see
their share price Rising on news of
their departure and imagine the same is
pretty applicable for a prime minister
you don't want to see uh guilt prices
and uh Sterling going up on news of
their departure but it has unfortunately
for Liz truss been the case this lunch
time
yeah and Ian will lead markets have a
favorite to take over
well I think the markets will really be
uh what what they essentially want is
for Jeremy Hunt to remain a sir
Chancellor of the exchequer I mean that
has been the key appointment in terms of
completely repudiating uh those policies
of quasi-quarters and Liz trust that so
spooked the markets on the 23rd of
September and Beyond so I think Jeremy
Hunt remaining as Chancellor will be the
key thing that they're looking out for
uh if you get Richie soon you're going
to be getting a technocratic prime
minister so probably something that the
markets would like the look of Penny
wardened I suspect are pretty similar
approach and feel really in many ways I
think it's Jeremy Hunt's uh positioning
as Chancellor that is most important for
the market right now as we await that uh
fiscal statement on the 31st of October
okay Ian thanks very much indeed we
haven't spoken to Sam coats for a while
let's go over and uh join him in the
central lobby of the houses of
Parliament he's been getting reaction
from mes Sam
that's right uh before we get to
reaction some news for you a statement
from a source close to Kenny badenot she
of course was one of the uh contenders
in the leadership contest over the
summer she did better than many realized
better than some expected and his Hearst
uh well a statement from a source close
to her now that the Prime Minister has
announced a resignation the party must
unite around a new leader who restores
trust in politics and delivers good
government for the British people people
kemi is in conversations with colleagues
about how best to achieve this in other
words we've already got people throwing
their hat in the ring you've got MPS
talking up Boris Johnson you've got
sources close to Kenny badenock saying
that she's actively looking at whether
or not it should be her we know that
petty mordant is interested in the job
I'm told that Rishi sunak is very keen
sowella braveman's been acting in many
ways as if she wants the job to the
desire for a stable and orderly
transition right now an hour after Liz
truss resigned looking quite tough
but with all these opportunities where
does that leave the labor party I'm
joined by Jonathan Ashworth who is in
the shadow cabinet
what do you make of Liz truss's
departure well it's clear to me now that
the conservatives have no mandate to
continue in government the economic
crisis the British people are facing
with soaring mortgage rates is a direct
consequence of decisions taken in
Downing Street and the idea that Tory
MPS here can stitch up and force upon
the country another Tory prime minister
by fought by denying the British public
any say in that decision whatsoever is
unacceptable people have had enough we
need a government that will clear up
this economic mess stabilize the economy
rebuild our Public Services we need a
general election now
I want to talk about what happens next
in a moment but watching the way that
the conservative party dispatched
Liz trust after 44 days are you a bit
jealous you kept Jeremy corbyn imposed
quite a lot longer than that despite
many many of you wanting him gone do you
wish the labor party was a bit more
ruthless like the conservative party is
well Jeremy corbyn was never elected
prime minister and Tori MPS gave us this
Tory prime minister who was responsible
for a disastrous budget which led to a
run on Pension funds and soaring
mortgage rates there are people in my
constituency facing in increasing their
mortgage of hundreds of pounds a month
because Tory MPS gave us the disaster
that was list for us the idea that they
have a mandate to continue into
Government after giving us this crisis
is completely laughable it's why we need
a general election now but Prime
Ministers do change in the middle of a
parliament good Brown became prime
minister in 2007 uh when Tony Blair was
elected at the start of that Parliament
so so that yes there is an economic
crisis however it is constitutionally
perfectly fine for this to happen and
you'd be wrong to suggest otherwise well
actually I mean you may be able to me
but when in recent history certainly not
in post-war history I don't think have
we had two prime ministers imposed on
those in this particular way actually in
2005 2005 general election the Tory
party run a campaign saying vote Blair
get brown and then and then so you could
argue there was a there was a mandate
for that but but the problem here is
that there is no mandate whatsoever for
the conservative governments to continue
to continue down this line they have
given us a disastrous budget which led
to everyone on Pension funds which led
to Soaring mortgage rates and the idea
that the people who caused this mess who
caused this chaos are the people who can
fix it is laughable it's why we need a
general election now because people have
had enough so I suspect we're going to
hear labor figures calling for general
election sort of until Level in the face
but the bottom line is you can't make
one happen can you there is an
opportunity if you put down emotional no
confidence in the government and you get
enough Tory MPS voting with all the
opposition parties to force one do you
think you're anywhere near to getting
Tory MPS who are absolutely fed up with
this government voting with you and
actually forcing the country to go to
the polls well it's certainly true that
Tory MPS are fed up with their own
government we've seen that played out uh
in the last few days
but are you close to doing evasionally
confidence you know
these conservatives have got an ATC
majority yeah yeah to get a general
election they need to need to decide on
one and a new Thai prime minister coming
in has to accept that they have no
mandate they've just been forced on the
country by Tory and peace the same Tory
MPS who gave us listruss gave us this
disastrous budget who have given us
soaring mortgage rates they have got no
mandate they need to give us a general
election now and I think that is the
view of the British people when I go
around talking to British people there
is a yearning for change out there
because people have had enough of this
lot and they need and want a government
that will come in clear up their Tory
economic mess stabilize the economy and
rebuild our Public Services there's one
element of today that's continuity
rather than change it's quite clear that
Jeremy Hunt for now is going to remain
as Chancellor because of the scale of
the economic problems facing this
country do you think that's the right
decision the scale of economic problems
created by this Tory government yeah the
reason Jeremy Hunt is supposedly looking
at cutting back on support was what was
until yesterday going to cut the pension
by about 400 pounds on top of another
big cut we've just had this year in the
pension is because he's trying to clear
up the mess created by this conservative
government look I'm not going to get
into whether Jeremy Hunter should be the
chancellor or somebody else oh I want to
see the chancellor is Rachel Reeves
because we need a change of government
to why we need a general election
very much indeed labor wanted general
election it's not quite clear how they
can force it to happen soon but they
will continue to make those calls
Sam for now thank you very much indeed
now the former special advisor to Boris
Johnson and Theresa May Lyla house and
Smith joins me now thank you very much
for being with us and John Ashworth is
right about one thing it is a mess isn't
it
certainly it looks very difficult now to
get to um a any kind of stable
Arrangement
um while we've seen that truncated
leadership contest kind of put forward
um by Graham Brady
um it looks like there's still a number
of conservative MPS that are considering
running
um so really there's quite a bit of road
I think still to run in the general sort
of feeling of chaos and instability I
think uh the one sort of Silver Lining
if you like is that Jeremy Hunt looks
extremely likely
um to remain as Chancellor if if not
because of kind of personal preferences
of leadership candidates because frankly
they'll only be three days between
um the election of a new leader and that
on that October 31st fiscal of air
all right and I mean what do you think
looking forward then we're just getting
details of who is going to run or who
may run who may not run uh what are your
feelings about the week ahead
so I think the interesting thing and the
thing to watch is going to be how
quickly support kind of consolidates a
run among just a small um pool of
candidates I think it's extremely likely
given they're showing in the summer that
Rishi soon I can Penny Warden emerges
from Runners they have established
campaign teams established groups of MP
supporters and you can see that coming
to our head relatively quickly I think
the kind of remaining unknowns are
whether individuals who've been tasked
in recent days like Ben Willis choose to
put that hat into the ring that includes
Sue Ella Braverman and Kenny bradlock in
that category as well and then the final
major and known is of course uh whether
Boris Johnson
um at all considers a another another go
I think that's kind of you know very
much an outside chance at least at this
stage but I think once we see a bit more
detail about how the conservative
membership might be involved um it
certainly might be kind of more
interesting in terms of uh individuals
who think that they might not get the MP
vote but think that they can rely on
that membership though
and we're not just talking a lot of
changes within governments here within
government here we're talking changes of
chancellors uh now another prime
minister
um how long will they be able to resist
calls for a general election do you
think
look I think it would be an extremely
Brave conservative prime minister that
goes into an election now with polling
where it is I think you know if whoever
is um is the next leader
um receives a bit of a poll bounce if
they manage to kind of set out a clear
mandate for what they're going to do
with the remaining time before for an an
action I think you know there's not
there's an opportunity potentially for
them to suggest that they need a general
election to have a fresh mandate
um there's also kind of risk that the
MPS are perhaps not so whippable in the
context of
um of of without fresh election but look
I think conservative MPS right now the
future leadership candidates are all
going to be thinking this is not a
pretty picture we do not want to put you
know labor and power we do not want to
be putting a bunch of MPS out of a job
and what about the credibility issue all
the talk has been about The credibility
of the Prime Minister given what has
happened to her key policies but isn't
that the credibility of the party as a
whole now under question
yes look I think it's not the case I
think you know a lot of the mistakes can
be kind of squarely towards uh decisions
made by Liz traps and just commitments
really made by her during the leadership
campaign I think the challenge for
whoever is the next leader and next
prime minister is going to be very
quickly establishing kind of their
Vision uh their ability to kind of
preserve economic competence there
um their desire to kind of balance the
books on the 31st of October and their
willingness to kind of take tough
decisions
um but also set out a kind of
overarching conservative mission that is
kind of in line broadly with the um with
the 2019 Manifesto and I think that's
going to be the key test and how quickly
they can do that and assume
um a cabinet that's kind of able to
deliver on that as well that you know
sticks with the plan
um is going to be pretty crucial
and what about uh just reflecting on I
mean the chaos of well there's been
shambles for several weeks but the last
24 hours were extraordinary
yeah I think I think the last 24 hours
proved that you know this government
could go on frankly they made a vote on
fracking a confidence issue and 20 to 30
of their MPS still didn't still
um still didn't vote with the government
I think at that stage your ability to
deliver legislation to deliver your
mandate is is pretty pretty weak and you
know it was already weakened um prior to
that by the various u-turns that that
trust had to make I think it just wasn't
credible
um for her to carry on and I think it
would have been kind of an ability to
achieve much
um and I think we were already kind of
seeing seeing that um play out over the
last couple of days
okay Lila thank you very much indeed for
being with us this afternoon John Craig
is uh still with me mercilessly the uh
the um thankfully the rain has gone
um so John Let's uh talk about where we
are um was it inevitable that she was
having to go it looked that way didn't
it it's been looking that way for a few
days so that's been the prediction of
many uh MPS and back benches she
completely lost all credibility uh the
economic problems uh suela bravaman the
shouting match we're told happened
yesterday A Clash over immigration
policy then the shambles overnight let
me bring you an intriguing thought
um the the political editor of the Daily
Telegraph Ben Reilly Smith has tweeted
Boris Johnson is expected to stand for
the Tory leadership the telegraph
understands now bear in mind Boris
Johnson's relationship with the Daily
Telegraph he was a columnist for many
years remember Dominic Cummings says
that uh Boris Johnson regards The Daily
Telegraph as his real boss well an
intriguing thought all those who are
expecting a coronation
um as Sam Sam coats was discussing a
moment ago of course there's other
candidates who may throw their hats in
the ring but I mean if we thought the
party was split now I mean that would be
a move that would just cause further
eruptions and you've got the issue of
the what is it the Privileges yeah
correct that is going to meet fairly
soon I think yes I was talking about the
possible misleading of parliament I mean
it's look it's history but it's pretty
recent history yes that's right he's
still got to face that inquiry yes by a
pretty top level uh Commons committee
um I'm only mentioning it because it's
an intriguing thought there will be
those Nadine Doris is a big supporter as
we know and I mentioned that poll 33 he
was the favorite amongst in the poll
um that um for to come back and to
succeed Liz trust if she if and when she
she was toppled
um there's no doubt she has been toppled
I mean just reflecting on the events
here this morning sir Graham Brady was
in there for a good out of more than an
hour and what what convinced me the game
was up was when they sent for Jake Berry
the party chairman because clearly they
it became clear then that they had to
start a process for a new election and
so that is now underway so Graham said
just now didn't he that they're going to
give us more details but it looks as
though this idea of a coronation a Unity
candidate doesn't look as though it's
going to happen at this stage no but the
process the mechanism is that clearer
now and do you think it can work well
it's an ambitious deadline isn't it a
week
um if you if you say you've got two
three four candidates perhaps they might
have the MPS might have more than one
round of voting on in in in the same day
they really want to speed things up
and email voting by email for the party
members I guess yeah I mean what does
campaigning look like in 20 seconds well
I mean what does campaigning look like
in a campaign at last well those who are
serious about standing probably need to
State their intentions in the next 24
hours get a bit of momentum we need to
hear from Rishi sunak yeah and do you
think we will soon well if he's serious
about standing definitely yes yeah okay
thank you very much indeed a telegraph
reporting Boris Johnson may sound that
is a pretty interesting on an
extraordinary day
it is uh three o'clock this is Sky News
live from Downing Street
Liz truss resigns as prime minister
after just 44 days in office
I cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
[Music]
will be a leadership election within a
week with Liz truss saying she'll remain
as prime minister until a successor is
announced it will be possible to conduct
a ballot and conclude the leadership
election
by Friday the 28th of October this would
be a general election we can't just
allow the Tory party to keep putting up
the next candidate in the middle of this
chaos
and as labor calls for an immediate
general election we'll wait to hear who
will try to replace Liz truss all the
action for you or the reaction as well
live on Sky News
[Music]
so good afternoon from Downing Street
where Liz truss has resigned as prime
minister after just 44 days in office
she has recognized she says that she
could not deliver her mandate a
leadership election will now take place
and be completed they say in a week here
is Liz truss's statement made here in
Downing Street a short while ago
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir Graham Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well as trust mentioned him there the
chair of the 1922 committee confirming a
short time ago that a new prime minister
will be decided by next Friday here's
what's the Graham Brady said in a
statement outside Parliament
I'll be meeting with the officers of the
22 and the executive later this
afternoon we also have a meeting of the
conservative party board I have spoken
to the party chairman Jake Berry and he
has confirmed that it will be possible
to conduct a ballot and conclude the
leadership election
by Friday the 28th of October so we
should have a new leader in place before
the fiscal statement which will take
place on the 31st I'll be able to give
you more details later on this afternoon
well the labor leader secure stammer has
also been reacting to Liz truss's
statement and he has been calling for a
general election
well what a mess and this is not just a
soap opera at the top of the Tory party
is doing huge damage to our economy and
to the reputation of our country and the
public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election some sympathy for Liz trust her
time in office pretty humiliating the
damage that has been inflicted on the
public through higher prices and
mortgages is considerable this is not a
soap opera these are real lives that are
being impacted by the mess at the top of
the Tory party we've had this revolving
door we've had these experiments at the
top of the Tory party the public are
entitled to choose between this utter
chaos and a labor party which will
stabilize the economy under God clear
plan for growth for living standards and
for jobs of the future isn't there an
argument that a general election
my chance for a clean State and just to
stabilize the ship the risk at the
moment is continuing with this chaos not
having a stable labor government so
that's why there should be a general
election we can't just allow the Tory
party to keep putting up the next
candidate in the middle of this chaos
there is a choice there's a labor party
that's capable of you know stabilizing
the economy has a clear plan and the
public entitled to choose between that
stable labor government and this utter
chaos of the conservatives are you ready
for government this is not the context
you would have wanted to take over we
are ready to form a government to
stabilize the economy and Implement a
real plan for growth for living
standards to help people through a cost
of living crisis and that's the choice
now a stable labor government or this
utter chaos from the conservatives
kissimmer there sky is Chief political
correspondent John Craig joins me now at
talk Runners and Riders just a moment
first of all was this only a matter of
time yes it because there was a
Groundswell of back bench opinion and
indeed some ministers who felt that she
had to go I mean we the political team
have been talking to MPS all week or the
Tory conference the last few weeks and
clearly she'd lost support uh which all
fell apart on the day of sakwazi
quatteng although bringing in uh Jeremy
Hunt has been a popular move he went
down well at the 1922 committee uh last
night and that the signs are that
perhaps whoever becomes leader they will
keep him as Chancellor can I just bring
you back to this intriguing possibility
of Boris Johnson this is causing
excitement and controversy Sir Robert
Sims senior Tory backbencher X whip MP
for pool down on the south coast Boris
is a fantasy the number for nominations
will be lifted at to limit Runners and
there will be massive pressure on the
second candidate in MP's ballot to drop
out by the way Ladbrokes have cut Boris
Johnson's odds from 20 to one to three
to one the liberal Democrats meanwhile
are calling for Forrest Johnson to be
barred from standing
um Deputy leader Daisy Cooper says the
fact that conservative MPS are even
considering putting Boris Johnson back
in number 10 shows how to touch they are
they think there's one rule for them and
another for everyone else he was forced
to resign in disgrace she says after
countless lies scandals and failures he
shattered public trust in the government
and plunged the UK into a political
crisis he must never be allowed near
Downing street again well that's the
liberal Democrats saying that they would
say that wouldn't they is there also an
issue of whatever the Privileges
committee decide could that have an
impact on on yeah but this process of
course is going to come before that yeah
um that will obviously be an issue that
that um but the fact that it's happening
yeah I'm just hearing actually this is
from Beth Rigby our political editor a
little bit on
what the timetable nominations by Monday
um threshold might be 50 plus MPS for
nominations
um she says she's heard higher but the
1922 committee must be careful not to
look like trying to stitch it up
accelerated final round might be an
indicative vote on the effect on the
final two online ballots for members
that's what's being discussed so Graham
said we're going to hear more about that
later today okay John thank you very
much indeed let's go over to our Deputy
political editor Sam coats and Sam all
this talk of uh Boris Johnson what are
you hearing in the way of reaction to uh
Boris Johnson standing or not
but we'll find out in just a moment from
uh one MP but an extraordinary number of
MPS already wanting to stand in this
contest it's meant to be truncated it's
meant to be a coronation it's meant to
be a smooth path to succeed Liz truss
all sort of within a week that's the
last thing it feels like right now here
in central Lobby so let's talk to Bob
Sealy now he is the other white MP but
critically for our purposes uh he is a
big fan of Penny Morton who is all but
certain to stand is that right do you
think she will stand I hope she does Sam
uh I wish all the candidates well we
need a truncated process we need to get
on with things but very much hoping that
Penny will stand and I think she would
be the best person to unite her party
and lead the nation why
um I think she has a great set of
qualities she has lots of ministerial
experience I think she comes across very
well and I think she resonates with
people and right now when we are facing
a couple of international crises both in
energy but also in the Ukraine war
having somebody with stature with
government experience and who can
resonate with people I think is really
important it's interesting that you list
two crises but this the third which is
the economic crisis that we're facing at
the moment so um I'm curious because
that's the thing that she doesn't have a
great deal of experience uh of compared
to her Rivals does she have the economic
knowledge understanding in order to do
the job sorry when I meant the energy
crisis I'm talking about the the Uber
there's a wider economic crisis you
forget the mortgage crisis I mean that's
not part of the energy crisis it's
standard of living it's inflation but
anyway back to back to the main point
is Penny good enough on the economics no
Minister will have done every single
role so Rishi will be very good on some
things that be quite blind on others
that's just the nature of having
government experience so has Penny been
transferred the exchequer no but penny
has had a wide range of government jobs
and government roles she understands
government she certainly understands
economics and I think she will be a very
strong candidate I think she will be the
best candidate to unite her party lead
the nation but sure in terms of our
understanding I'm absolutely confident
that she would understand the many
different facets of government that are
important as will Rishi I'm sure as will
the other candidates so if it was Rishi
sudako ended up being elected as prime
minister you're quite happy with that
you think that he could unite the
conservative party
for sure I what we need to do and we
need to learn some lessons and learn
them pretty quickly we have a reputation
for economic competence we cannot lose
that reputation because it is being
damaged at the moment we have to get
back at what we're doing uh what we're
good at leading the nation making
decisions sometimes difficult decisions
explaining why they're in the National
interest Rishi is a great blow I have
high regard for him he's a Southampton
kid and he you know I come from a
constituency very near that I wish him
well so he would be a superb leader but
on balance on balance I would support
Penny because I think Penny would have
greater resonance in the country and I
think she would be better at uniting our
colleagues that is not to show
disrespect for any other candidate okay
that is important because we have to
think in terms of positives
um when you heard the news that Boris
Johnson's considering standing what did
you think yeah good luck to Boris I mean
I don't want to go back to a few months
ago where we were so whoever is going to
get through I think there's going to be
quite a high threshold and I will see
personally who those candidates are when
they're now when they get the numbers
I'm not changing my position if Penny
stands and it's still an if if Penny
stands I would like to see her as prime
minister because I think she has many of
the upsides many of the positives and I
think she resonates smoking you've made
the points about penny I'm asking about
Boris Johnson would you would you
support the conservative party going
backwards to the Prime Minister it had
before one would you be comfortable with
that if that was the outcome of them the
choice of MP I wanted to go forward
under Penny but whoever we are LED we've
got a unite behind so you would not
unite behind even Boris Johnson you
would think that a perfectly okay choice
if that's where it ended I'm not
factional I will respect the choice that
we collectively make and I would implore
all my colleagues to respect the choice
that we collectively make but I want us
to go forward with Penny what what do
you think your vaters would make of it
if Boris Johnson ended up being prime
minister again I don't know and I think
discussing hypotheticals is probably
pointlessam I think penny is going to
have the best set of qualities to lead
us I hope she does I will respect as I'm
sure all my colleagues will the outcome
of that election but I think penny is
the best person to unite the party and
Lead our nation hypothetical is the name
of the game in the leadership contest uh
uh Bob Sealy there making the case for
Penny mordant but if Boris Johnson
actually descends into this race it's
gonna end up being quite something Unity
not necessarily being one of them
thanks very much Sam joining me now is
the SMP Deputy leader at Westminster
Kirsty Oswald thank you very much for
being Kirsten Oswald I apologies um so
what is your reaction
well you know it's extraordinary isn't
it I think you could say it's
unbelievable but then you know I think
we've all seen this coming and and
thought frankly they it couldn't come
soon enough that this trust stepped down
I must say that the continuing chaos
following her announcement is not voting
well for what comes next I think that
people away from the Westminster bubble
are absolutely sick Fed Up of all of
this internally focused chaos that the
Tory party is visiting upon them and
particularly because they're probably
also really worried about things like
their mortgage bills which are
increasing significantly because of the
chaos that the Tory party has inflicted
on them so these are really challenging
times really serious times
um and I I fear for for what comes next
given some of the conversations that
I've just heard on your Channel
what you're um you're talking about but
Boris Johnson what do you think the
chance the I mean what what do you make
of him possibly standing in this
leadership election I mean there are so
many unanswered questions about the
leadership election so we've um been
told it will take a week for them to
have a leadership contest and put a new
prime minister into place now I
certainly don't want us to go back to
the days of the Summer where the Tory
party were consumed by infighting for
the 54 DS which it took for them to run
their last leadership contest and you
know that's actually 10 days longer than
Liz truss actually has lasted in office
but to suggest that in seven days time
there can be a reasonable way of
selecting the next prime minister I
think that that's for the birds there's
only one sensible way to allow you know
a decision to be taken on what should
happen about who is going to be prime
minister and that's actually for the the
people to decide and I think that people
away from Westminster are looking in I
think horror at what is going on here
this is not a democratic way of working
it's chaos it's a shambles with all the
uh the you know all the the twoing and
throwing in the lobby last night which
was really unedifying and I think that
that's just exactly how things are here
at Westminster it's it's really a a
challenge to think that this is the best
way that a democratic system can run and
if you think about people in Scotland
seeing the prospect of yet another
conservative prime minister being voiced
upon us we've not voted for a
conservative government in Scotland
since the 1950s and yet here we have
this suggestion that we should just take
what we get take another Tory prime
minister
um and and I don't think that that's
democratically sustainable and I don't
think that it's good for democracy or
for the people of Scotland we can do an
awful lot better than that the reality
is you're sorry to interrupt but the
reality is you're not going to get a
general election night
well I think that actually the the Tory
MPS need to look very closely at
themselves in the mirror here they need
to grow a backbone this is not a
sustainable situation it's not a
democratic situation and looking at the
internal wranglings of the Tory party
which has been their entire Focus for
months and months on end and we see that
that's going to continue to be their
entire Focus I don't think that they
will be able to look at themselves in
the mirror and say that that is right
and proper it's obviously not the way
that things should be run and and really
the people who should be making the
decision about what comes next are the
general public and I think that the
general public in Scotland will have a
very clear view that the way that
Westminster has shown itself to work is
absolutely not the way that sensible
country would run itself and and no
wonder there are so many more people
seeking to have that conversation about
the better future that Scotland can have
with Independence we can certainly do
better than this
okay thank you very much appreciate your
time this afternoon thank you
let's go back to uh Deputy Felicia
there's a Sam coats who is in the
central lobby of the houses of
Parliament Sam
thanks very much Mark so we're digesting
the news that this leadership contest
barely a couple of hours old is wide
open with all sorts of people throwing
their hat in the ring we haven't yet
heard from Raymond chisty but the whole
of the rest of the panoply already
getting going with Penny Morden quite
clearly going to run Rishi sunak is in
the running and now these reports
actually of Boris Johnson plotting a
comeback with a bevery of MPS including
his former top aide in Parliament James
dudridge calling to for Boris Johnson to
return so let's see how all of that's
going down with MPS Justin Tomlinson
let's just start with Boris Johnson how
would you feel about him coming back to
Parliament I mean I I
I mean I would genuinely be surprised if
that actually happens like I was part of
Team Boris I was disappointed to see him
go but I I think it's probably too soon
I think that's probably wishful thinking
from some of my uh colleagues on that
front why do you say XTC I just I just
think it's too soon that the the I was
there supporting him to the very end but
he did lose the confidence of the
majority of our colleagues I thought
that was wrong but you have to respect
that and I don't think in a sufficient
enough time has probably passed for for
the party to then unite behind him and
for me this now is about as frankly been
grown up being pragmatic and putting the
country first because these are serious
times are you saying that it's not grown
grown up to think that you can bring
back Boris Johnson so soon no as in I
think we all now just have to find a way
that we can unite as a team now I
couldn't care less whether people are
ERG One Nation voted remain voted brexit
I want the very best people in those top
positions on ability best media
performers cabinet ministers can deliver
quickly because we owe it to people the
market matters these are people's
pensions it's people's mortgage rates
this is our ability to service
government debt and fund public services
and I'm I'm not going to lose any sleep
over who ends up being the Prime
Minister as long as it is a team this is
bigger than an individual now we need
every one of those people at the top
table and pulling their weight
um are you a little bit nervous that
already just in the last couple of hours
we've got such a big long list where
she's seen that Penny mordant uh Brandon
Lewis is thinking about putting his hat
in the ring Kami badenock and now these
rooms are at Boris Johnson you've ruled
the hope of a Unity candidate nobody's
behaving like that are they well look
the process is going to be swift people
are going to fly kites but I think there
is the mood is that we have to
consolidate very quickly and the
successful person will be the one who
can convince the others that they can be
part of their team so I was a big
supporter of Cami bandernok in the last
leadership contest with one of our best
natural performers great in the media
great with the briefs that she gets
given she has to be part of that top
team the same would apply to Tom
tuguenot same would apply of any of
those names that you've listed they've
got to be part of the team that sounds
like you're saying chemical really
shouldn't expect to become Prime
ministering is those people need to have
that conversation and between them agree
a way that they are all part of that
because this isn't about the individual
this is about the team Boris was a
one-off he could carry the party as an
individual at his Peak is proved with
our former prime minister that wasn't
possible you've now we owe it to the
country to get our best people because
we've got to deliver quickly we've got
to deliver credibly and we've got to be
pragmatic here if you're going to get a
new prime minister within a week how can
you consult the members well what we've
got I I've been doing media so I didn't
actually hear how the rules would work
over the next week but this is my point
that the person who I think should be
successful is the one who can convince
those who've got a chance with their
flying of their kites that they should
all unite behind and all be part of that
it has to be a team effort going forward
do you think rounds of voting in
Parliament is the way to sort that out
or do you think even that's a bit too
divisive and you should just lock the
grandis in a room and let them decide I
would hope but the Grandes are the
candidates there is no party Grandes the
thing of sort of you know older
gentleman in the smoking room that's
nonsense it is about this people who
have a realistic chance they're the ones
who have to have the conversations not
their AIDS not their friends not their
Runners they need to get in and go and
have those conversations and they need
to find a way that they're all part of
that now if that can't happen they will
have to be votes but they have to be
done on an understanding that this is
the absolute Last Chance Saloon for us
to have credibility in representing the
country that's my point about being
grown up being pragmatic and they're all
going to have to run around that's why
I'm not going to lose any sleep over who
the individual is as long as the team is
strong final thing and politics is
brutal there's trust God after barely a
month in office we can't forget her
entirely
did Liz trust do anything right will she
deliver the energy support package and
that's making a difference to people's
lives as we speak that was the one that
was completely Rewritten on Monday
morning well it's giving people on
average up to a thousand pounds off
their typical bills and then the top-ups
for those on disability benefits
pensioners and means tested benefits and
that's making a difference here in
Outlook it's been a difficult time if it
was a difficult time should still be a
prime minister but the country isn't
wanting us to look backwards it's
wanting us to look forward and
colleagues greater than me need to be
having those conversations and quickly
Justin Tomlinson there picking this
trust is one success or something that
had to be Rewritten on Monday and saying
that the party needs to get together
behind a new candidate gosh it's
difficult mark
Sam thanks again thank you very much so
uh where are where are we as we come up
to about uh 25 past three half past
three is it well just after uh 1 30 this
afternoon Liz truss stood on the steps
of Downing Street the same steps where
44 days ago she pledged to deliver
deliver uh deliver this time though she
announced her resignation she says she
came into office at a time of great
International instability but hers is a
Premiership that will be characterized
by infighting and chaotic u-turns she
will likely now be remembered as the
shortest serving prime minister in
British history as a political
correspondent Ali Fortescue now looks
back at her political career
even Liz cross's greatest critics will
praise the political skill that led her
all the way to Downing Street we
shouldn't be daunted by the challenges
we face
as strong as the storm may be I know
that the British people are stronger
catapulted to number 10 with a mandate
from the membership to challenge a
status quo but a mini budget just two
weeks into the job set in motion Liz
trusses downfall
and lost another Tory leader the
confidence of the party I think one of
the potentially early missteps on the
political side was to form an
Administration that was so heavily
weighted to those that were on one side
of the leadership contest and not to
have reached out a bit more to the other
side
Liz Strauss was politically engaged from
a young age growing up in Glasgow and
Leeds she described her parents as
left-wing at Oxford University she was
even president of the liberal Democrats
there are two main problems with this
amendment conference it was in her late
30s the woman who would become Prime
Minister began to rise through the Tory
ranks she carved out a position on the
right of the party and became a
Grassroots favorite
despite her at times awkward public
appearances
we import two-thirds of our cheese
that is a disgrace
in cabinet she was seen by some as a
troublemaker determined to get her way
some were surprised to see Boris Johnson
promote her to foreign secretary
when the search began to replace him she
made it onto the final ballot for the
leadership by just eight votes mordant
one zero five
sunac one three seven
truss one one three
a path then through the Tory membership
was rarely endowed
exactly the idea of being stuck in a
lift with care style but strikes being
extremely boring
it was once she got the job things began
to unravel his trusses Premiership bid
off course two days after becoming the
Queen's 15th prime minister she was
confronted by a nation in mourning
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from Balmoral
when politics eventually did return the
new prime minister was on the back foot
you're prepared to be unpopular aren't
you yes yes I am pushing ahead with a
bold tax cutting agenda blamed for
Market turmoil and political unrest
I'm not going to cut the additional rate
of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
then unceremoniously sacking her
Chancellor and close friend
quasi-quarting is crazy quieting
shirtless trust resign authority never
recovered
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend and he shares my
vision to set this country on the path
to Grace
the man she hoped could steady the
economy and save her Premiership tried
firstly we will reverse almost all the
tax measures announced in the growth
plan three weeks ago that have not
started parliamentary legislation
but that left Liz truss a prime minister
without a purpose as her home secretary
resigned in chaotic scenes emerge from
The Commons last night it became clear
she couldn't hold on
Liz truss came into office at a time of
global instability but hers was a
Premiership characterized by infighting
and u-turns and shall be remembered as
the shortest serving prime minister in
British history Ali faulsku Sky News
Westminster
so a new leader of the conservative
party and a new prime minister could be
in place by next Friday but just who are
the runners and riders for leadership
well uh three of the leadership
candidate who ran in the summer are
expected to run again Penny Morden the
leader of the house is expected to be
one of the favorites as is the former
chancellorishi sunak who came second in
the summer to Liz truss in that
leadership race and kemi badnock the
international trade secretary could also
run
it's also being reported that Liz
truss's predecessor Boris Johnson could
run again the times and Telegraph are
both saying they're expecting him to go
for the leadership Grant chaps could
also run he was made Home Secretary
uh when was it only yesterday that cave
after Sue Ella bravaman was forced to
resign as Home Secretary she may run as
well
and two of the other leadership
candidates in the summer could also run
security minister Tom tugenhart May
throw his hat into the ring and the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
Nadine zawi may also fancy his chances
let's go back to our Deputy
ballisticated to Sam coats everybody
wants to talk to Sam this afternoon who
have you got uh with you now Sam
uh with me now Mark is Brennan Clark
Smith he's basketball MP and critically
I think that you might describe yourself
as part of the bring back Boris campaign
is that right and why I'd say that's
very fair Sam yes I mean obviously I'm
very disappointed today that the Prime
Minister has taken the decision to
resign I think she's a decent person who
wanted to deliver for this country and
to have the chance to do that and I
think it's a shame she hasn't been able
to in the end but really what we need
now we need someone who can come in we
need someone who can bring people
together somebody who actually has got
that mandate so a mandate from the
people at the last general election a
mandate from party members and somebody
actually who can get this party going
again get us winning elections again the
only person that I think that ticks all
those boxes is Boris Johnson do you
think he's interested
I think potentially I think I'd
encourage colleagues um to to make their
feelings felt with that and I was on
holiday with this family at the moment
um certainly I'd urge him to stand again
I think he's the only person who can
actually dig us out of this mess and
then if he comes back again I would
appeal to parliamentary colleagues look
at what we're in if we don't pull
together as a party now we can't deliver
for this country and that's what we need
to do Sam
um clearly some people have been tipped
the wink that he's actually interested
in the job you're fairly certain that
he's going to give it a crack well he
never wanted to leave the job he loved
doing the job as prime minister and you
you see the enthusiasm he always used to
have for it and of course it was cut
shortly elected with that historic HTC
majority in 2019 all the plans for
leveling up all of the things you wanted
to achieve and I think really he wants
to be able to finish that job so yes I
think he would be interested and that's
why I'm urging him now to put his name
forward but given that he was ejected
from Downing Street because large
numbers of Tory MPS were shame to keep
him there because they didn't feel that
he adhered to the standards necessary
for the office how could he be a Unity
candidate well I think we have to
remember he did win the last confidence
vote that he had as well but I think
also colleagues I think we need to
realize that the public are sick of
politicians Naval gazing and really we
want some grown-up politics really if we
carry on squabbling between ourselves
we're never going to get anything done
as a government but you've got to
acknowledge he would be divisive because
all those people wanted him out and
don't want him back we've been talking
to them on skynees this afternoon some
of them but it's about bringing together
people on both sides I think Sam really
I think you know letting bygones be
bygones and looking at the bigger
picture why we all got elected here in
the first place and yes that means some
compromise but we're all going to have
to compromise we're all going to have to
come together because if we don't let's
be frank a lot of people here aren't
going to be MPS in a couple of years
time I mean at the moment the
conservatives have a 71 majority Boris
Johnson won't be able to keep that
majority pushed through change if he
becomes prime minister again surely well
I think we need to look at grown-up
politics Sam and as I say we're having
people calling for general elections now
we're looking at what's happening with
the markets and so on and we need some
stability really and I think colleagues
are kind of getting the realization of
that uh in the last few weeks I think
they say a week is a long time in
politics it certainly has been this week
and I think really it's time for a bit
of reflection really but again it's
about being grown up it's about coming
together it's about letting the past be
the past and looking towards the future
when I talked to Tory MPS it's the red
wall MP people like yourself who want to
but but the blue wall MPS arguably
vulnerable in different direction
they're the ones that um are nervous
about the Boris Johnson Republic do you
recognize that as a bit of a divide in
the party here one of the problems that
he's going to overcome that's a fair
point and as I say we had a lot of new
MPS coming in
um Boris is very popular in my
constituency in the red wall as we say
um but really the conservative party
were a broad Church you look at some of
the new people who've been coming in
recently into cabinets as well and I
think if Boris Johnson comes back you
will be able to shape that so we can
include more people and kind of bring
them into that big tent that we've
really got and I think that's vital
whoever becomes the leader gets 100
backing from the rest of the
Parliamentary party because if that
doesn't happen it's the road to Oblivion
some
thank you very much indeed Brennan Clark
Smith who thinks that Boris Johnson can
unify the conservative party and bring
back grown-up politics he says
[Music]
Sam thank you very much for joining me
now as the former conservative special
advisor under David Cameron Lauren
mccavett and also the chief leader
writer at The Observer and former
advisor to Ed miliband Sonia soda and
Sonia I think it was 48 hours ago or
something that you were telling me that
you thought it was all over and uh well
as far as this trust is concerned it is
now
yeah well I think I can hardly take
credit for that there were lots of other
people making that prediction as well
but I think you know it's it's
surprising how quickly it's happened but
I think after the scenes in Parliament
that we saw last night it became very
clear that Liz truss had sort of
suffered a dramatic loss of confidence
in her parliamentary party and the fact
of the matter is we live in a
parliamentary democracy and if you can't
if you don't have the authority to
govern if you don't have the backing of
your MPS in Parliament it does mean that
you need to go and I think that's what's
happened today but I think when we take
a step back she's left the country in an
appalling mess the economy is in a much
worse State than when she arrived and
that in large part not only because of
her but the mini budget that she and
quasi quateng uh announced in the market
reaction to that has left the UK in a
much worse place economically
um and it means that the entry of the
next prime minister is really pretty
Grim
um huge questions left by her
resignation now which is that the
conservative party has said there
collect a new leader in a week how is
that going to be done who will get a say
what kind of democratic mandate will
they have I mean obviously they won't
have one in the sense that they won't
have been a general election so you are
going to continue to see labor put
pressure on uh for a general election
regardless of who it is who gets picked
and how it is and I think there's still
a certain amount of uncertainty about
who it will be
yeah Lauren we're looking at a lot of
people declaring uh that they're running
a lot of Runners and Riders we've just
been through a few of them
um the next week or 10 days or so it
could be just as chaotic
absolutely and I don't think it's going
to be particularly edifying for my party
and I don't think it's going to be
particularly stable for the country
um but I think that there is absolutely
no question facing our party right now
for which Boris Johnson is the answer
um he is not in Parliament at the moment
he's on holiday in the middle of term um
in the Caribbean he is not a uniting
figure for the conservative party
um he would have absolutely no prayer of
governing a national Unity government
this is what we really need going into
quite a very a very difficult winter
um and I think we need somebody who has
some personal Integrity left and I don't
believe that he left office with any so
I really don't believe that he's the
solution to our problem
but the recent poll showed Lauren that
he's pretty popular with the membership
I think that's why it's very important
that the the Parliamentary party
narrowed down the list to two people
with very high thresholds very quickly
because I do not believe that his former
parliamentary colleagues are going to
put him on that ballot I may well be
wrong about that but if they do I
believe it is a mistake and I believe we
were going to get one Almighty kicking
in the polls not just in a general but
if we don't call a general very quickly
in the locals in May and we could be in
real trouble there
Sonia what do you think of Boris Johnson
possibly standing
you know that there is this thing which
is he's always been very popular with
the conservative party membership and
um you know there's been a lot of talk
from his allies around how party members
feel that he was forced out by the
cabinet by MPS
um and that they would have still liked
to seen him be prime minister but the
fact of the matter is who are the who
are the conservative party membership to
tell us that we live in a parliamentary
democracy and Boris Johnson very clearly
lost the support of his MPS and that's
why he had to go and I think the idea
that he could come back after the
disrespect that he showed the country
um you know still this open question
that the standards committee are looking
at did he mislead Parliament
unbelievable that somebody could even
consider trying to put their sorry their
hat in as prime minister when you've got
an investigation like that still ongoing
yet to report all the stuff around
um parties in Downing Street the
disrespect that he showed people who
respected the laws around covid I think
it's completely inconceivable and I I
agree with Lauren that I you know I
think there are some MPS in the
Parliamentary party who would like to
see him back but I think it would be a
real mistake I think um you know I don't
think there's any sense that the
Public's view of Boris Johnson has
shifted very much so
um I I think the question really is
though
um is it right that members would get a
say
um is it right that this tiny
unrepresentative sliver of the
electorate get to select our next prime
minister I really think not I think MPS
have to pick um the the next candidate
for prime minister conservative MPS and
ideally we would have a general election
I don't think we're going to get one
because I think conservative MPS are
very worried quite rightly about what's
going to happen in that general election
but I think the idea the conservative
party members were responsible for trust
the idea that it would go out to a group
of people who are so unrepresentative
who don't speak for voters again I think
that's very troubling indeed
yeah and Lauren just finally there may
not be a clamor for Boris Johnson but
there might well be a clamor for a
general election
um how do you think the conservatives
will play this just reject it out of
hand
I think there is a credibility argument
about a conservative party that's gone
through three leaders since the last
general election however there's also an
argument that our credibility now is so
low that there's absolutely nothing that
could take it further and there's only
repair work that can be done and since
that's the case I think that the party's
probably likely to say that they don't
want one
okay uh thank you both very much indeed
well let's just bring you up to date
then with what's been happening this
afternoon earlier just after half past
one Liz truss resigned as prime minister
after just 44 days in office she said
she recognized that she could not
deliver on her mandate a leadership
election will now be completed they say
within a week here is Liz truss's
statement in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills on on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well all the attention here is now
focused of course on who will replace
Liz trust with reports this afternoon
that Boris Johnson is considering uh
standing in the leadership election
joining me now is former special advisor
to Amber Rudd Mo Hussein thank you very
much for being with us so
um what do you think of the possibility
that Boris Johnson may be standing
well I mean anything is possible given
what we've seen the last few months and
there's always been a bit of speculation
that he could try and make a comeback at
some point and people could wish for
what they had before uh the the mess and
the turmoil of the last few weeks but I
sometimes I think it's also quite easy
to look at things through Rose tinted
glasses as well yes he is an electoral
asset he has been in the past he did win
lots of seats in places around the
country that have never voted
conservative before but also he did
oversee Mass resignations from his
government lots and lots of MPS
ministers resigned because they were so
fed up with him and his behavior and he
also lost two quite big by-elections as
well so I think it's easy just to look
at he's the one that we need he's got
the gold the Gold Dust the Stardust to
try and get things through but actually
it was a more complicated picture and I
don't think people forget the negative
as well particularly if you're an MP he
was marched up the hill several times to
go and defend something or explain
something and then there was a U-turn
and you were you were the one who's left
looking a bit silly in front of your
constituents or on the media
and if it's not going to be Boris
Johnson who do you think uh will I mean
they're all sort of you know showing
their hand uh today gradually I mean who
do you think will come through
I think there's a few names in the frame
probably a lot of the people who tried a
few months ago feels a bit like
groundhog day but certainly the Rishi
sunax the penny moderns there were other
more interesting people I think you
didn't make a show last time like
Brandon Lewis who is said to be thinking
about it as well the challenge thing
forward though is you can have lots of
people and they can all present
different ideas but as we've seen the
last week or so the market is actually
really really important in this the
economic situation the country is facing
does not change just because you have a
different prime minister and if we're
just promised a positive things a
promise boosterism they'll promise more
tax cuts without a real plan for how the
next prime minister is going to help the
country get through this economic crisis
then unfortunately we're just going to
be in the same situation again so I hope
whoever does run does put forward a more
real world credible plan even if it's
not necessarily what people want to hear
and that will involve as we heard from
the the now our new Chancellor difficult
decisions going forward
but the prospect of any new leader or
combination of new leadership actually
winning the next election is um well
that's going to be a very tall order
indeed isn't it
yeah it will be difficult it would be
it's called a historic fifth term for a
reason because it's never happened
before on either side and it will be
challenging and I think there will be a
lot of calls from people to go to an
election
sooner as well because this will be the
third prime minister in space of a year
and if you're going to diverge even more
and we've seen this did not end well for
the current prime minister diverge even
more from the manifesto and from the
commitments are actually made and pursue
a very uh libertarian or very kind of
Fringe way of dealing with the economy
then that doesn't really work you always
need to try and govern I think from the
center ground so
um even if there is a new prime minister
they try and hold out for as long as
they can an election is coming and they
don't have very long to really set out
their own store put their own record
forward in terms of what they will have
delivered and how that is different to
the Johnson Administration how that is
different to the shortened Trust
Administration
okay saying appreciate your time and
your perspective thank you very much
indeed joining me now is the
conservative MP for South Cambridgeshire
Anthony Brown uh well uh first of all
um this whole idea of Boris Johnson
possibly standing uh what do you make of
that
well I think the challenge he would have
would be getting through the MPS because
remember these are exactly the same
people who uh ousted him uh three months
ago and he had the resignation of
fastest government in in one day it's
still got the procedures committee
investigation hanging over him uh we
don't know the result of that that's
carrying on at the moment so I think
that would be his uh main challenge the
one I would urge to stand is that is
Rishi sunak actually he came first in
the membership polls uh in every single
round of the last leadership election
and it's clearly got the economic
credibility uh which we need at this
moment in time
and do you think the membership should
have a say in in this contest this time
what I'd like to see actually as a Unity
candidate where we all get around we
know how divisive these leadership
campaigns are we've just seen that a few
months ago if you had a Unity candidate
that we could all support and that goes
forward then it would be uh far better
for the party but far better for the
country that you've clearly got one
individual who commands the confidence
of uh of conservative MPS and Parliament
generally
I mean there's an issue here though that
people have little faith in the party
now to move on given the the chaos of
the past few weeks so isn't the right
thing to do uh concede to a general
election
well no I agree this has not been a good
time for conservative party and as a
conservative MP obviously I'm somewhat
aggrieved by that but what matters is
what's best for the country uh I think
what the country needs now is stability
it doesn't need a a general election
campaign we need to get a new leader who
commands the confidence of the House of
Commons uh who can help with the various
crises that the country is having I
think what we need is a period of cool
calm competent government no fireworks
no dramas please we've had enough of
that over the last five years or so uh
and that if we have this cool competent
government delivering for uh voters and
I think they will return to us but the
ultimate answer to your question is we
have a parliamentary system not a
presidential system uh in the
parliamentary system the person who's
prime minister is the one who commands
the majority uh of the House of Commons
it's not we are you don't elect an
individual as prime minister
no I understand that but does it become
undemocratic eventually to foist one
prime minister after another on the
country
well people voters voted for their mp uh
they didn't vote for the Prime Minister
I'm the only people who voted for the
prime minister or the people uh and the
prime minister's constituency and as I
said that's the system we have clearly
if the new leaders elected they may well
feel uh likes to raise the May that they
need to have an election to uh to ensure
their mandate as it were but when Gordon
Brown took over from Tony Blair there
wasn't a general election when John
Major took over from Margaret Thatcher
there wasn't a general an immediate
general election and I can see no
particular constitutional reason why you
should have that now what matters is
stability restoring confidence in the
financial markets we're going through
that now I think Jeremy Hunter's done an
amazing job uh doing that in a very
short period of time and as I said
addressing the best crisis we have I
think most people plunging the country
into a general election campaign when
there's so much that needs fixing uh
most voters will be banging their heads
on the table saying no please just get
on with the job voters want governments
that are competent that it can fix the
problems that concern voters and broadly
share their values and I think that's
what we need
just finally isn't it about credibility
and hasn't your party just shed its
credibility now
well as I said earlier I you know it'd
be ridiculous to pretend this wasn't bad
for conservative party you know clearly
I think all conservative MPS have been
as well as a country widely deeply
frustrated about what's been going on it
hasn't been us at our best but I think
if we do uh choose a leader who can
unite the party who can lead the country
in a a cool competent government in the
years ahead then I think if we can feel
that the country if voters feel the
country is getting better then they will
come back to us and the next general
election isn't due for another two years
more than two years and two years as an
eternity in politics we've seen how much
can happen in a day or a week uh you
know two years is a very long way away
and certainly plenty of enough time for
a new leader to show that they are
capable of delivering to the country
okay Anthony Brown thanks very much
indeed now the first minister of
Scotland Nicholas sturgeon has been
reacting to the prime minister's
resignation that's here to uh let's hear
what she had to say prime minister well
this is an Almighty mate and it's people
the London Bridge of the UK who are
paying the price of this you know I
think Liz truss's early resignation as
prime minister was probably inevitable
the moment she walked into Downing
Street but let's trust isn't the problem
here she's the symptom of a much more
fundamental problem you know a broken
Tory party certainly but also a broken
UK political system what needs to happen
now well on a UK level there must be a
general election it is a democratic
necessity the idea that the Tories can
unite behind a prime minister now any
prime minister let alone one that is in
the public interest I think it's for the
birds but fundamentally at the UK now
needs to have a Democrat Choice over its
next prime minister there's even
ludicrous suggestions this afternoon
that Boris Johnson is going to try to
make a comeback so that's what what
needs to happen immediately of course
for Scotland that doesn't really solve
the fundamental problem because
Scotland's votes don't determine the
outcome of UK general elections so as
long as we're part of this Westminster
system we're always going to be
vulnerable to getting Prime Ministers we
don't vote for implementing policies
that we don't support and do real damage
to the country for Scotland the only way
we get Prime Ministers and governments
that the greater number of us vote for
is to be independent and I think the
Democratic case for Independence is
growing literally with every hour that
passes let's trust said so John Craig is
uh here so Nicholas sturgeon wants an
election Kia stama wants an election
will they get one no all the opposition
parties of course they want an election
but the one of the things that Tories
whoever becomes leader will be
absolutely determined to do is not hold
an election right now given the way the
opinion polls are at the moment um I
should tell you a few moments ago Wendy
Morton the much criticized Chief whip
who quit and then unquit uh in the
middle of the night she's gone back in
there not quite sure what particular
aspects of Commons business they're
discussing it may be they're talking
about what to do about those MPS who
didn't vote
um in the controversial vote on fracking
last night one of those who did not vote
was Theresa May although she was paired
Theresa May has offered us her thought
she says that the prime minister is
right to provide a road map for an
orderly transition MPS must now be
prepared to compromise that chance you
might say it is our duty to provide
sensible competent government at this
critical moment for our country now
since we last spoke I think you
mentioned to one of your guests actually
Brett or one of the guests mentioned it
Brandon Lewis is said to be considering
standing he's the current uh justice
secretary
oh the field is getting bigger and
bigger there was an intriguing to speak
as a question about how long is that
going to take yeah exactly I mean it's
very ambitious timetable let's say
Graham Brady's talking about
um the uh penny mordant is taking
soundings from colleagues clearly there
are a lot of potential candidates and
this idea of a Theresa May talks about
compromise a compromise candidate a
Unity candidate doesn't look as though
that is going to happen
now the fact that Wendy Morton's gone
back in clearly some aspects of Commons
business they're going to talk about
could well be the discipline but
discipline has broken down
um the on the the whole Boris Johnson
question intriguingly some political
journalist tweeted that he was on his
way back this evening but it looks as
though the tweet's been deleted so
perhaps he's not right
interestingly he supported his Trust of
course yeah yeah I mean she was seen
very much as the continuity candidate
there was a day a day the cabinet met
when I remember Jacob Reese MOG and uh
and Nadine Doris walked over here to our
cameras just over there and said we're
backing Liz truss
um now Dean Doris of course we'd love to
see Boris you might change her mind
about standing down from Parliament
um not in it but is that because he
wants to be seen to be getting on with
this
um statement on uh October 31st but he
did say an interview with Beth Rigby a
few days ago I don't want it Mrs hunt
doesn't want it and my three children
don't want it so it's fair to say he's
ruled himself out he would hope to stay
on as Chancellor whoever becomes the
leader and by all accounts I mean I was
at the 22 last night and the amps came
out of there say very impressed by his
calming reassuring performance okay John
thank you very much indeed joining me
now is the leader of the liberal
Democrats the Ed Davey who is in
Westminster thank you very much for
being with us so Kia starmer wants an
election Nicholas sturgeon wants an
election do you want an election
yes I do for this reason Liz trust has
trashed the British economy with her
unfunded tatskus and before her Boris
Johnson failed our country with his lies
in law breaking and the conservatives
just shown they're not fit to govern our
country and we don't want another Tory
prime minister trying to lead a divided
party it's just not going to work our
country needs strong leadership in these
extremely difficult times where millions
of families are struggling and I think
the only way to get to that position
where you can help people properly is
for a general election of concert is to
go
I mean the reality is as John Craig was
just saying you're not going to get one
well I respect John Craig very much but
if conservative MPS did their patriotic
Duty and for once put the national
interest the interest that constituents
above their party interest they would
vote for a general election with the
opposition parties if they don't liberal
Democrats will campaign relentlessly
against them uh We've shown in the last
sort of 60 months that we can beat many
conservative MPS in our three
by-election victories in True Blue
territory in the in the blue wall and I
believe you're only going to get rid of
the conservatives out of Downing Street
out of government by seeing many liberal
Democrats elected to Parliament the next
election
but more likely than you getting a
general election is according to reports
today Boris Johnson
standing for the leadership
well frankly with this Boris Johnson
Richie sunac or any other conservative
MP that party is now unleadable it's so
divided and the irony of Boris Johnson I
think will send shivers down the spine
to many people he broke the law he lied
to Parliament he's still hasn't finished
the inquiry into his law breaking he's
not fit to government we've known that
for many many a long time and but that
symptomatic emblematic of the whole
conservative party now you know once
they stood for economic competence and
now they've completely lost that by
trashing the economy and you know I
talked to my concessions there are many
many people who are looking to this
winter deeply worried worried about the
heating bills what about being cold or
about the food prices which are going up
so fast and now worrying about their
mortgage costs this is a truly worrying
time and I don't think the concert has
shown they've got any ideas any of them
have got ideas about to solve this
problem and that's why I think we need
real chain and that needs a general
election
but the Privileges committee into Boris
Johnson is a long way from
um coming up with any sort of conclusion
and I suppose you could argue at least
Boris Johnson has some sort of mandate
well frankly he's shown that he's not
fit to govern our country and if there
was an inquiry hanging over his head
that's not going to lead to political
stability that our country needs and
this is the point if you want economic
stability so interest rates can come
down so people aren't paying so much on
their mortgages if you want economic
stability so we can have a proper growth
strategy we need political stability as
well and that's critical you can't get
economics ability unless you get that
political stability first and the
conservative party has shown that they
cannot do that they are so divided I
mean the lobbies in the Commons last
night they were at each other's throat
um I've never seen anything like it it's
chaotic and it's become very personal
it's become pretty nasty and I just
don't think they are fit to govern our
wonderful country we have a great
country I'm proud to be British and I
just wish the conservatives could could
do the job but they can't they have to
go but to be a general election and it's
shame on conservative MPS if they can
can't see that
but uh Jeremy Hunt has brought some
economic stability and there will be
those who will argue that a combination
of Rishi sunak and Jeremy Hunt could
bring the kind of economic stability
this country this country wants
well there's not the fairness that our
country needs you know British people go
out and work hard they bring up the kids
they look after the neighbors they run
the businesses okay all they want from
the government is a fair deal and we're
just not getting there from the
conservatives okay Ed David we've got to
leave it there we've come to the end of
the hour thanks so much for joining us
so uh there we are it's a well I mean
what an afternoon Liz truss has uh
resigned uh just after 1 30 this
afternoon she came out of the office and
said that uh of Downey Street and said
that she could not fulfill her mandate
and she was resigning
it is four o'clock this is Sky News live
from Downing Street
Liz trust resigns as prime minister
after just 44 days in office
on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
there will be a leadership election
within a week say the Tories with Liz
truss saying she'll remain as prime
minister until a successor is announced
that will be possible to conduct a
ballot and conclude the leadership
election
by Friday the 28th of October
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
is expected to stand for the leadership
we'll bring you all the possible Runners
and Riders
this should be a general election we
can't just allow the Tory party to keep
putting up the next candidate in the
middle of this chaos
foreign as labor calls for an immediate
general election we'll bring you all the
reaction live
[Music]
good afternoon then from Downing Street
where Liz truss has resigned as prime
minister after just 44 days in office
she said she recognized that she could
not deliver on her mandate a leadership
election will be completed within a week
with the race to succeed her wide open
we'll bring you the possible Runners and
Riders to be the next prime minister in
a moment but first here is Liz truss's
resignation statement in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well the chair of the 1922 committee
confirmed earlier this afternoon that a
new prime minister will be in place will
be decided by Friday here's what's the
gray and Brady said in a statement
outside Parliament
I'll be meeting with the officers of the
22 and the executive later this
afternoon we also have a meeting of the
conservative party board I have spoken
to the party chairman Jake Berry and he
has confirmed that it will be possible
to conduct a ballot and conclude the
leadership election
by Friday the 28th of October so we
should have a new leader in place
before the fiscal statement which will
take place on the 31st I'll be able to
give you more details later on this
afternoon
so a new leader a new prime minister
will be decided by next Friday but just
who are the runners and riders for the
leadership
well there are a lot of them three of
the leadership candidates who ran in the
summer expected to run again Penny
Morton the leader of the house is
expected to be one of the favorites as
is the former Chancellor Rishi sunak who
came second in the summer to Liz truss
in the leadership race and Kenny bednock
is uh International Trade secretary she
could also run
it's also being reported that Liz
truss's predecessor Boris Johnson could
run the times and Telegraph are both
saying they're expecting him to go for
the leadership Grant chaps could also
run he was made Home Secretary only
yesterday that came after suela bravaman
was forced to resign as Home Secretary
she may run two and two of the other
leadership candidates in the summer
could also run uh here they are security
minister Tom tugenhart may he throw his
hat in the ring and also the chancellor
of the duchy of Lancaster Nadim zahawi
may also fancy his chances
well speaking in the last hour or so the
conservative MP for the Isle of Wight
Bob Sealy told our Deputy political
letter Sam Coates he'll be backing Penny
Morton for the leadership
good luck to Boris I mean I don't want
to go back to a few months ago where we
were so whoever is going to get through
I think there's going to be quite a high
threshold and I will see personally who
those candidates are when they announce
when they get the numbers I'm not
changing my position if Penny stands and
it's still an if if Penny stands I would
like to see her as prime minister
because I think she has many of the
upsides many of the positives and I
think she resonates working you've made
the points about penny I'm asking about
Boris Johnson would you would you
support the conservative party going
backwards to the Prime Minister it had
before one would you be comfortable with
that if that was the outcome of them the
choice of MPS I wanted to go forward
under Penny but whoever we elect we've
got to unite behind
well the labor leader sirma has been
reacting to the prime minister's
resignation and he has called for a
general election
what a mess and this is not just a soap
opera at the top of the Tory party is
doing huge damage to our economy and to
the reputation of our country and the
public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election some sympathy for this trust
her time in office pretty humiliating
the damage that has been inflicted on
the public through higher prices and
mortgages is considerable this is not a
soap opera these are real lives that are
being impacted by the mess at the top of
the Tory party we are ready to form a
government to stabilize the economy and
Implement a real plan for growth for
living standards to help people through
a cost of living crisis and that's the
choice now a stable labor government or
this utter chaos from the conservatives
okay starmer calling there for a general
election we're not sure about that what
we do know is there is a contest now
next week um what can you tell us about
that just going back to your list of
Runners and Riders there we've not heard
anything from Grant chaps you mentioned
nadeem's a harway one name you didn't
include there who apparently is
considering standing is Brandon Lewis we
have heard from Friends of swella
bravaman who calls a sensationally quit
yesterday amid reports of a 90-minute uh
shouting match with the Prime Minister
over immigration policy her friends are
saying there needs to be a candidate
from the right wing of the party here's
an amusing one Michael fabricant the
colorful should we say conservative mp
uh here's my no longer private and
confidential letter I wrote To Sir
Graham Brady a couple of days back I'm
writing to express my full confidence in
and support for the Prime Minister
that's this trust but if she does resign
the only person to replace her is Boris
Johnson so
um he has his support but as you've been
saying he's such a divisive figure and
there is that standards committee uh uh
inquiry and opposition MPS are making a
lot of that already for example Chris
Bryant who's been pretty vocal the last
24 hours over events in Parliament has
uh tweeted problems with Johnson one
privileges investigation two his poll
ratings with the public rather than the
Tories three ministers who resign can
hardly support him for uh pincher Chris
pincher that is the former deputy chief
whip uh five the advisor on the
ministerial code six he makes unforced
era's time and again seven he lies and
can't help it well labor MPS would say
that wouldn't they but I think the Boris
Johnson possibly entering and one
veterans or EMP
Roberts Sims has said it's fantasy
um it's made the can con contest bit
more interesting hasn't it the
possibility that he might enter the race
yes I think some of those like sir
Graham Brady who want this smooth
transition or a Unity candidate probably
throwing their hands up in the air with
horror at the the thought of Boris
Johnson getting on a plane from the
Caribbean and charging into the contest
with his usual membership
um they love it so Tory parties always
loved a glamorous bomb think about
Margaret Thatcher Michael hesitine right
Boris
Johnson's blonde as well yeah okay well
let's um stop that right there and uh
get a labor view then of um uh Boris
Johnson possibly returning let's talk to
Labor's Shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy thanks very much for being with us
so what would you think
possible Boris Johnson return
look I think that the public are sick of
this pantomime and they want it to end
we cannot have a revolving door of MPS
that think that they're fit to run our
country it's quite wrong it's absolutely
clear that to stabilize our democracy so
the British people can choose a version
of how they want the country to run for
the next five years that we should have
a general election and this sort of
constant revolving door of MPS parading
not to the public but amongst themselves
is entirely unacceptable and it's not
worthy of a G7 Nation a country that has
a seat on the UN Security Council and
frankly a country where so many people
are feeling the burden of high inflation
a cost of living crisis an energy crisis
and now a mortgage crisis all because of
this Reckless government
yeah but you may have to be careful what
you wish for or should have been careful
what you wish for because maybe you'd be
better off with Liz truss limping on
I'm not in politics
simply as a self-serving sort of
individual that cares solely about party
we used to be a country where whatever
your political tradition you cared about
the country first
and that's why of course it's for labor
to put our position which we think is
about a stable country normalized and
without this pantomime to the British
people but in the end it's the people
that must determine this do they really
want someone to return to run our
country with a sleaze uh uh inquiry
hanging over his head who demonstrably
lied to the British people and to
Parliament while many people I'm afraid
experience loss in their own families
was partying in number 10 do we really
want that do we really want anyone who's
been associated with the last 12 years
of the Tories running this country
without actually returning to the people
and asking them what they want at this
extraordinary difficult economic time
that's not the kind of country
well you talk about a mandate but at
least I suppose Boris Johnson could
stand up and argue well I've got one
Boris Johnson I'm afraid uh was kicked
out of office many people resigning from
his cabinet because of the pantomime
that he visited not just on his party
but on this country people died under
his watch while he partied uh his
judgment in relation to a sex pest was
horrendous that's why he left office the
idea that just three months later that
we should return to him this is taking
people for Falls and it demonstrates
frankly a political movement and a party
that's run out of ideas that it really
thinks that you can just do a rerun of
what you had three months ago even
though then you had people resigning
from the cabinet and say we can't
continue to go on like this
so who does labor fear most
look
look what labor wants is the general
election general election whoever
ever comes in as them you're not going
to get a general elections
I can tell you I've been in I've been in
Parliament 22 years
sorry Mark forgive me forgive me he
comes later
forgive me I can't actually see see you
but look
um whoever comes in
will have a divided conservative party
whoever comes in will have different
Visions within that party of how our
country should be run particularly the
economy at this time it's for all of
those reasons that we should allow the
public to determine whether they want to
continue with this chaos or whether they
want something different alternative
stability under labor
and just finally the new reality is that
you need to fix your own plan for the
economy there are obvious new
constraints now that don't give you much
room for maneuver where will you be
cutting spending do you acknowledge that
you will now have to cut spending look
you're quite right we've had too many
budgets without proper fiscal forecasts
from the obr we await that on the 31st
of this month I'm afraid all of the
predictions are that we have the most
enormous amount of borrowing 62 billion
I was seeing perhaps 74 some of that has
been dealt with by Jeremy Hunt let's
wait and see what the obr suggests and
of course
do you acknowledge you will have to cut
spending is that what you're saying now
and until we've seen the forecasts I
can't say but what I would say is that
we are determined to be fiscally
responsible and we've set out very clear
rules that we will only spend what we
receive in tax receipt let us see the
mess that we are being handed in the
event of a general election
okay uh David Lammy thanks very much
indeed I'll pass on your regards to
Derma thank you forgive me but well it
was just after 1 30 this afternoon Liz
truss stood outside here in Downing
Street the same steps where 44 days ago
he played she pledged to deliver deliver
this time though she announced her
resignation she says she came into
office at a time of great International
instability but hers is a Premiership
that will be characterized by infighting
and chaotic u-turns she will likely now
be remembered as the shortest serving
prime minister in British history as
political correspondent Ali Fortune
looks back at her political career
foreign
EST critics will praise a political
skill that led her all the way to
Downing Street we shouldn't be daunted
by the challenges we face
as strong as the storm may be I know
that the British people are stronger
catapulted to number 10 with a mandate
from the membership to challenge a
status quo but a mini budget just two
weeks into the job set in motion and his
truss is downfall
and lost another Tory leader the
confidence of the party I think one of
the potentially early missteps on the
political side was to form an
Administration that was so heavily
weighted to those that were on one side
of the leadership contest and not to
have reached out a bit more to the other
side
Liz truss was politically engaged from a
young age growing up in Glasgow and
Leeds she described her parents as
left-wing at Oxford University she was
even president of the liberal Democrats
there are two main problems with this
amendment conference it was in her late
30s the woman who would become Prime
Minister began to rise through the Tory
ranks she carved out a position on the
right of the party and became a
Grassroots favorite
despite her at times awkward public
appearances
we import two-thirds of our cheese
that is a disgrace
in cabinet she was seen by some as a
troublemaker determined to get her way
some were surprised to see Boris Johnson
promote her to foreign secretary
search began to replace him she made it
onto the final ballot for the leadership
by just eight votes mordant105
sunac one three seven
truss one one three
a path then through the Tory membership
was rarely in doubt
the idea of being stuck in a lift with
care style but strikes being is
extremely boring
it was once she got the job things began
to unravel Liz trusses Premiership
veered off course two days after
becoming the Queen's 15th prime minister
she was confronted by a nation in
mourning
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from Balmoral
when politics eventually did return the
new prime minister was on the back foot
you're prepared to be unpopular aren't
you yes yes I am pushing ahead with a
bold tax cutting agenda blamed for
Market turmoil and political unrest
not going to cut the additional rate of
tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
then unceremoniously sacking her
Chancellor and close friend
quasi-quarting
authority never recovered
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend and he shares my
vision to set this country on the path
to Grace
the man she hoped could steady the
economy and save her Premiership tried
firstly we will reverse almost all the
tax measures announced in the growth
plan three weeks ago that have not
started parliamentary legislation
but that left Liz truss a prime minister
without a purpose as her home secretary
resigned in chaotic scenes emerge from
The Commons last night it became clear
she couldn't hold on
Liz truss came into office at a time of
global instability but hers was a
Premiership characterized by infighting
and u-turns and shall be remembered as
the shortest serving prime minister in
British history Ali volsku Sky News
Westminster
well questions are already flying about
uh about who will need uh next lead the
conservative party earlier we spoke to
the leader of the liberal Democrats at
Davey who said that no matter who takes
over the party is too far gone now to
recover
frankly whether it's Boris Johnson Rishi
sunak or any other conservative MP that
party is now unleadable it's so divided
and the idea of Boris Johnson I think
will send shivers down the spine to many
people he broke the law he lied to
Parliament he's still hasn't finished
the inquiry into his law breaking he's
not fit to government we've known that
for many many a long time and but that's
symptomatic emblematic of the whole
conservative party now you know once
they stood for economic competence and
now they've completely lost that by
trashing the economy
sorry Davey there well the first
minister of Scotland Nicholas sturgeon
has also been reacting to the prime
minister's resignation
in terms of my interactions with lots of
trust you know it is quite absurd I
guess that she has come into office and
left office and there hasn't even been a
phone call to me or to the first
minister of Wales but actually in the
you know the the Realms of political
history list just is going to be a
footnote and you know we need to now
firstly see stability
for the UK and that means undoubtedly a
general election to try to restore some
kind of stability
now is the Fleet Street Fox and Daily
Mirror columnist Susie Boniface and the
Times columnist Rachel Sylvester uh
welcome to you both Rachel first of all
just your reaction to the day's events
extraordinary day you think every day is
the most chaotic and shambolic and then
the next day is even worse and even more
extraordinary
um so Liz trust becoming the shortest
ever prime minister in British history
and proving really that you cannot
govern on the basis of ideological
certainty you have to have a pragmatic
approach you can't Buck the markets you
can't ignore the experts uh you can't
sort of dismiss the economic realities
or what she called treasury Orthodoxy
and also reinforcing the importance of
having a breadth of opinion in the
cabinet and in the party she tried to
bring in some of her opponents and the
leadership contest right at the end but
it was too late she started off on this
very narrow path I thought it was
fascinating there hearing Nicholas
sturgeon pointing out that she hadn't
even received the phone call there was
no attempt to reach out no attempt to
build Bridges either around the United
Kingdom within her own party or across
the country and she's paid the very
heavy price
Susie people were saying it was only a
matter of time and so it has proved
exactly I think it's being predicted uh
by Rachel's colleague Matthew Paris and
at times at the end of August that Liz
truss wasn't going to last very long
said she was crackers and it's just not
going to work uh political journalists
who've known her for a long time have
always said that she's a bit of a hollow
vessel and there doesn't seem to be much
going on in there in terms of principles
and beliefs and things like that and
we've all seen how much she's changed
and you turned and not being able to
stay on one course but it was worth
bearing in mind I think as well that you
know when Theresa May resigned after
having been accused of being robotic and
unemotional and not able to pull her
party together she stood outside Downing
Street and she wept and she showed and
she said that you know it had been the
honor of her life to try to serve her
country and to try her best and whatever
you think about Theresa May I think most
people do accept that she did try her
best in difficult circumstances when Liz
trust resigned on exactly the same spot
she looked to me like she could barely
not giggle she was almost laughing it's
an astonishing contrast she doesn't seem
to have appreciated how important her
job was and how much it affects the life
and death of of 65 million people it
seems to have been a little more than a
game and it's that game unfortunately
which has not only destroyed her party
but is doing a great deal of damage to
the country
and Rachel let's just look ahead then
and the prospect of Boris Johnson
incredible isn't it you know only a few
months ago he was ousted by his party by
his MPS by his own cabinet for rule
breaking and lying breaking the law line
to Parliament or misleading Parliament
he's still under a parliamentary inquiry
on that
um I certainly have had texts from MPS
this afternoon saying that if he's back
they won't they just won't tolerate him
returning as as their leader so the
challenge now for those MPS is to make
sure that Boris Johnson doesn't get on
to any kind of final short list that
goes to the party members uh because
there's an assumption among many people
at Westminster that if he does make it
to that final short list the members are
likely to back him uh and of course it
was the members who brought
um the country and the party Liz truss
uh who was a disaster and that was
against the witches of the MPS
um so there's a lot of uh anxiety among
politicians at Westminster about the
return of Boris Johnson
yeah and Susie I mean these are
remarkable times what do you make of the
prospect or possibility of Boris Johnson
Mark II well it does send a shiver down
the spine a bit you've got to bear in
mind that when the conservatives won
that general election in 2019 it was the
conservative party that got the Mandate
it wasn't Boris Johnson
um it that depends on the leadership of
the party and the person who can command
the confidence of the party is the prime
minister and that's just how it is
constitutionally so it's not possible to
say it should be Boris because he won in
2019. it's also worth bearing in mind
that he lost the lead in the opinion
polls back in November 21 that's when
starma went ahead and labor went ahead
so this is not just the lead that
Labor's got now it's not just this
trust's fault this was something that
was coming anyway because of partygate
and the other problems that Boris
Johnson had in office he's also got in
the first week of November the first
couple of weeks the Privileges committee
which is going to be having hearings
perhaps every single day of the week
four days a week and the idea that he
could be prime minister next week and
then within a fourth night up before the
Privileges committee for lying about
parties in Downing Street which we all
know took place is just astonishing
you've also got an economic statement
which is penciled in at the moment for
October the 31st now how can you
possibly have a new prime minister in
office in a week's time and then only a
week before you go to the markets and
say this is how we're paying for
everything and get all your ministers
and all your cabinet to sign off on that
and do the sums and the office of budget
responsibility as well it can't be done
they have to push that um uh October the
31st fiscal statement back a bit into
November and I think to be honest the
best thing that Tories can do now
they're they're slated to lose at least
10 top cabinet ministers in a general
election if it was held tomorrow and
maybe be down to 138 members lose 200
odd MPS and give labor the massive
bigger than Blair even majority of 273
and the only thing I think that could
save any of those Tory seats now is if
they put a safe Pair of Hands in charge
someone like Ben Wallace or Theresa may
even immediately call a general election
and go to the country have that vote and
perhaps not lose as badly as they would
have done if they'd done it this morning
under Liz truss yeah well that's
interesting just finally Rachel if we're
looking at former Prime Ministers what
about Theresa May
well she's definitely a name you here
mentioned but I think there'll be a
reluctance again to go backwards you
can't kind of reinvent the wheel I think
you always have to go forwards in
politics and I think it would be a
mistake for them to go for either of the
former prime ministers they should
choose a new candidate I think Jeremy
Hunters I understand it has ruled
himself out but will she tsuna or Ben
Wallace will be a better choice in my
opinion uh they need to try and prove
that they're serious that they're stable
that they understand the economic
realities of Life uh and that they're
they're able to be competent and I think
even then as Susie says it'll be pretty
tough for them to win a general election
whenever it comes very tough and then
you know to get that reputation for
economic competence back I think that's
now lost
um you know maybe even for a decade that
Liz trust hasn't just sacrificed her own
Premiership she's also sacrificed their
absolutely crucial
um Tory association with economic
responsibility and competence uh and
then a lot of MPS won't ever forgive her
for that
okay uh very interesting Rachel and uh
Susie thank you both very much indeed
right our Deputy political Sam coats is
still in the central lobby of the houses
of Parliament and I gather Samuel with a
supporter of Rishi sunak
that's right Mark we're digesting the
fact that the prime ministerial ship of
Liz trust lasted a shorter period of
time than the campaign that got her
there 44 days and MP's coming to terms
with what's going to happen next a
contest in the next seven days in order
to replace her I'm joined by Rick Holden
Rick is a backer of Rishi sunac is Rishi
seen that going to run I'm pretty sure
he will I hope so I think he in these
times when we're facing now got horrific
problems uh in the global financial
markets and we need somebody who's got
the experience to deliver real stability
over the next few years and get the ship
of State back on an even kill does he
really really want it because over the
summer it's a bruising leadership
contest we heard from allies afterwards
he wasn't quite sure he would go for it
again because he hadn't enjoyed that
process has he got what it takes I think
he did enjoy it you know I've spoken to
him recently uh you know all those last
few weeks he was saying how he'd really
enjoyed getting out there on the
campaign meeting the members he did so
many events compared to
um to competitors in the campaign and
but I think he's uh is really up for it
and uh I think as I said in these
circumstances we've got to have
competence in the economy at the center
of it I just can't think of anybody
better to deliver for the country in
these times than Michigan did he learn
lessons from his defeat I think
everybody always learns lessons in any
campaign I'm you know what were they do
I didn't I would like I was just going
to say I didn't back Liz but you know
actually I think she's she also you know
would have done things differently and
I'm on a personal level you know I I'm
sad that she's ended up in this
situation so quickly and but I think he
also and looking back now everybody
knows that what you need to do is have a
broad group of people supporting you a
broad group of people coming into
government bringing the party together
and I think Rishi with who got support
from right across the country I've got
the most MP support last time is a
person to do that now because we have to
have that unity and also so competence
and economic leadership right at the top
Penny Morden arguably has the pizzazz at
the dispatch box and ability to puncture
opponents Boris Johnson has the star
quality why isn't Richie seeing that
just the dry accountant candidate I
think what we need is competence right
at the core of this at the moment that's
what's really important
um you know I backed Boris in his
leadership campaign Sam I worked for him
then I think at this moment in time
though what we need is that economy it
is the economy front and center it's
what my constituents want and they're
worried about the energy crisis caused
by Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
and they want to see economic competence
right at the heart of government now so
that they can be secure in their jobs
and you know and also whether they're
small businesses or whether they're
households facing really high pressure
on their bills they want to know that
somebody's going to be behind them and
Rishi was was there all the way through
the uh the coronavirus pandemic and also
with that support early on in the energy
now now if this ends up going to the
membership in an email ballot over
few days next week and Boris Johnson is
one of those names and Boris Johnson is
going to win do you accept that and and
how do you stop that happening if that
case well look we're gonna have to see
what the exact process is we don't know
yet the 1922 committee are currently
meeting is going to be interesting to
see what they come up with uh thresholds
it's going to have to do uh whatever
they're going to do in regards to
membership as well I think we're getting
a bit of ahead of ourselves on that we
don't know who's declared yet across the
board and let's just see when we come to
that but again so that's a really really
important point there you're basically
saying the people drawing up the rules
effectively could end up determining
whether Boris Johnson becomes prime
minister because
if it's up to the membership and he gets
on the ballot and the threshold is low
enough he becomes prime minister again
but but if the rules are different and
perhaps he requires a lot of MPS then
perhaps he doesn't so that 1922
committee meeting this afternoon you
know in the next few hours and those
rules that come out of it well that's
going to determine the course of you
know what happens well the rules of any
election determine the course of it you
know we have a constituency system in
the UK with first Buster post they
determine the outcome of the general
election so of course that's what will
determine it
um but I think really at the moment when
the con you know when I speak to my
constituents uh when I speak to other
members of parliament what we've had a
really tough time over these last few
weeks
um you know I don't think it's gone the
way that you know you know even as
somebody who didn't support Liz I didn't
want it to go the way it's gone and what
we need to see now is competence at the
heart of government and particularly
that economic vision and driving force
because that's what our that's that's
the bread and butter stuff that our
constituents really need right now
finally if it doesn't go your way and it
is Boris Johnson would you unite behind
him absolutely I you know behind anybody
I did I did it with Liz and you know was
delighted when she uh made me come his
PPS uh in the department of
international trade I thought that was
uh very good of her
um and obviously I do not behind anybody
because the truth is that the
conservative parties got to unite
whoever is elected to win the next
general election and I think that's the
conservative party in power is always in
the best interest of the country Rick
holded there saying he would unite
behind anyone but preferably where she's
sunak who he says is the best man for
the job because of his economic
experience Mark
Sam thank you very much indeed so let's
just bring you up to speed with what has
happened here earlier just after half
past one Liz truss resigned as prime
minister after just 44 days in office
she said she recognized that she could
not deliver on her mandate a leadership
election will be completed within a week
we're told is Liz statement in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well there has been International
reaction to Liz truss's resignation
President Joe Biden who was rather rude
about her economic strategy I seem to
remember issued this statement it says
the United States and the United Kingdom
are strong allies and enduring friends
and that fact will never change I thank
prime minister Liz truss for her
partnership on a range of issues
including holding Russia accountable for
its war against Ukraine we will continue
our close cooperation with the UK
government as we work together to meet
the global challenges our nation's face
that there from Joe Biden joining me now
is the conservative MP for some hostel
and uh new keys Steve double thanks very
much for being with us so you wanted her
to go you called for her resignation now
you've got it who should come next
uh well I'm back wish you seen that back
in the summer in the leadership campaign
I think he has demonstrated during that
campaign that he's got what it takes to
be prime minister he's certainly got the
right policies on the uh economy uh
which has to be the priority right now
and I think he can provide the
leadership we need in these very
challenging times so I I hope he will be
on X prime minister
do you worry though about the number of
um those entering this race and the
short time going to be allowed for it
and the mechanism that may be part of
all this do you worry about the week
ahead
um I welcome the fact it's going to be a
quick process I think one of the
problems of the previous contest would
it dragged out for week after week and
was far too long I think we need to get
this done I think the country needs
um clear leadership and stability and
therefore we need a short process in
order to select someone and what's
absolutely vital is whoever wins that
the Parliamentary party then absolutely
unite behind and back whoever the winner
is because that's what our country needs
us to do
would you be able to unite behind Boris
Johnson again
yes if he was to win the contest
um I I would I I served in his
government for three years previously I
actually backed him right up until the
uh the very end
um I was sad to see him go so I'd have
no problem at all in backing and and
getting behind Boris if he was to win
the election
so you've got no problem then
um as others have been expressing this
afternoon you've got no problem again
with him with him standing
if that's what he chooses to do uh you
know and I understand that's not
confirmed yet but that's his choice
clearly if he
thinks he wants to do that and he's got
the support behind him then then he's
perfectly entitled to do so
so I mean whatever happens whoever takes
over you'll be on your what is it third
prime minister in months your fourth
Chancellor within weeks isn't there an
issue here of some sort of democratic
deficit and you should
push for an election or agree agree
concede an election
I don't think so because we have a
parliamentary system in our country
where we elect MPS and constituencies to
form a parliament and the prime minister
is the person that commands the
confidence of the majority of MPS in
Parliament uh are are our mandate is
through the MPS and our mandate is on
the manifesto that we were elected on in
2019 I think one of the problems of the
last few weeks under Liz trust is that
we departed too far away from that
Manifesto and I hope whoever wins the
leadership and becomes prime minister
gets back to delivering on the manifesto
that we were elected on
so how many unelected prime ministers
would it take before you agreed to an
election
well our Constitution doesn't work that
way does it our constitution is a
parliamentary democracy the prime
minister is the person that commands the
the confidence of parliament we've had
many examples over Decades of of
changing prime minister midterm
um you know I I don't think any of us
Pretend This is where we want to be I'm
on my I'm on my fifth prime minister now
since I got elected back in 2015 it's
not where we want to be but it is where
we are and our constitution allows for
it
isn't the truth that given the turmoil
of recent weeks that the Tories have
lost the people they have lost trust in
you as a party
well I I think under his trust that was
true uh but we've now uh you know she
has done the right thing and and stepped
aside we now have the opportunity to
elect someone new and the opportunity to
win back the trust of the British people
by demonstrating to them that we can be
a competent government that we can deal
with the issues that the country is
facing right now and we can provide the
leadership going forward that we
desperately need that's the onus is on
now as a party to back and unite behind
whoever the new leader is and get back
to delivering for the country
and just finally on the issue of unity
and getting behind a leader you're
backing Rishi sunak what are the chances
of unity uh if he was the Prime Minister
there are those who blame him for
forcing out or helping to force out
Boris Johnson and there's the the right
of the party who don't uh want his brand
of Economics what are the chances of
uniting behind Rishi sunac well I think
it's time for every one of us to grow up
and get real about the situation we face
as a as a party
um and I mean I don't accept that
characteristic of Rishi I was in the
whips office last year right up until
the moment when Boris um decided to to
resign
um and that you know that characteristic
of him isn't what I uh what I recognized
you know through all of that time
um he he was Chancellor he got on with
the job of being Chancellor actually the
Tipping Point
um of Boris having to resign was many
Junior ministers resigning
um and then they many of them went
straight back into government under his
trust so you know I I don't think that's
a fair characteristic I think Rishi is
one of the most honorable uh people I've
ever met he has very strong integrity
and I think that's what we need in the
prime minister
all right uh it's a double thank you
very much indeed and uh good to have you
on the program
so another extraordinary day here at
Downing street we will have much more
after this break
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm in zamam Rasheed and I'm Skies north
of England correspondent telling stories
from this culturally Rich region I call
home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
thank you
the Taliban found your family what would
happen I think they're just going to
straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was in the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically safe sales I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Downing Street then on
what has been a pretty eventful
afternoon we now know that a new leader
of the Tory party will be decided by
next Friday but just who are the runners
and riders for the leadership contest
well three of the leadership candidates
who ran in the summer are expected to
run again Penny Morden leader of the
house is expected to be one of the
favorites as is the former Chancellor
Rishi sunak who came second in the
summer to Liz truss in the leadership
race then and kemi badnock the
international trade secretary could also
run
it's also being reported that Liz
truss's predecessor Boris Johnson could
run the times and the telegraph
newspapers are both saying they're
expecting him to go for the leadership
Grant shaft could also run he was made
Home Secretary uh well just hours ago
really that came after suela bravaman
was forced to resign as Home Secretary
she may run two we're told it's rumored
that the Justice secretary and former
chairman of the party Brandon Lewis is
being urged to stand by MPS as could two
of the other leadership candidates in
the summer security minister Tom tugen
Hartley threw his hat in the ring and
the chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
Nadim zahawi may also fancy his chances
well we've been hearing from several MPS
this afternoon some coming out to
publicly praise their choice to be the
next prime minister they have been
speaking to our Deputy political editor
Sam Coates
I wish all the candidates well we need a
truncated process we need to get on with
things but very much hoping that Penny
will stand and I think she would be the
best person to unite our party and lead
the nation I'm not going to lose any
sleepover who ends up being the Prime
Minister as long as it is a team this is
bigger than an individual now we need
every one of those people at the top
table and pulling their weight and
really what we need now we need someone
who can come in we need someone who can
bring people together somebody who
actually has got that mandate so a
mandate from the people at the last
general election a mandate from party
members and somebody actually who can
get this party going again get us
winning elections again the only person
that I think that ticks all those boxes
is Boris Johnson I hope that we won't
have to even run the full week I I'm
hoping that they can all get together
and and come up with it with a team that
will be acceptable as I say some egos
will have to be uh sacrificed in the
National interest and in the interest of
the conservative party frankly I want to
see a government of the talent CEO of
left and right coming together people
who've Got Deep experience back in
cabinet just governing the country for
the best of the country we need an
election winner and we had an election
winner and so as far as I'm concerned
I'll listen to my constituents and their
message was bring back Boris
so they're lining up to support their
man or woman Sky's Chief political
correspondent John Craig joins me now so
I mean the one thing we can say is that
it's a it's a big field it looks like it
yes it depends on the threshold of
course we were reporting earlier on that
Beth Rigby are political editor had
heard it might be as high as 50
nominations to get on the ballot paper
so that would restrict the field
remember Jeremy Hunt who's just been
made the chancellor I think only got 18
votes in the first round the last time
anyway he's ruled himself out this time
um apologies to those who think we're
sort of exaggerating the possibility of
Boris Johnson standing but Chris's hope
of the Daily Telegraph is reporting that
he is in fact flying back to the UK this
weekend apparently reading his WhatsApp
messages while he's on holiday One
Source says he's thanking MPS for their
messages he's enjoying it yeah yes I
imagine he's in loving it and
we know that he's such a divisive figure
he has his
adoring supporters the likes of Nadine
Doris and male MPS as well it has to be
said who'd love to see him come back at
the same time there's some conservatives
who be appalled at the prospects of him
coming back and some are even claiming
that they'd defect to another party or
leave the party stand as Independence or
whatever I mean it is a fact that many
party members whilst that a lot of them
love him and that poll this week
suggested he was more popular than Rishi
sunak or any of the other Rivals the
fact that was a lot of left them left
the party appalled at his conduct over
party gate and Chris pincher I've always
said it was the three p's that did for
uh Boris Johnson
Patterson party gate and pincher
um event three events that he handled
very badly and dishonorably according to
his critics and that was what did for
him in the end uh so uh but it's the if
it's the the mechanism that is decided
in a meeting of the 1422 and the board
yeah yeah that will decide whether it's
likely he can get through is that right
well they will obviously want to decide
on how many nominations you need and so
on uh and how they're going to
presumably will have the same round of
voting by MPS first if they're going to
do it in a week they're perhaps going to
have to have more than one ballot each
day and then of course if it it's all
about who goes to the last two this
system was brought in by William Hague
when he was leader between 97 and 2001
the first time around the Tory members
chose Ian Duncan Smith over Ken Clark so
they've made what you might describe as
controversial choices before
um perhaps the one time when you
arguably they got it right was when
David came camera and beat David Davis
in 2005. David Davis was initially seen
as the front runner but David Cameron
performed very well during the campaign
now critics of the Tory party will say
that the members have got it wrong this
time because Liz truss has manifestly
been a failure out after 44 days but
they will want their say that meeting
that's going on now or at least it
started at four o'clock the mem the
representatives of the members will be
saying the members must have a say they
will not want the MPS just to stitch it
up that's probably why uh there's these
discussions are going on it's why the
party chairman was brought in because it
involves the Party Machine and the
members the one thing we know about the
conservative party uh over recent years
is the division within it and the splits
within it and everybody's been coming on
this program saying what we want is
stability and what we want is Unity is a
leadership election that's going to
unfold next week is that a way to get
you know unity and stability it's
probably not one of the things that
we've noticed since 2019 is that as well
as the Left Right divide amongst
conservative MPS there's very much an
age divide as well you've got the
younger MPS we just heard from Richard
Holden who was being interviewed by Sam
coats a younger Tory MP from the north
of England red wall seat soon act
supporter a lot of the Old Guard the
veteran stories we saw it the other
night when Liz truss went to the
European research group they're veterans
the bill cashes the John redwoods this
the or the Christopher chopes the Edward
Lee's veteran toriapies they're all
right-wingers their view is probably
reflected in the membership who are
predominantly quite elderly as well a
lot of them are are over 65 we know I
think it's 40 over 65. so yes the
party's massively split modernizers
traditionalists right left and an age
divide as well
and on Liz Truss It was inevitable was
it that it would end this way or
inevitable in the last um but it's not
inevitable a month or two ago I mean she
she started off with such great High
Hopes but I think uh the uh the
quasi-kartang budget
um obviously as she acknowledged today
it all went horribly wrong she had to
sack him
um bring in a new Chancellor to try and
steady things well it didn't steady
things as far as for her point of view
from her point of view because she just
absolutely hemorrhaged support amongst
MPS and of course the day she didn't win
a majority of the MPS back in the summer
Rishi sunak did Boris Johnson felt very
hard done by will this trust feel hard
done by these bound to bound to
is my tip
you think they'll probably try and
Stitch it up to keep Boris off the
ballot paper probably but if he gets on
the ballot paper of course oh formidable
but cnx being quite a divisive figure
yes well of course Boris Johnson's
supporters blame him for Boris Johnson
demise uh they claim he stabbed him in
the back when he uh resigned minutes
after uh Sajid Javid yep okay well
that's all to come but today has been
another historic day in Downing Street
Liz truss has resigned she is the
shortest serving British prime minister
in history I'll be back at the top of
the hour with the NewsHour
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
It's Five O'Clock you're watching the
NewsHour live from Downing Street this
evening I'm Mark Austin coming up in the
next 60 minutes
Liz trust resigns as prime minister
after just 44 days in office
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
there will now be a leadership election
within a week Liz truss says she'll
remain as prime minister until a
successor is announced
that will be possible to conduct a
ballot and conclude a leadership
election
by Friday the 28th of October
a former prime minister Boris Johnson is
expected to stand in the contest we'll
bring you all the possible Runners and
Riders as labor calls for an immediate
general election
this would be a general election we
can't just allow the Tory party to keep
putting up the next candidate in the
middle of this chaos
foreign
[Music]
good evening we're live in Downing
Street where earlier this afternoon Liz
truss resigned as prime minister after
just 44 days in the job her successor
will be appointed within a week with
several MPS already positioning
themselves for a fresh leadership
contest among them the former prime
minister Boris Johnson but his trust is
time at number 10 had become
increasingly untenable after her
economic policies sent markets into
turmoil leading to resignations from
ministers questions over the direction
of her government and growing calls from
her own MPS for her to quit here is Liz
truss's statement on the steps of
Downing Street in full
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
well the chair of the 1922 committee Liz
trussa mentioned there confirmed earlier
this afternoon that a new prime minister
will be decided by next Friday here's
what's the Graham Brady said in a
statement outside Parliament
I'll be meeting with the officers of the
22 and the executive later this
afternoon we also have a meeting of the
conservative party board I have spoken
to the party chairman Jake Berry and he
has confirmed that it will be possible
to conduct a ballot and conclude the
leadership election by Friday the 28th
of October so we should have a new
leader in place before the fiscal
statement which will take place on the
31st I'll be able to give you more
details later on this afternoon
square and Brady there so a new leader
of the Tory party and a new prime
minister will be decided by next Friday
but just who are the runners and riders
for this leadership contest well three
of the leadership candidates who ran in
the summer are expected to run again
Penny mordant the leader of the house is
expected to be one of the favorites as
is the former chancellorishi sunak who
came second in the summer to Liz truss
in the race then and kemi badnock the
international trade secretary could also
run it's also being reported that Liz
truss's predecessor Boris Johnson could
run other times in the telegraph are
both saying they're expecting him to go
for the leadership
Grant chaps could also run he was made
Home Secretary only yesterday that came
after suela bravaman was forced to
resign as Home Secretary she may run two
and it's also rumored that the Justice
secretary and former chairman of the
party Brandon Lewis is being urged to
stand by MPS the security minister Tom
tugenhart May throw his hat into the
ring and the chancellor of the duchy of
Lancaster Nadine zahawi may also fancy
his chances
or the labor leader sakistama has
reacted to the prime minister's
resignation and demanded a general
election
what a mess and this is not just a soap
opera at the top of the Tory party is
doing huge damage to our economy and to
the reputation of our country and the
public are paying with higher prices
with higher mortgages so we can't have a
revolving door of chaos we can't have
another experiment at the top of the
Tory party that is an alternative and
that's a stable labor government and the
public are entitled to have their say
and that's why there should be a general
election some sympathy for Liz trust her
time in office pretty humiliating the
damage that has been inflicted on the
public through higher prices and
mortgages is considerable this is not a
soap opera these are real lives that are
being impacted by the mess at the top of
the Tory party we are ready to form a
government to stabilize the economy and
Implement a real plan for growth for
living standards to help people through
a cost of living crisis and that's the
choice now a stable labor government or
this utter chaos from the conservatives
there we are kissed armor calling for a
general election there our political
correspondent Ali Fortescue joins me now
so when it was done it was done quickly
yeah it was I mean it was pretty obvious
I think in the last 24 hours that Liz
trust was not going to cling on she was
trying to hold the various factions in
the party together which is obviously
incredibly weak and I mean this time a
week ago quasi-quarting was a chance to
sort of braveman was a Home Secretary
everything has changed since then it is
actually quite hard to comprehend the
scale of what has happened in the last
seven days and she is another the
shortest Southern prime minister in
British history the last one George
canning in the 19th century died in
office and he was in for more than 100
days so it's a short downfall a short
Premiership and a short speech he made
outside here just 44 days that she made
her speech when she arrived see that was
the last seven days what about the next
seven days okay so another Tory
leadership contest you were going
through some of the runners and Riders
there I mean I was in Parliament this
morning and what was very clear is there
is no consensus and it feels like some
of those some of those um that people
are becoming more entrenched I think in
in their positions in who they're
backing I mean I spoke to one Ally of
Grant Schatz who says that he might
throw Rose hat in the ring we know
that's well abravement potentially is
thinking about it we know that Boris
Johnson's name has been reported already
people like Brendan Clark Smith I'm
saying that they'd back him so we we've
seen all the names of course Rishi sunak
and Penny Morden seem to be the favorite
with The Bookies at the moment but I
think don't underestimate
um the the mood of the people that
didn't back for example Rishi sunak I
think there is a a real sort of
anti-richy sunak campaign going on as
well some people I spoke to in
Parliament today saying it can't
possibly be him he's not the unity
candidate Theresa May was tweeting
earlier saying that they need to find a
compromise
from the soundings I was getting in
there this morning it doesn't seem like
they're there yet I think what will
matter and what we might get more
clarity on in the next hour or so is the
threshold and how exactly the rules will
work for this what will be a very quick
leadership contest so it's possible we
could be looking at another week of
turmoil yes
we'll be sorted out in the next week or
so but the splits are not going to go
away
from what I was the conversations I was
having this morning it's hard to see I
mean you never know of course labor as
you you heard there calling for a
general election Tories want to see a
quick smooth transition they want
someone to come and command The
Authority but
they all have different views on who
that person should be and it's not clear
that they're going to find someone they
all agree on okay Ali for now thank you
very much indeed let's just get the
views then of the first minister of
Wales Mark Drakeford uh welcome to the
program thank you very much indeed who
would you like to see taking over from
Liz Trust
well I have no View at all on who the
conservative party should choose as
their leader but I do believe that the
conservative party is ungovernable and
whoever is selected will simply find
that there will be new factions inside
the party more determined to do them
done than any other political purpose
they will have
Britain deserves better than this we all
deserve better than this which is why
Kia stama is absolutely right but the
only way to have a fresh start that we
need is to have a general election as I
hope a labor government has a result
how are you going to get that general
election the Tories don't seem in the
mood to go to the country now
well I think they what their Authority
is completely collapsed and I think that
whoever the elect of their next leader
will simply have on their hands exactly
the same problem as their more recent
leaders have had but if you can appeal
to one part of the conservative party
that guarantees
deep enmity towards you from other
factions within the same party they no
longer fit or able to govern they should
recognize that they surely are people in
the conservative party who believe that
the interests of a country are more
important than the short-term interests
of their own party
they should put their case to the
country and let's see who wins
but I'm just confused as you how you're
going to bring about this election if
the conservatives are set against Going
to the Country how do you and labor the
SMP how do you bring about the lib Dems
how do you bring about this election you
also want so clearly well you're you're
right of course opposition parties do
not have the votes on their own to see
an end uh to this Parliament a
parliament whose course has run and has
created enormous damage in the lives of
people in Wales and to the reputation of
the United Kingdom abroad I simply think
that we cannot we simply cannot go on
with a series of
traumas inside the conservative party
creating the damage in the lives of
other people they should recognize that
if they're confident in their case take
it to the country in an election and
let's see but there is a new government
with a fresh mandate and an opportunity
therefore to deal with the enormous
problems that lie ahead of whoever is in
government
and what about this growing suggestion
uh Mr Drakeford that Boris Johnson could
uh stand in this leadership contest
well that will be for the conservative
party to decide uh it's only a matter of
months ago but nearly 16 ministers in Mr
Johnson's last government decided that
he could not be trusted to tell the
troops to such an extent that they were
prepared to serve under him does anybody
believe but all that has simply gone
away in a few short months
uh but someone was making the argument a
little earlier that at least Boris
Johnson could argue in a way that he has
a mandate
well when he had a mandate that Heath
returns a wedding and uh you know he
destroyed Amanda mandate he had because
of his own conduct in office and because
he's not out of the woods even on that
point because there is a House of
Commons inquiry into whether he failed
to tell the truth to the House of
Commons uh anybody who thinks to the
return to Boris Johnson is somehow a get
out the jail card for the conservative
party must have some of the shortest
memories in political history
okay Mark drapered appreciate your time
thanks for coming on
thank you
so questions are already flying about as
to who will lead the conservative party
earlier we spoke to the leader of the
liberal Democrats Ed Davey who said that
no matter who takes over the party was
too far gone to recover
frankly with this Boris Johnson Rishi
sunak or any other conservative MP that
party is now unleadable it's so divided
and the irony of Boris Johnson I think
will send shivers down the spine to many
people he broke the law he lied to
Parliament he's still hasn't finished
the inquiry into his law breaking he's
not fit to government we've known that
for many many a long time and but that's
symptomatic emblematic of the whole
conservative party now you know once
they stood for economic competence and
now they've completely lost that by
trashing the economy
sorry David there well the first
minister of Scotland Nicholas sturgeon
has also been reacting to the prime
minister's resignation
in terms of my interactions with us
trust you know it is quite absurd I
guess that she has come into office and
left office and there hasn't even been a
phone call to me or to the foreign
minister of Wales but actually in the
you know the the Realms of political
history let's just is going to be a
footnote and you know we need to know
firstly see stability
for the UK and that means undoubtedly a
general election to try to restore some
kind of stability
take a sturgeon there will joining me
now is the former number 10 director of
communications under David Cameron sir
Craig Oliver uh welcome uh Craig and
we've spoken a number of times during
the turmoil of the last few weeks what
do you make of today's events
look I think it was bowing to the
inevitable last night when there was
just so much chaos I think it just
became impossible to make the defense
that she could continue in office and I
think that today was inevitable the MPS
were just clearly making clear to Liz
trust that they simply can't continue
what is concerning I think for the
conservative party is that we still
don't have a clear picture of who our
next prime minister is going to be and
there's a real danger that over the next
week that there continues to be chaos
there continues to be arguments um and
it looks like a deeply fractured party
that is not really paying attention to
the crises that are facing the country
at the moment
so do you think they should have got
together and sorted out a Unity
candidate before Liz truss walked out
and resigned
well look everything's for the best and
the best of all possible worlds but
actually in reality nobody was going to
stand down and I think that that's
what's been clear is there are people
here who think that they could be prime
minister and why should they let that go
um also Boris Johnson entering into The
Fray here I think a lot of people don't
really understand quite how many people
in the conservative party feel that he
was kicked out unfairly he had the
Mandate he's the election winner and he
should be there others are deeply deeply
concerned that somebody who had to leave
because they were considered to have had
a whole certain series of propriety
issues brought a whole series of
problems and by the way as Ed Davey was
just making clear there Parliament is
still investigating that is this a sign
of a party that gets what's going on at
the moment or is it actually more
interested in bitter in fighting
I guess the very least that Boris
Johnson who we think is returning from
holiday the least that he can do is
cause some Mischief because he felt sort
of hard done by didn't he
he did and I think that a lot of people
who've been in the conservative party
for a long time will be deeply concerned
look that this has gone beyond being
about individuals and whether or not
they feel heard it's actually a major
issue for their party but more
importantly a major issue for the
country this is a country that is facing
very very serious problems with its
economy at the moment we've seen the
troubles on the markets over the last
couple of weeks but also with energy
crises a huge um backlog in the NHS many
many problems that are coming this
winter and the danger I think for the
conservative party at the moment is that
the longer this goes on the longer that
they look like they're Naval gazing and
fighting among themselves the more that
they will melt down in terms of their
popular opinion poll with the public and
the danger is it will take many many
years to come back from that
well that is the point isn't it because
this is about people who are going
through this cost of living crisis
people whose mortgages have uh shot up
Suddenly because of you know what the
Tory party in part because of what the
Tory party has done I mean do you think
that they will
um take this out on the Tory party at
the next election do you think they've
given up on trusting the Tory party
look I think you can never say never in
politics and we live incredibly volatile
times a huge thing changes have happened
in the last year it's not that long ago
since the labor party was trying to
persuade us to vote for Jeremy corbyn
it's not like long ago that Boris
Johnson was leader of the party and
people were openly speculating about
could he win three even four elections
and he was out within a year so politics
is incredibly volatile having said that
I think all the indicators are that
barring something miraculous the
conservative party is heading for a real
kicking in the next general election and
the longer they allow a situation to go
on where there is chaos where it looks
like you're in fighting where it looks
like people are more concerned about
their own careers than they are about
the country that is a real existential
danger for the conservative party I
think a lot of MPS really get that when
we saw people like back benches like
Charles Walker come out I think he spoke
for a silent majority who are deeply
concerned about this but there will be
that that group will be deeply worried
about what will happen over the next
week and how not even portray itself and
what it will look like
yeah okay uh Craig thank you very much
good to talk to you thank you
right we'll have much more from Downing
Street much more from Westminster you
can see there another uh well remarkable
day of politics in this country and
we'll have more reaction as I say after
the break
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Rasheed and I'm Skies north of England
correspondent telling stories from this
culturally Rich region I call home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
if the Taliban found your family what
would happen I think they're just going
to straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was on the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically sick so I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force through doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well if you want to know what the day
has been like it went like this just
after 1 30 this afternoon Liz trust
stood on the steps of Downing Street
same steps where 44 days ago she pledged
to deliver deliver this time though she
announced her resignation she says she
came into office at a time of great
International instability but hers is a
Premiership that will be characterized
by infighting and chaotic u-turns she
will likely now be remembered as the
shortest serving prime minister in
British history as a political
correspondent Ali Fortescue looks back
at her political career
foreign
EST critics will praise a political
skill that led her all the way to
Downing Street we shouldn't be daunted
by the challenges we face
as strong as the storm may be I know
that the British people are stronger
catapulted to number 10 with a mandate
from the membership to challenge a
status quo but a mini budget just two
weeks into the job set in motion Liz
truss's downfall
and lost another Tory leader the
confidence of the party I think one of
the potentially early missteps on the
political side was to form an
Administration that was so heavily
weighted to those that were on one side
of the leadership contest and not to
have reached out a bit more to the other
side Liz Strauss was politically engaged
from a young age growing up in Glasgow
and Leeds she described her parents as
left-wing at Oxford University she was
even president of the liberal Democrats
there are two main problems with this
amendment conference it was in her late
30s the woman who would become Prime
Minister began to rise through the Tory
ranks she carved out a position on the
right of the party and became a
Grassroots favorite
despite her at times awkward public
appearances
we import two-thirds of our cheese
that is a disgrace
in cabinet she was seen by some as a
troublemaker determined to get her way
some were surprised to see Boris Johnson
promote her to foreign secretary
research began to replace him she made
it onto the final ballot for the
leadership by just eight votes
mordant105
sunac one three seven
truss one one three
a path then through the Tory membership
was rarely in doubt
completely the idea of being stuck in a
lift with care Style with strikes being
extremely boring
it was once she got the job things began
to unravel his trusses Premiership
veered off course two days after
becoming the Queen's 15th prime minister
she was confronted by a nation in
mourning
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from Balmoral
when politics eventually did return the
new prime minister was on the back foot
you're prepared to be unpopular aren't
you yes yes I am pushing ahead with a
bold tax cutting agenda blamed for
Market turmoil and political unrest
I'm not going to cut the additional rate
of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
then unceremoniously sacking her
Chancellor and close friend
quasi-quarting is crazy quieting should
list trust resign the authority never
recovered
I met the former Chancellor earlier
today
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend and he shares my
vision to set this country on the path
to Grace
the man she hoped could steady the
economy and save her Premiership tried
firstly we will reverse almost all the
tax measures announced in the growth
plan three weeks ago that have not
started parliamentary legislation
but that left Liz truss a prime minister
without a purpose as her home secretary
resigned in chaotic scenes emerge from
The Commons last night it became clear
she couldn't hold on
Liz truss came into office at a time of
global instability but hers was a
Premiership characterized by infighting
and u-turns and shall be remembered as
the shortest serving prime minister in
British history Ali faulsku Sky News
Westminster
and Ali who compiled that report is here
with me and I mean by any standards it's
a pretty extraordinary political career
yeah it's it's not going to go down in
history as one of the great tenures I
don't think I think this was a
Premiership as I was saying that will be
characterized by the extraordinary
infighting the chaos we've seen in the
last 44 days someone that had to
completely row back on the economic
Vision that she was elected on someone
that had to sack her Chancellor just a
month in someone that lost her home
secretary it's become really clear in
the last 24 hours that she wasn't going
to be able to hold this party together I
guess the question now is who will be
able to do that but you know Liz truss
came out here and said Glo there'd been
Global instability it is a really
difficult time it's a difficult time to
be a prime minister but I don't think
anyone would say that she did well but
what the Tories have got to get their
head around is that two prime ministers
in succession have
you know basically
their premierships have ended and it's
been self-inflicted both times yeah and
I think the Tories now have a problem
because you know Boris Johnson was the
one that got them that big mandate they
rolled the dice with Liz truss and they
know that those calls for a general
election are getting louder and louder
and there's polling that suggests that's
what the public want to I spoke to a few
Tory members members earlier um sorry
Tory voters rather who say they've been
lifelong Tory voters they won't vote
Tori again the the poles are going in
One Direction so of course the
government won't want to have a general
election I spoke to any Tory MPS who say
yes we should have a general election I
haven't well I I I've spoken to three
MPS that are certainly pretty
disillusioned and one person I spoke to
said that if Boris Johnson's name does
end up on the ballot they will defect to
labor so I think that it's it's can't
overestimate the strength of feeling
among some Tories
um I haven't spoken to anyone that said
they want to see a general election I
mean it would be Madness given the state
of the polls right now at the Electoral
suicide but there are there is a great
strength of feeling and as I say you
know I I was chatting to MPS this
morning there is no clear consensus at
all on who should be the next prime
minister and it feels like people are
getting increasingly entrenched in their
camps but we are expecting at some stage
um the Tory party to set out in more
detail the mechanism
um you know what what is the process
going to be do you think so this is
really important so we understand that
this is all going to happen very quickly
by next Friday there will be a new
leader of the conservative party
um we don't know exactly how it's going
to work we're going to find that out
very soon what could happen is that MPS
Whittle down to a final two by Monday
this is an idea that's been suggested
we haven't confirmed this yet and by the
end of next week the members vote
the one of the big questions I think is
the threshold how many MPS have to back
a candidate for them to become Prime
Minister there's some talk that they
could make the threshold pretty high so
that for example if Boris Johnson did
want to run he wouldn't end up on the
final ballot because it's pretty clear
if he got put to the membership he would
win I mean last time around the numbers
were Rishi sunak 137 votes for MPS he
was a pretty clear front runner
throughout that part of the ballot Liz
truss okay I'm going to interrupt you
we're going to go straight over to uh
Instagram Brady who is speaking
will close at two o'clock on Monday
candidates will be expected
and we if we reach
es
I don't know whether you made anything
of that but I certainly didn't but we'll
find out what Graham Brady is saying and
what he's planning uh just as uh as soon
as we can well that's a shame but we
will try and get a feed of what togra
and Brady are saying but he's in a very
difficult position isn't he yeah I heard
something there about 2PM on Monday I
think but I didn't quite hear what is
happening at 2PM on Monday
um hang on we might be able to let's see
if we've got a better
um sound on this now let's have a listen
online vote of conservative party
members to choose its next Legion all
stages of the leadership election will
be concluded by no later than Friday the
28th of October
before the vote of members is concluded
cchq will be working with media Outlets
to ensure that we can have one broadcast
event so members can hear from the final
two candidates so Graham and I are ready
to take a few questions if you can
indicate
uh which one of us you'd like to answer
it'd be quite helpful wouldn't it to
grow can we start with buff Ruby Jake
Barry you're the conservative
conserved chair this you have to agree
in terms of a governing party is a
terrible State of Affairs the public
will be looking at you thinking can
these guys can these men and women
govern what's your message to the public
and ideally would you like just one
Unity candidate to come through
that fits up to the members of
parliament uh who will be standing about
whether we have one or two candidates my
job as conservative party chairman is to
ensure that if there are two candidates
in a rapid way acting in the national
interests or membership can make their
views known
my message is that we will we have acted
quickly we will continue to act quickly
to ensure that this country has the
stability it requires yes
um kind of to both of you really are you
stitching up the rules here to keep
Boris Johnson off the ballot and would
you be quite happy with one person going
forward and no membership stage we've
fixed a high threshold but a threshold
that should be achievable by any serious
candidate who has a realistic Prospect
of going through a threshold of 100
members of parliament nominating a
candidate obviously allows for three
candidates potentially to come forward
we clearly have no say or no knowledge
of who those candidates will be at this
point and are you are you happy for it
to be one person and not go to the
members I know it's a matter of for
Graham and the 1922 Committee in the
process they are running in terms of our
membership we want to ensure that if
there are two candidates that come
forward the members will have their
final say yes
make sure the online voting system is
we will take for reasons I'm sure we
understand we are satisfied with the
online voting system will be secure all
efforts will be made including
outreached members for who we go to have
an email address or members who are
enable to vote online
meant to be any hustings between the
candidates before they go on before MPS
there will be a house things on on
Monday uh once the nomination closed Mr
Barry this party this is
if conditional so much in that statement
as to whether or not it is one or two
candidates or three candidates to go
forward on Monday does this mean if
there is one candidate who meets this
threshold on Monday Monday is the day
the nation gets its new prime minister
would you like to take this opportunity
to urge the candidates not to drop out
if they make the final two to make sure
that the members of your party aren't
disenfranchised
um that is a matter for the process that
Graham is running
um if there are two candidates we will
ensure that every member has the
opportunity to vote thank you
if there is only one candidate there
will be no confirmatory vote of
conservative party members thank you
thank you thank you thank you
so there are all sorts of questions but
basically nominations by Monday uh
decision by uh Friday and the membership
will get a say Ali Fortis who is uh with
me here so things are a little clearer
now yeah a little clearer I mean we must
have been
a big Android
appeased about them by Monday that's a
pretty high threshold I mean if you look
back last time around richest United got
130 plus uh Liz truss got over 100 penny
more than I think got just over 100 yeah
105 Penny wardens so it's it's a
threshold that a few a few of them could
potentially reach
um then we understand it will go to the
members and all of this will be wrapped
up by next Friday and you had enough
Monday I mean someone I think it was
making a point that you know it could be
done by Monday if if there's someone
with the if MPS can coalesce around one
person then this could all be done by
Monday it could end up being that it
doesn't go to the membership there are
some MPS that want to see that happen
they think that membership picked badly
last time but I think inevitably if they
didn't pick the person that you were
backing you are going to think that so I
think someone please do want to make
sure that they get it right obviously
this time they know that this is their
last chance they're not going to be able
to go through another prime minister as
quickly and that's Rigby making the
point there that uh what will the public
make of this but because you know they
will be watching this and she sort of
hinted at they'll be looking at this
chaos of the last few days and what was
the message to the the public it's very
difficult for the conservative party all
this yeah I mean right now their chances
of electoral success are pretty bad it
is very clear that labor Riding High in
the polls it's no wonder that neighbor
live Dems and SNP all want to see a
general election right now but whoever
becomes the next prime minister would be
pretty mad to do that straight away it's
unlikely that they will do that I think
what they'll hope is that they can try
to find some sort of unity try to bring
this party together and hope that by the
time we get to an election potentially
yeah spring next year maybe even Autumn
um they may have recovered some of their
ground in the polls okay uh thanks very
much for now Ali joining me now is the
labor Deputy leader Angela Rayner who is
in Westminster uh thanks very much for
being with us so what do you make of the
events of the day
I mean it's utter chaos and looking at
the 1922 committee there they look like
rabbits in their headlights they haven't
got a clue what they're doing and the
scary thing is we could have a situation
where we have a prime minister of this
country with zero Monday I mean it's
pretty clear they've lost the confidence
of the British public
and they just don't have a clue what
they're doing they've got no plan no
leader and they they're trying to cling
on to power like somehow being the Prime
Minister forming a cabinet is some sort
of game for them when the rest of the
country are praying paying the price for
it it makes me kind of really frustrated
and angry because people's lives have
been affected by their silly little
games and I just cannot believe the
absurdity of what we're seeing and what
we're witnessing
uh but uh the conservative party rules
are conservative party rules you you it
doesn't look at least like you're going
to get your election
I mean you say conservative party rules
to their rules but as you were saying
before I don't even think they trust
their membership at the moment and it
seems to me like they're going around uh
trying to make it up as they go along to
say nothing to see here and try and just
drag any old MP who they're willing to
put in front of the people and say this
is who we've got for you running scared
of a general election because they know
that the public are the real ones who
should be deciding how the future of
this country is governed because they've
lost the will of the people and the
confidence now because he crashed our
economy they've ripped up the manifesto
that they stood on and they've done more
u-turns than a cul-de-sac I mean it's
embarrassing not just here but also
abroad to see the Fiasco the chaos that
we're witnessing at the moment and they
need to put the country first and not
the party first and they need the
general election and a mandate
but you might be coming up against Boris
Johnson again
I mean that in itself I find absolutely
absurd their own MPS finally got rid of
Boris Johnson after he'd lied to the
British people broke the rules chaos
sleaze Scandal that engulfed that Boris
Johnson's leadership and now all of a
sudden they think that's going to save
the country people haven't forgotten
what happened during the pandemic the
fact that Downing Street became the
worst offenders for breaking the rules
of any other address in the UK when
people weren't able to see their loved
ones if that's their solution to this
problem then they're going to get even
more font at a general election because
the British public do not like being
taken for Falls
but isn't the one thing we've learned
from this chaos is the nature of the
fiscal whole of the black hole and and
isn't that
um proof that you really need to fix
your own plan for the economy and do you
accept that you're going to have to look
at spending cuts
well we've been very clear that we'd set
out our plan which would our fiscal
rules would mean there'd be no
expenditure without showing where that
money would come from so for example
even though that mini budget has pretty
much been ripped apart and you turned on
there is still the lift on the the cap
on Bankers bonuses when ordinary working
people are facing the squeeze we've said
that we'd end the charitable status of
school so that we could give children
free School meals we've said that we
deal with non-dom status so that we can
get more doctors and nurses in our NHS
we've got a plan we said that we'd put a
levy on a windfall tax on the Energy
company so we're not putting it on the
national debt we have a fiscal plan for
growth in this country
sorry to interrupt but with the level of
spending in that plan survive contact
with the with the markets
well as I've just suggested to you and I
think that you know it was the CEO of
Tesco recently that said the labor party
is the only team on the field with a
plan for growth at the moment we set out
so far as we can what our plan is and
we've made it very clear to the British
public we would not put any spending
plans forward that is not economically
sound that we would make sure that
people can see where the money's coming
from and we've not even had an obr
forecast or the ons on the latest U-turn
from the conservatives so nobody knows
whether their plan is in any way
fiscally sound now even with the u-turns
because we've not had that independent
scrutiny of what they've come up with it
is a company but we are getting in it
yeah we are getting an obr statement uh
at the end of uh October oh yeah but we
had that we had the statement last week
and we've still not had that statement
independent scrutiny of their plans it's
a mess all right Angela Arena
um gotta leave it there thank you very
much indeed now we uh
um had a little problem with the sound
with that's Graham Brady and we couldn't
quite make out what he was saying on a
very important issue which is the
process that will take place in the next
seven days to find a replacement for
lystra so let's just have a listen now
to what segre and Brady were saying
thank you very much good afternoon again
uh just to confirm I've met with the
board of the conservative party and the
executive of the United super committee
we've agreed the process as I indicated
earlier it will conclude by Friday the
28th of October the process for the
Parliamentary stages of the contest will
begin now nominations are now open we'll
close at two o'clock on Monday
candidates will be expected to have at
least 100
colleagues nominating them nominations
can be accepted either by signature or
by email we will then go on to conduct
whatever ballots are necessary during
the course of Monday
and when we reach two final candidates
we will also conduct an indicative
ballot works so that it is clear what
the balance or preference within the
Parliamentary party is and I'm going to
hand over to the party chairman to talk
about the members stages
good afternoon the board of the
conservative party met at four o'clock
today and in conjunction with the 1922
committee we have decided that if the
party should decide to put forward two
candidates there will be an expedited
binding online vote of conservative
party members to choose its next Legion
all stages of the leadership election
will be concluded by no later than
Friday the 28th of October
before the vote of members is concluded
cchq will be working with media Outlets
to ensure that we can have one broadcast
event so members can hear from the final
two candidates so Graham and I are
essentially their nominations by Monday
decision hopefully they say by the end
of next week joining me now is the
former conservative Minister Anna subri
and welcome to you and just your
thoughts on the last where do we start
24 hours 48 hours the day's events
look it it's it's Dreadful it's a Chaos
on a scale that we've never seen before
and one of the great political parties
um in the world is now absolutely in the
most appalling of messes but it goes
further than that I think that the
conservative party has shown that it is
unfit to govern we can't trust them
anymore
Boris Johnson was bad enough he left of
course in disgrace it wasn't a policy
Fallout that led to his departure he led
in disgrace but all the reasons which
have been well rehearsed notably by
Angela Rayner just recent just in your
last interview
and it's like we gave them one last
chance and we said okay try you know
come up with a new leader a new prime
minister who can do the right thing by
the country and put some stability and
perhaps some competency Unfortunately
they came up with this trust
and they knew what they were getting the
Parliamentary party but nevertheless
they put her forward to the membership
they know the state of the membership
it's been infiltrated and so on and so
forth and of course she's proved to be
one of the worst Prime Ministers well
probably second only to Boris Johnson if
not on an equal footing because she's
just unfortunately was just not up for
the job the mini budget and so on and so
forth and she's gone in these appalling
circumstances in absolute chaos and they
can't be trusted again they can't even
settle on the obvious replacement for
trust which is the guy who came second
that's how divided they are and that's
why the only way through the chaos is to
go to the British people and have a
general election
yeah but you say that Boris Johnson was
bad enough but I mean there's the
prospect at least of Boris Johnson
standing again a return of Boris Johnson
just the fact that the conservative
party is even considering such an
outrageous thing speaks volumes about
the conservative party the stated it is
in I mean you know I am obviously old
enough to remember 20 30 40 years ago
obviously more were given my age but I
have never known and so many of your
viewers will never have known such a
spectacular lack of talent and ability
at the top of the conservative party
and the thought this party is in such a
terrible State having booted that man
out that we can now see that's there are
there's a significant number that
actually think he might come back
says it all it really said where is it
he's on holiday in the Caribbean
that also says everything you need to
know about Boris Johnson and his
commitment to the people of this country
okay well we understand he may be on his
way back but anyway uh honestly we
appreciate your time thanks very much
indeed
joining me now is a former civil servant
and author uh Caroline slocock thanks
for being with us actually it's an
interesting point
um Civil Service White Hall I mean what
on Earth will they be making of what's
going on will much be getting done while
all this is is going on
well I think inside number 10 there'll
be probably uh amongst the political
appointments uh a massive shock because
they'll be losing their jobs they'll be
leaving with his trusts and I think that
uh even the civil servants will
um be struggling with the enormously of
today's events but they will also be
turning their minds very very fast
to the challenge of briefing and
incoming prime minister who as you
realize will have to make some decisions
on this uh not sure what we call it but
this fiscal events uh at Halloween if
that's still going to run to that
timetable massive decisions to take a
huge political moment as well as very
grave importance for the country and
very very little time to absorb that or
discuss it so the civil servants will be
doing what they can to sort that out
and you know I'm sorry to interact but
just on the rest of the
um government agenda as it was and you
know as it is we will much be getting
done the public will be watching this
and thinking it's all about the
politicians it's all about pushing for
um becoming prime minister uh but things
need to get done in government
well you know the other kind of
implication of this trust is resignation
which I think is very welcome by the way
is that
um there'll be a cabinet reshuffle many
of the cabinet well almost all of the
cabinet ministers are completely
inexperienced in their brief uh people
were kicked out who actually had been
running those departments for years who
actually knew what the issues were had
the relationships with the civil
servants and others
um and so you know that
the Departments are unable to make um
progress on some critical areas until
those new appointments are made and they
knew who know who their new secretary of
state will be so this is a paralysis and
and obviously that you know there are
major issues affecting uh people right
across the country the NHS social care
lots of others but I think it's also a
paralysis for the country as a whole I
think it's very easy to sort of think
this is all about Westminster but really
um this has caused a lot of damage what
what this truss has done as prime
minister has caused a lot of damage to
the confidence in our economy and people
will not know you know what's going to
happen to their personal finances
business will not know what's going to
you know what's coming their way in
terms of okay regulations and so forth
so it's a big
it's a big it's a big change yeah okay
well listen thank you so much for um
giving us your view appreciate your time
well our political correspondent Amanda
acass joins me now from uh Central Lobby
and I gather you've got a member of the
22 committee with you
yes indeed so we've just been hearing
from Sir gray and Brady more details
about how the contest is going to work
with a high bar of a hundred MPS having
to nominate their chosen candidate for
the leadership obviously if we're going
to get someone in by just over a week's
time it's going to have to progress very
quickly I'm joined Now by Richard Graham
who is the conservative MP for
Gloucester and who is a member of both
the 1922 committee and the conservative
party board first of all can you just
explain to us your role in coming to
these decisions about how the process is
going to work so there are two bits to
it Amanda one of which is the 22
committee deciding how the bid in
Parliament works and then the other bit
is the party board deciding how it's
going to work for the party members and
the two came together this afternoon and
agreement has been reached the process
is there Graham and Jake Berry have
announced the the outline details of how
it's going to work and yes it will all
happen here on Monday by Monday evening
it will be all over as far as the
Parliamentary bits concern it's
obviously a very different time scale
from what we saw over the summer was
their Unity over that decision complete
unity in fact unanimity not a single
member of the party board so all the
different voluntary elements all agreed
on all the ingredients that were
discussed it was very quick meeting
100 mp
of a nomination that's obviously quite a
high bar are you hoping that actually
there'll just be one candidate that goes
to the membership
I think there'll be more than one and
and you could in theory have three
um
but obviously if
everybody came together and just
supported one candidate then that makes
everything simpler but I don't think
that'll happen
and in terms of going to the members
they're likely to be voting online
um how confident you about how that
process is going to work so I think if
there are two candidates and it comes to
an online vote by the party members
which will be done on Friday and all
over by Friday afternoon
I I suspect that will be relatively
straightforward because we've done it in
a sense not that long ago and a very
high percentage of members emails are
already there we've got a very good
secure operator to run that process for
us so I'm fairly confident that that
will go smoothly now previously you
supported Jeremy Hunt for the leadership
then Rishi sunak who are you looking at
now
well I supported Jeremy Hunt in 2019 and
Rishi sunak earlier this year so I got a
track record of backing the losing
candidate so it's probably the safest
thing for the person that I back this
time that I don't reveal who I'm
supporting so we'll have to see uh who
the candidates are but Jeremy Hunt has
specifically ruled himself out I think
he's doing a wonderful job as our new
Chancellor stabilizing things reassuring
the markets and helping my constituents
get a feeling for lower mortgage rates
so that's very good and I hope very much
that he stays in place now we wait see
really who coalesces around which
candidate
have you heard from Rishi sunak do you
know what the uh the feeling what would
you say the feeling is in the party
around him obviously came second last
time but very divisive seen as having
stabbed Boris Johnson in the back well I
haven't spoken to him today now I've
been in in meetings pretty well or in
the chamber pretty well all today but I
spoke to him yesterday uh Rishi is in a
very good space he's completely resisted
the temptation to say uh you know that
he was right and he's got a lot of
credentials for this job lovely thank
you for Richard Graham there from the
1922 and the conservative party Port
Amanda thank you very much indeed and we
leave you with pictures of Westminster
another remarkable day here and we'll
have much more at the top of the hour
[Music]
[Music]
thank you